GOOD AFTERNOON.
THIS WILL BEGIN OUR FIFTH
HEARING OF SOMEONE ON THE
ASSEMBLY I'D LIKE TO INVITE THE
FIRST PANEL UP FRONT
.
WILL FIRST HEAR FROM DIRECTOR
LIGHT BORN SCOTT GRAVES FOLLOWED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA ON
ISSUES ONE ENDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHARRON BELOW HOMES TO HARPER
ALONE WILL LIKE BORN DIRECTOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES.
THE FIRST ITEM OF COURSE ON OUR.
PRINT A BUDGET PRESENTATION
TODAY IS THE.
SS I SS PEOPLE GRAHAM MRS CORSI
CORE PART OF THE STATE'S.
ARM SAFETY NET.
SYSTEM.
AND.
TO.
TAKE YOU THROUGH SERVE A HIGH
LEVEL OF THE DETAILED PROGRAM.
MOMENT GOING TO TURN OVER TO
DEBBIE THOMPSON OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR ADULT PROGRAMS.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEBBIE THOMPSON
THAT.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR IT'LL PROGRAM
CDSS
AND YOU WERE HANDED OUT UP POWER
POINT. THAT.
TALKS ABOUT AN OVERVIEW OF THE
SSI ASSIST PEAPACK PROGRAM. AND
I'M JUST GOING TO QUICKLY GO
THROUGH IT AND POINT OUT WHAT IT
CONTAINS. AND SPEND HAPPY TO
EXPAND OR ANSWER QUESTIONS ON
ANY OF IT FOR YOU.
THE FIRST.
SLIDE JUST SHARES THROUGH THE
PROGRAM SERVES
DIFFERENT INFORMATION.
THE SECOND SLIDE.
PROVIDE SOME DATA OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE POPULATION
RECEIVING SSI ASSIST P. BOTH ON
A STATE AND NATIONAL LEVEL SO
THAT YOU CAN SEE IT IS. COMING
DOWN SLIGHTLY BOTH STATE AND
NATIONALLY.
.
THE NEXT SLIDE KIND OF GOES INTO
SOME REASONS THAT ARE THAT HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS THE POTENTIAL
FOR WHY IT MAY BE DECLINING
SOMEONE. IT SEEMS TO BE
PRIMARILY THE DISABLED
POPULATION.
THAT SEEMS TO BE DECLINING.
THE NEXT SLIDE SLIDE FIVE.
PROVIDES INFORMATION ABOUT THE
BUDGET WHICH HAS STAYED FAIRLY
FLAT THIS YEAR AND INTO NEXT.
RIGHT ABOUT TEN MILLION DOLLARS
WITH ABOUT TWO POINT EIGHT OF
NOT BEING.
ASSIST P. PORTION WHICH THE
STATE FUNDS.
NEXT SLIDE COVERS THE
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT
REQUIREMENT AS FAR AS WHAT'S THE
STATE IS OBLIGATED TO
PARTICIPATE IN.
AND THEN YOU GO INTO ON SLIDE
SEVEN THE DIFFERENT PAYMENT
STANDARDS.
SO THIS YEAR THE INDIVIDUAL MOST
COMMON PAYMENT STANDARD FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL IS NINE HUNDRED AND
TEN DOLLARS AND FOR THE COUPLE.
IT'S FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO THOSE
ARE ANTICIPATED TO GO UP DUE TO
THE COLA. JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TO APPROX WE
NINE THIRTY FOR AN INDIVIDUAL IN
FIFTEEN SIXTY TWO FOR THE
COUPLE.
THE FOLLOWING SLIDE ON SLIDE
EIGHT PROVIDES.
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SS I SS
P. LEVELS IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE
FEDERAL POVERTY GUIDELINES.
CURRENTLY.
THE INDIVIDUALS AT ABOUT EIGHTY
NINE PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL IN THE COUPLE'SAT
ABOUT A HUNDRED ALMOST A HUNDRED
AND TWELVE.
SOME OF VERY SIMILAR FOR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ABOUT NINETY
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL AND HUNDRED
AND TWELVE AGAIN FOR A COUPLE
PERCENT.
THE FOLLOWING.
SLIDES PROVIDE SOME INFORMATION
ABOUT THE COLA HISTORIES.
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS AND THEN THE
COUPLES.
AND THEN THE LAST SLIDE PROVIDE
SOME INFORMATION ABOUT.
.
THE RELATIONSHIP OF SS P. AND.
CAO FRESH AND THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN A CASH OUT MODEL.
GREAT NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM SCOTT
GRAPES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SCOTT
GRAVES ON THE RESEARCH DIRECTOR
AT THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND
POLICY CENTER. HOW MY ROLE TODAY
OVER THE NEXT FEW MINUTES IS TO
SHOW HOW BASIC MONTHLY INCOME
SUPPORT PROVIDED THROUGH AS A
SCIENCE IS P. FOR SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES? I'M
STACKS UP TO DIFFERENT MEASURES
OF COST OF LIVING AND MATERIAL
WELL BEING HOW I'M GONNA DO THAT
THROUGH BY WALKING YOU THROUGH
ABOUT SEVENTH CHARTS. ON BUT
BEFORE I GET INTO THE DETAILS
ABOUT THE GRANTS THEMSELVES ARE
AND HOW THEY MEASURE UP I FIRST
WANT TO STEP BACK AND LAY OUT.
ON FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE STEEP DECLINE IN
STATE SUPPORT FOR SS I SS P.
THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE PAST
DECADE SO YOU SHOULD HAVE. ON
THE HANDOUT IF YOU DO I WOULD
ASK YOU TO TO MOVE TO THE FIRST
CHART WHICH IS ON PAGE TWO.
.
CLEARLY YOU CAN SEE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN EIGHT ABOUT A
DECADE AGO ADJUSTING FOR
INFLATION THE STATE WAS SPENDING
THROUGH RIGHT GENERAL FUND JUST
YEAR ON ITS SHARE OF SS P.. ON
GRANTS AS PART OF THE SS I SS P.
PROGRAM ON BECAUSE OF SEVERE
CUTS THAT WERE MADE IN RESPONSE
TO THE GREAT RECESSION IN THE
BUDGET SHORTFALLS THAT THE STATE
EXPERIENCED. AREN'T WE SOUGHT
SPENDING ON S. S. P. ON THE US
HAS PEOPLE RUSSIAN OF THE GRANTS
DROP PRETTY DRAMATICALLY OVER
THERE THE COMING YEARS I'M TO
THE POINT WHERE.
THE STATE TODAY IS SPENDING
JUST OVER AROUND TWO POINT SIX
BILLION.
ON SS THE SS P. PORTION OF THE
GRANT SO WHAT IS THAT MEAN THAT
MEANS THAT OVER THE LAST DECADE
STATE SPENDING ON THESE GRANTS
HAS COME DOWN BY ABOUT. FORTY
PERCENT.
RELATIVE TO THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN EIGHT LEVEL ON A DIFFERENT
WAY OF THINKING ABOUT THAT IS IN
ANY GIVEN YEAR CALIFORNIA
SPENDING WELL OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS LAST.
FROM THE GENERAL FUND ON SS I SS
P. I'M AS A RESULT OF THE
ONGOING CUTS THAT HAVE CONTINUED
ON IN THE PROGRAM.
SO HOW DID THE STATE ACHIEVED
THESE LARGE ONGOING GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS WELL IF YOU LOOK AT THE
CHART ON PAGE THREE.
IT PROVIDES THE ANSWER.
THAT SORT OF AT THE FOR THE AND
I APOLOGIZE TO THE AUDIENCE WHO
MAY NOT HAVE THE CHART BUT.
AT THE BOTTOM OF EACH BAR YOU
CAN SEE SORT OF A GOLD SHADING
THAT REPRESENTS THE STATE'S S.
S. P. PORTION OF THE GRANT.
BACK IN EARLY TWO THOUSAND NINE
CALIFORNIA WAS PROVIDING A
MAXIMUM GRANT ON THE ON THE S.
S. P. SIDE OF OF OF TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE DOLLARS PER MONTH.
FOR MOST SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
ON THAT VERY QUICKLY CAME DOWN
TO AROUND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX PER MONTH WHICH WAS THE
MINIMUM ALLOWED BY FEDERAL LAW
FOR INDIVIDUAL GRANTS. ARM AND
OVER THE COMING YEARS THE STATE
HAS PROVIDED JUST A SINGLE COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT THAT TOOK
EFFECT IN EARLY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND WHICH BROUGHT. UP
THE GRANT LEVEL FROM A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SIX DOLLARS UP TO
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
DOLLARS SO RELATIVELY ON MODEST
INCREASE TO GRANT LEVELS. SO THE
REDLINE ABOVE THE BARS IS THE
FEDERAL POVERTY GUIDELINES FOR
EACH YEAR THAT SIMPLY INDICATES
THAT WHILE WE WERE FUNDING ON SS
I SS P. GRANTS. ARM SO THAT THEY
REACH THE POVERTY LINE BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE. ARE THESE
GRANTS ARE CURRENTLY BEING
FUNDED AT A LEVEL THAT LEAVES
THEM AT NINETY PERCENT OF THE
POVERTY LINE SO BASICALLY
ANYBODY ON SS I SS P. EVEN IF
THEY RECEIVE THE MAXIMUM GRANT
ALLOWABLE. I'M AS AN INDIVIDUAL
THEIR LEFT IT NINETY PERCENT OF
THE POVERTY LINE ALWAYS
IMPORTANT POINT OUT THAT AS MANY
OF YOU ALREADY KNOW OUR AYE I
BELIEVE ALL OF YOUKNOW. THAT AS
A SCIENTIST HE RECIPIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
CAL FRESH FOOD ASSISTANCE SO THE
MINIMAL BASIC SUPPORT THEY
RECEIVE EACH MONTH NOT ONLY HAVE
TO HELP THEM KEEP A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEADS. BUT ALSO PURCHASE
GROCERIES MEDICINE AND OTHER
BASIC NECESSITIES.
SO IF WE MOVE ON TO SLIDE FOR
I'M SOME ADVOCATES HAVE
SUGGESTED.
A REASONABLE GOAL TO SET WOULD
BE TO RAISE EXERCISES P. GRANTS
BACK UP TO THE POVERTY LINE ON
THE FEDERAL FEDERAL POVERTY
GUIDELINES. I'M WHAT WOULD THAT
LOOK LIKE IN SHORT FORM THIS IS
SIMPLY TO BARS ON PAGE FOUR ONE
SHOWS YOU WHERE WE ARE NOW
RELATIVE TO THE FEDERAL POVERTY
GUIDELINES FOR AN INDIVIDUAL.
THAT THE BAR ON THE RIGHT SHOWS
YOU WHERE WE WOULD HAVE TO GO IN
ORDER TO GET GRANTS UP TO THE
POVERTY GUIDELINES ESSENTIALLY
WE HAVE DUG SUCH A DEEP HOLE IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO RAISE OUR STATE S. S. P.
PORTION OF THE GRANT BY JUST
OVER ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
MONTH. UP FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL IN
THE PROGRAM WHO RECEIVED AN
INDIVIDUAL GRANT ON IN ORDER TO
BRING THEM UP JUST TO THE
POVERTY LINE.
AND AND YOU KNOW THAT'S A
RELATIVELY MODEST GOAL TO HAVE
TO TO BRING SOMEBODY UP TO THE
POVERTY LINE WERE NOT EVEN
TALKING ABOUT PUSHING THEM WELL
I'M OUT OF POVERTY SO.
THERE HAVE BEEN OTHERS WHO HAVE
HAD SUGGESTED THAT THAT WOULD
NOT BE I'M A AND IT WOULD BE A
RELATIVELY EXPENSIVE ENDEAVOR
WOULD BE DIFFICULT FOR THE STATE
TO DO THAT IN A SINGLE FISCAL
YEAR.
BUT IT COULD BE A GOAL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDES TO SET THAT
IT WANTS TO ACHIEVE OVER TIME.
SO THE LAST UP YOU SLICE HERE MY
PRESENTATION I'M I JUST WANTED
TO HELP YOU UNDERSTAND HOW S. P.
S. ISAPI GRANTS MATCH UP NOT
JUST TO THE FEDERAL POVERTY
GUIDELINES.
BUT TO OTHER MEASURES OF COST
OF LIVING AND MATERIAL WELL
BEING IN CALIFORNIA SO SOME OF
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN A FACT SHEET
THAT THE BUDGET CENTER RELEASED
LAST MONTH. IN WHICH WE SHOWED
UP THE AND WE COMPARED THE
MAXIMUM SS I SS BE GRANTED EVERY
COUNTY.
TO THE FAIR MARKET RENT FOR A
STUDIO APARTMENT IN EACH COUNTY
THE FAIR MARKET RENT OR FM ARE.
IS SET BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EACH YEAR FOR HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PURPOSES IT'S A
RELATIVELY MODEST UNIT YOU'D BE
LOOKING AT.
WHAT ARE FACT SHEET SHOWED WAS
THAT I'M IN SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES UP THE STUDIO F. M. R.
I'M EXCEEDS THE MAXIMUM SSI
ASSIST P. GRANT?
AND IN ALL COUNTIES THE FM ARE
FOR A STUDIO APARTMENT EXCEEDS
HALF OF THE GRANT THE REASON WE
PICK HALF THE GRANT IS BECAUSE
THAT'S SORT OF AN INDICATOR. IF
SOMEONE IS SPENDING HALF OR MORE
OF THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO BE AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS SO THIS
CHART SIMPLY PICKS OUT FOR YOU
ELEVEN OF THE COUNTIES THAT WE
FEATURED IN THAT FACT SHEET. OUT
WHICH NOT SURPRISINGLY ARE
REPRESENTED BY THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE JUST TO GIVE YOU
A SENSE OF AND PERHAPS WHERE
YOUR. THE COUNTIES YOU REPRESENT
FALL ON THE SCALE IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW AN FM ARE FOR A STUDIO
APARTMENT WE'RE NOT EVEN TALKING
ABOUT A ONE OR TWO BEDROOM
APARTMENT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
APARTMENT WITHOUT A BEDROOM.
IN ALL CASES I'M EXCEED WHAT
SOMEBODY LIVING ON THIS INCOME
SHOULD BE EXPECTED TO PAY.
THE LAST THREE SLIDES IN THE
PRESENTATION HERE I'M MAYBE A
LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED TO LOOK
AT BUT WHAT I WANTED TO DO WAS
TO COMPARE THE MAXIMUM SSI SAYS
P. GRANT FOR AN INDIVIDUAL. TO
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF.
POVERTY THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT
POVERTY THRESHOLDS WE USE IN THE
U. S. ONE IS THE OFFICIAL
POVERTY THRESHOLD THAT MANY OF
US ARE FAMILIAR WITH. ON THE
OTHER IS CALLED THE SUPPLEMENTAL
POVERTY THRESHOLD THAT'S BEEN
PUBLISHED IN RECENT YEARS BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND TRIES TO
DO A BETTER JOB OF CAPTURING.
Y. TO FAMILY OR INDIVIDUAL
MIGHT NEED IN ORDER TO OUR STATE
SOMEWHAT MAKE ENDS MEET IN THIS
STATE OR IN THIS COUNTRY.
ANOTHER WAY OF LOOKING AT.
A BUDGET IS TO THINK ABOUT I'M
NOT JUST WHEN IS SOMEONE OUT OF
POVERTY BUT WHAT LEVEL OF INCOME
DO THEY REALLY NEED AN ORDER ON
TO HAVE A DECENT STANDARD OF
LIVING. OF THE UC I CENTER FOR
HEALTH POLICY RESEARCH EVERY
COUPLE OF YEARS PUBLISHES WHAT
THEY CALL THE ELDER INDEX AND
ESTIMATES WHAT IT COSTS ON FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL A SENIOR OR A YET
SENIORS LIVING IN ANY CALIFORNIA
COUNTY WHAT IT WOULD COST FOR
THEM TO SORT OF MAKE ENDS. MEET
IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET SO I'VE
DONE ON THE NEXT THREE SLIDES
FOR THE FRESNO AREA OF THE SANTA
ROSA AND CINEMA COUNTY AREA AND
THE LOS ANGELES AREA INCLUDING
THE INCLUDING THE THE
METROPOLITAN AREA.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE ANAHEIM AS
WELL IS TO SORT OF LAY OUT WHERE
THE MAXIMUM SS I SS P. GRANT FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL AGAIN THAT'S
AROUND AND NOT NINE HUNDRED
ELEVEN DOLLARS RIGHT NOW. HOW
THAT STACKS UP TO THE OFFICIAL
POVERTY THRESHOLD THE
SUPPLEMENTAL POVERTY THRESHOLD
AND THE BASIC BUDGET OF THAT THE
UCLA CENTER FOR HEALTH POLICY
RESEARCH ESTIMATES WOULD BE
NEEDED IN ORDER FOR? A SENIOR TO
MAKE ENDS MEET IN ANY PARTICULAR
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND REALLY THE KEY TAKEAWAY HERE
I DON'T HAVE TO WALK THROUGH
EVERY SLIDE BECAUSE THEY ALL
TELL A SIMILAR STORY THE KEY
TAKE AWAY IS THAT THE MAXIMUM
SSI S. P. GRANT. IS INSUFFICIENT
IN EVERY CASE IT FALLS BELOW THE
OFFICIAL POVERTY THRESHOLD IF
FALLS BELOW THE SUPPLEMENTAL
POVERTY THRESHOLD AND IT'S WELL
BELOW.
WHAT YOU SEE OUT UCLA'S ELDER
INDEX ESTIMATES IS NEEDED ARM IN
ORDER FOR SENIORS TO MAKE ENDS
MEET IN CALIFORNIA?
SO WITH THAT I'LL CONCLUDE MY
PRESENTATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE'LL HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AND IF YOU CAN JUST TELL
US WHEN YOU WELL PRESENT ON
ISSUE TWELVE AS WELL. YOU MAY
PRESENT BOTH RIGHT NOW THAT'S
GETTING IT FOR YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHERYL IT'LL ALLOW YOU TO
HEAR FROM YOU ONLY ONCE TODAY. I
KNOW MISTER HARPER'S PLACE AND
ABOUT THAT.
AND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
YEAH.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
BEFORE ALL OF YOU TODAY I'M HERE
ON BEHALF.
OF MANY ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES AS
WELL AS AS CHAIR OF THE AGING
AND LONG TERM. CARE COMMITTEE OF
IN MAKING TWO REQUESTS. NUMBER
ONE TO RESTORE THE STATE'S SHARE
THE SOCIAL SECURITY INCOME AND
STATE SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT GRANT
TO THAT OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL OF THIS BEFORE FROM OTHER
PRESENTERS.
AND A NUMBER TWO WHICH IS ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE I BELIEVE TO
PROVIDE A MODEST ALLOCATION.
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS FOR THE HOME SAFE
PROGRAM FOR ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES.
OF WITH THE CHAIRS COMMISSION
OUGHT TO FIRST BEGIN WITH SS I
SS P. REQUEST.
I WANT TO THINK OF AS A MEMBER
RUBIO AND EIGHT OTHER MEMBERS
WHO HAVE JOINED ME IN THIS
REQUEST.
OTHER QUESTIONS BY NO MEANS A
PANACEA AS WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
PRESENTATION.
IT WILL NOT SOLVE THE CRISIS
FACING OUR AGING AND DISABLED
POPULATIONS BUT IT WILL PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT HELP FOR SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
FOR MANY OF THE ONE POINT THREE
MILLION LOW INCOME SENIORS AND
PEOPLE LIVING WITH DISABILITIES
WHO RECEIVE SSI S. B. GRANTS IT
IS THEIR SOLE SOURCE OF INCOME.
IT HELPS TO PAY RENT BUY FOOD
PAPER UTILITIES MEDICINE AND
OTHER BASIC NECESSITIES.
AND TWO THOUSAND NINE RESPONSE A
DEEP BUDGET SHORTFALLS BECAUSE
WITH THE GREAT RECESSION THEY
CUT THE SSB PORTION THE GRAMMAR
BOTH INDIVIDUALS AND COUPLES TO
THE LOWEST LEVELS ALLOWED BY
FEDERAL LAW.
FOR ACCESSBECAUSE FOR TAKING A
TWO THOUSAND NINE THE MAXIMUM
GRANT WAS A HUNDRED POINT SIX
PERCENT OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL TODAY. IT IS EIGHTY NINE
POINT ONE PERCENT.
AS A RESULT THE MAXIM COMBINED
SS I SS BE GRANT FOR INDIVIDUAL.
CURRENTLY ABOUT NINE OR ELEVEN
DOLLARS PER MONTH AS HE COULD
JUST NINETY PERCENT. OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE OF COURSE
WHEN COMPOUNDED WITH THE GROWING
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
RECIPIENTS ARE FALLING FAR BELOW
THE POVERTY LEVEL. AND FACING
SERIOUS AND LIFE CHANGING
DECISIONS ON HOW TO PAY FOR
DAILY LIVING EXPENSES. RENT FOOD
MEDICATION ELECTRICITY EXETER.
ALL THE STATE SAVE AN ESTIMATED
TEN BILLION DOLLARS IN THESE
CUTS THAT BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE. WE HAVE RESTORED IN NEARLY
EVERY MAJOR PROGRAM IN THE
BUDGET.
EXCEPT S. S. P. GRANTS AND IF
APPROVED WILL FULLY FUND THE
STATE'S RAINY DAY CASH RESERVE.
FUND TO THIRTEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS LARGEST CASH
RESERVE IN STATE HISTORY.
WHILE WE EMBRACE THE
PROJECTED BUDGET SURPLUS AND THE
WISDOM OF THE CASH RESERVES.
WE CANNOT FORGET THAT THESE WERE
ATTAINED IN PART DUE THE
CUSTOMER MADE IN THE SACRIFICES
MADE BY MANY SITTING BEHIND ME.
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
ALSO THIS IS NOT JUST A
RESTORATION BUT RATHER A STEP
TOWARDS CONTINUING OUR
OBLIGATION TO HELP OF TO OUR
SOCIAL CONTRACT. WITH OUR
SOCIETY WITH OUR COMMUNITY. WHEN
HE SERVED PROTECT THE MOST
VULNERABLE I WORKED ASSURE THAT
ALL PEOPLE CAN LIVE THEIR LIFE
WITH DIGNITY. IT IS TIME TO
RESTORE SSI SSB.
INSIDE MY PURSE ACROSS I PRESS
YOU TAKE THE TIME. I HAD TO
LISTEN TO OUR TO THE REQUEST.
.
ITEM TWO THAT I'M SPEAKING TO
WHICH I BELIEVE IS ISSUE TWELVE
BEFORE YOU IS REGARDING THE HOME
SAFE PROGRAM.
I PLEASE TO HAVE THIRTEEN OF MY
COLLEAGUES INCLUDING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO ADJOINING AND THIS
REQUEST.
THIS REQUEST TO PROVIDE A ONE
TIME FIFTEEN MILLION GENERAL.
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION. FOR A THREE
YEAR DEMONSTRATION GRANT PROGRAM
TO HELP PREVENT HOMELESSNESS
AMONG VICTIMS OF ELDER ABUSE AND
NEGLECT.
THE INTENT WOULD BE IF THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES TO
ISSUE DEPICTING MILLION DOLLARS.
AS A GRANT PROGRAM TO COUNTY
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
AGENCY.
I AGENCIES TO HELP APS CLIENTS
MAINTAIN THEIR HOUSING TO
SERVICES SUCH AS SHORT TERM
RENTAL UTILITY ASSISTANCE.
LEGAL ASSISTANCE AND EXPANDED
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY THE GRANT PROGRAM
WOULD OPERATE AS A DEMONSTRATION
PROGRAM.
ONE THAT WOULD BE USES A MODEL
TO REPLICATE IN OTHER COUNTIES.
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY A BY WAY
OF EXAMPLE. REPORTS OF ELDER AND
DEPENDENT ABUSE NEGLECT OF GROW
BY NEARLY THIRTY PERCENT.
IT'S TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
GROWTH MIRRORS.
AMID GROWING REPORTS OF ELDER
ABUSE NEGLECT ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND AS ONE THOUSAND BY STATES
ADULTS TURN SIXTY FIVE EVERY
DAY.
THIS GROWTH IS EXACERBATED
I CALIFORNIA'S AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS LEADING ABUSED
AND NEGLECTED OLDER ADULTS AND
EXCRETE THE STREAM RISK. OF
BECOMING HOMELESS.
IMPACT A P. S. RECEIVES ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PORTS
ELDER ABUSE AND NEGLECT EVERY
YEAR. OF THOSE CASES COUNTIES
ESTIMATED AVERAGE OF TEN PERCENT
OR MORE AT OR AT RISK OF LOSING
THEIR HOMES.
ALTHOUGH IT APPEARS PROGRAMS ARE
DOING YEOMAN'S WORK WITH MEAGER
RESOURCES.
BUT THE INCREASING GROWTH OF THE
STATE'S SENIOR POPULATION THERE
STRUGGLING TO PROVIDE THE
ASSISTANCE NECESSARY TO HELP
VICTIMS OF ABUSE REMAIN IN THEIR
HOMES AS THEY RECOVER.
RATHER THAN REQUESTING AN
ONGOING ALLOCATION WE HOPE
COMMITTEES. TO MAP PRIORITIZE A
ONE TIME MONEY.
SO THEY COUNTY APS BROKERS CAN
DEMONSTRATE HOW INTERVENING AT
MOMENTS OF CRISIS CAN PREVENT
VICTIMS OUTER AND DEPENDENT
ABUSE AND NEGLECT FROM BECOMING
HOMELESS SO I I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS. FOR UP TO LISTEN
TO THAT REQUEST AS WELL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
WITH THAT WE WILL NOW HAVE
ANDREAS ANDREW CHAIN FROM
CALIFORNIANS FOR SSI AS WELL AS
LOUISE HERNANDEZ FROM FRESNO
METRO MINISTRY. IF WE CAN CREATE
A LITTLE BIT OF SPACE FOR THE
TWO OF THEM.
WHILE THEY'RE COMING UP WE'RE
GOING TO ESTABLISH QUORUM.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
HERE HARPER.
MATHIS
HERE RUBIO.
WOULD.
QUORUM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MERCY
INTERCHANGE FROM CALIFORNIANS
FOR SSI.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN
TO AN ORGANIZATION STATEWIDE AND
IF I KNEW HOW TO DO MY JOB I
WOULD HAVE GIVEN THE STE.
FOLKS ALREADY BUT.
THAT'S PROVIDED FOR YOUR.
FOR YOUR REFERENCE ON THIS
REQUESTED ALSO LIST THE GROUPS
STATEWIDE.
YOU KNOW IT ON THE ABILITY TO
BREAK IT DOWN AS I THINK I JUST
WE CAN CLEARLY SEE THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE FROM EVERY CORNER OF
THIS STATE TO CARE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
AND I APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATIONS ARGUMENTS I WILL
BE BRIEF AND JUST TALK ABOUT THE
HIDDEN COSTS WHICH YOU'RE BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE.
ON ON THE PUBLIC SECTOR SIDE
YOU KNOW WE FEEL JUST AS
STRONGLY THAT THE STATE SHOULD
NOT CONTINUE TO BOOK SAVINGS AND
AND BUILD A RESERVE AT THE
EXPENSE. OF.
RESIDENTS WHO ARE FORCED INTO
POVERTY BY STATE ACTION.
BUT ALSO THAT THERE ARE ACTUAL
COSTS AND THAT ARE ALWAYS BUY
INTO THAT THE PERSPECTIVE.
SO DOCTOR SELIGMAN AT UCSF FOR
EXAMPLE HAS SHOWN THAT
HOSPITALIZATIONS SPIKE IN THE
FOURTH WEEK OF THE MONTH FOR LOW
INCOME POPULATIONS.
AFTER FOOD BUDGETS RUN OUT
FOLKS CAN'T TAKE THEIR MEDICINE
I MEAN THERE THAT WE KNOW PEOPLE
ARE ALREADY SKIPPING MEALS YOU
KNOW AND AND MAYBE TAKE THEIR
MEDS AND THEY SHOULDN'T BUT WHEN
THOSE TYPES OF. THINGS BREAKDOWN
BECAUSE FOLKS SENSIBLY HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY END UP IN THE
HOSPITAL AND THAT'S PUTTING
PRESSURE ON OUR HEALTHCARE
UTILIZATION AND WE CAN TRY TO MY
DOCUMENTATION TO YOU. AND AND
FURTHERMORE IT AS BEEN SPOKEN TO
ALREADY THERE ARE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND HOMELESS INTERVENTION COSTS
BECAUSE WHAT FOCUSED SO WE DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY TO LIVE IN AND OF
LIVING IN THEIR CARS ON THE
STREETS AND OTHER ACTS OF
DESPERATION. THAT CAN BE
PREVENTED IN PART OF RESTORING
THE GRANTS WE URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THOSE THOSE THOSE
COSTS.
BUT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE INVESTMENTS IN THE IN
THE PROGRAM AND ON THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AS WELL FROM THE STATE
COULD MAKE ASSOCIATION WE KNOW.
THAT WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN OUR SERVICE.
ONE I CAN SPEAK TO PARTICULARLY
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY THEY'VE
DOUBLED THE SERVICE TO SENIOR
SINCE TWENTY TEN APPROXIMATELY
YOU WENT IN ONE CUTS AND A FACT.
AND WE DON'T IMPRESS UPON YOU IS
THAT IT'S A PERMANENT LEVEL OF
SERVICE FEEDBACK FROM BUILT TO
PERMANENTLY SUPPORT OF THAT FOOD
AND NUTRITION NEEDS A SPECIAL
POPULATION IS LARGE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. RIGHT WERE MEANT
FOR TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE THIS
BOOK TO BETWEEN JOBS OR YOU KNOW
GETTING ON TO SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS LIKE LIKE HEALTH FRESH
THAT'S NOT ALLOWABLE UNDER THE
CURRENT RULES ARE GOING TALK
ABOUT A SECOND. AND SO JUST
THINK ABOUT THE HIDDEN BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALSO PUSHED ON TO OUR
SECTOR THAT'S WHY STORE GROUPS
COME FORWARD WITH ASKS BECAUSE
WERE SIMPLY BOOKING US COST
SOMEWHERE ELSE AND SO THANKS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
I'VE MY NAME'S LOUIS STRANDED SO
WITH PRESIDENT METRO MINISTRY
ALSO CO CHAIR OF CHOCO THE
CALIFORNIA ACTION COALITION.
I JUST LIKE.
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE FEW
RATHER FEW FRESNO RESIDENTS
SPECIFICALLY.
BUT DOES VERY MARTINEZ SHE'S A
HOMELESS ADVOCATE.
WHO?
IS ALWAYS CONSTANTLY OPPOSING
ON SOCIAL MEDIA RAISING
AWARENESS ABOUT THE HOMELESS
ISSUES IN FRESNO AS WELL AS
MAKING SURE THAT HER STREET
FAMILY IS HYDRATED AND WELL FED.
GENOME A BELLY.
SHE IMPLEMENTED OF GIVE AWAY AT
OUR CHURCH.
AND IS ALSO FACILITATING
COOKING CLASSES FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS AND LASTLY I'D LIKE TO
MENTION VERONICA RONA. SHE IS MY
NEIGHBOR AND SHE IS ALWAYS A
CONSIDERING HER NEIGHBORS WHEN
TRYING TO GIVE A HELPING HAND.
ALL THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE ON SSI
IN IN THE FACE OF SUCH ADVERSITY
THEY ALWAYS TRY TO PULL AS MANY
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THEY
SPREAD MUCH NEEDED HUMANITARIAN
EFFORTS AND FRESNO.
I CAN IMAGINE MY COMMUNITY
WITHOUT THEM AND I DON'T THINK
THEY SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
WEARING BETWEEN HOUSING.
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION.
OR FOOD.
ARE THESE PEOPLE DESERVES IN THE
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO BE OUT A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL AND.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ALONG WITH OVER FORTY THREE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
IN FRESNO COUNTY MAKE SURE THAT
THEY THAT THEY.
RECEIVED THOSE BENEFITS AS WELL.
THEY DESERVE CALIFORNIA'S
HUMANITY FOR THEIR HUMANITARIAN
EFFORTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LOUISE
MANDRELL.
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ELLIOT.
JACQUI ROCIO LA L..
.
JUST.
WITH REGARDS TO THE ASSIZES P.
OVERVIEW THAT THE DEPARTMENT
PROVIDED WE REVIEWED THE BUDGET.
KNOW INITIAL ISSUES WE WOULD
KNOW ONE TECHNICAL NOTE THAT
BASED OFF OF OUR ESTIMATES OF
THE FEDERAL COLA THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE SSI PORTION OF THE
GRANT OUR ESTIMATES SHOW THAT IT
WOULD BE SLIGHTLY LOWER THAN
WHAT IS.
MENTIONED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND AS MENTIONED IN THE
AGENDA AND THE STAFF COMMENTS
WERE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE ANY TECHNOLOGY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT THE. MEMBERS
MEAN REQUIRE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ARE ALSO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHICH IS NOT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION THAT
COALITION PREVAILED VALERIE AND
I KNOW YOU OR YOUR BASIS AND
ACCOUNT FOR ANY OUT YEAR FISCAL
IMPACTS THAT THEY MAY HAVE.
STRUCTURALLY.
COOL INCREASES.
ACCOUNT FOR A SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE OF COSTS IN THE OUT
YEARS IN ONE ENTRY NOTE THAT.
TO IN ORDER TO INCREASE THE.
INDIVIDUAL GRANTS FOR THE SS
PEOPLE OR SHUT UP TO THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE WE ESTIMATE.
APPROXIMATELY A ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
INCREASE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
INCREASE THE COLA FOR BUDGET
YEAR. IT WOULD COST
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
EVERYONE PERCENT INCREASE.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO INCREASE IT TO
THE AMOUNT OF THE CP I LOW IT
WE'RE ESTIMATING AT UP FOUR
POINT OH FOUR PERCENT. OVER COST
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
EIGHT MILLION ANNUALLY GENERAL
FUND.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE IN THE
UPPER GALLERY WHO WANTS TO MAKE
A COMMENT YOU MAY WANT TO START
MAKING YOUR WAY DOWN.
ARE YOU.
MARTY AMONG AUGUST ON HOW.
MORE HE MOTO A FAMILY MEMBER AND
ALSO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMITTEE
ACTION NETWORKS YOU CAN.
I JUST WANT TO URGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO MAKE THIS THE
TOP PRIORITY. AMONG ALL THE
PRIORITIES THAT YOU HAVE TO LOOK
AT.
THIS IS THE ONE THING THE SPOT
FAIRNESS TO ONE POINT THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WITH
DISABILITIES INCLUDING PEOPLE
WITH DOPE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES APPLYING AND
SENIORS.
AND A SUPPORT FOR THAT PROPOSAL
PUT TO.
INCREASED YES US S. P. YOU
PORTION OF THE GRANTS BUT ALSO
THE OTHER UP PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT THANK YOU.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF CAL PACE.
THE PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE
CARE FOR THE ELDERLY IN SUPPORT
OF THE INCREASE IN THAT GRANTS
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK KRISTY'S MOTHER BURCHETT
ON BEHALF OF EDUCATE ADVOCATE
AND EMPOWER FAMILY CALIFORNIA.
AND WE SUPPORT A HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR A HUNDRED PERCENT.
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS VIRGINIA
FAIR ALMA TONY. AND I AM A
VOLUNTEER FOR OUR.
MY FRIEND MARY IS ON SSI SFB
BECAUSE SHE IS SAID MIGRAINES.
SINCE CHILDHOOD SHE LIVES WITH
HER MOTHER BECAUSE SHE IS ON
SSI.
THE MONEY FROM SSI JUST NOT MEET
FOR EXPENSES.
SHE WOULD BE LIVING ON THE
STREETS.
IF SHE DID NOT HAVE HER MOTHER
TO LIVE WITH.
ON BEHALF OF MARY ANN OVER THREE
POINT THREE MILLION MEMBERS
I AM HERE TO EXPRESS ARPS.
PORT FOR THE BUDGET PROPOSAL.
TO PCF SYFY SFB MONTHLY GRANT.
TWO THE POVERTY LEVEL OUR URGES
YOU TO SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET
REQUEST.
OUR DEEPEST.
GRATITUDE FOR THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU MA'AM.
SHANNON PRIMER I'M FROM SAN
DIEGO AND I REPRESENT MY CLIENTS
I'M A SPECIAL EDUCATION
PARALEGAL AND I'M ALSO HERE WITH
EMPOWER FAMILIES CALIFORNIA. AND
I WOULD URGE YOU GUYS TO VOTE
YES FOR THE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
A HUNDRED PERCENT PLEASE.
THE COMMISSION SHARE MEMBER
JORDAN LINDSEY WITH THEY ARE
CALIFORNIAN UNIT UNITED CIRCLE
POLICY. APPROXIMATE NINETY FOUR
PERCENT OF REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS RELY ON SSI IT'S SP.
AND.
AND MANY OF THEM ARE STUCK IN A
POVERTY TRAP AND SO WE DEFTLY
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL AND HOPE
YOU WILL BOTH INCREASE THE
GRANT.
AND INVESTMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PER CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WE'D LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH.
THOSE OF OUR COLLEAGUES AND
WOULD JUST SUGGEST THAT IN THE
YEAR SUCH AS THE US THAT IT IS
REALLY QUITE SHAMEFUL THAT WE
WOULD CONTINUE TO ASK.
AGED AND DISABLED INDIVIDUALS
TO CONTINUE LIVING HERE BELOW
THE POVERTY LINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR.
BUT THE GOVERNMENT IS A SILLY A
CALIFORNIA WILL MINOR COMES OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SSI COALITION
SUPPORT THE REQUEST TO INCREASE
ASSIST P. GRANTS BUT A HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH AND TO
REESTABLISH THE PRIOR CENTURY
COST. OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
SUCH AS ACTION IS NECESSARY TO
REVERSE THE COURSE THAT PREVIOUS
FRANK CUTS AND THE COLOR REPEAL
HAS SAT UP PUSHING ASIDE. AND
ASSIST P. TO RISK RECIPIENTS
INTO HOMELESSNESS AND HUNGER
THANK YOU.
I CAN.
HYATT NORMALLY BODICE WITH A
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IE TEST US AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR SSI AS SP THANK YOU.
HOW MINOR OF RADICAL AYE BLUNTED
DOT BULLSHIT LOCAL DISABILITY
RIGHTS CROUPIER INSECT IN A
SHOCK SECOND HOMES OR LIVE
COMMITTEE? AND I'VE BEEN HERE
PEOPLE THERE SAY THEY HAVE A
CHIU BETWEEN A MEDICATION BOAT
RANT.
AND OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE.
HOMELESS BECAUSE OF THAT LACK
OF IF IF.
I INCREASED I SUPPORT A HUNDRED
PER HUNDRED THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S ERIC FRAME I AM A
HOMELESS ADVOCATE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
OUT THERE ON THE STREET I'VE
SEEN AN INCREASE IN THE ELDERLY
BECOMING HOMELESS.
.
IT'S NOT RIGHT TO HAVE THEM LIVE
UNDER POVERTY LINE.
I SUPPORT.
INCREASE ABOVE THE POVERTY LINE
PERHAPS A HUNDRED TWENTY PERCENT
BUT WE'LL TAKE WHAT WE CAN GET
AND I SUPPORT THE GRANT TO. PUT
US OUT POVERTY LEVEL THANK YOU
THINK.
HELLO MICHELLE ROUSEY.
S. AS A CONSUMER WHO WHO HAS HAD
AND. THE SSI AT GRANT LEFT THAT
THE PASSED IT AND I DON'T VIDEO
CONSUMERS TO USE IT NOW. OF IT'S
JUST NOT A LIVABLE OF INCOME TO
LIVE I'D. EVER HOUSING IS
CRUSHED SIR HUGE AND.
THE GROWTH IN HOMELESSNESS IT IN
THIS DAY IT IT EVEN IN MY CITY I
CAN'T RUN DOWN THE STREET
WITHOUT SEEING PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMELESS. BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
HAVE THE INCOME.
I START HOURS IN THE FOOD BANK.
TO BE ABLE TO GET FOOD TO
SUPPLEMENT MY EARLIER BECAUSE
AND I SEE IN MIND OF A HUNDRED
PEOPLE LIVE WHERE SOME TYPES.
IF THEY'VE INCREASED THEIR HOURS
TO FIVE OF FIVE TO SIX DAYS A
WEEK FROM THERE ONCE A WEEK.
BEEN ABLE TO GET THE FOOD.
PLEASE INCREASE SSI IT'S NOT
SHARED TO THOSE CONSUMERS TO USE
AND BECKY.
HUMAN.
SELENA PRIOR WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA A MORE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS SOCIETY SAYS P. INCREASE
EIGHTY PERCENT OF OUR AYE AEGIS
AS CONSUMERS RECEIVE SSI ASSIST
PEOPLE IN A FITS. THIS COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT IS ESPECIALLY
CRITICAL AT THIS TIME IS ONE OF
THE MANY PROGRAMS THAT IS
ESSENTIAL TO LIFTING CHILDREN A
FAMILY FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY
THANK YOU.
HUMAN.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL.
AND A SOCIAL WORKERS IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH OUR CODE OF
ETHICS AND THREE OF OUR
PRINCIPLES ARE SOCIAL WORKERS
PRIMARY GOAL IS TO HELP PEOPLE
IN NEED AND TO ADDRESS SOCIAL
PROBLEMS. SOCIAL WORKERS
CHALLENGE SOCIAL INJUSTICE AND
WE ALSO RESPECTED THE INHERENT
DIGNITY AND WORTH OF EVERY
PERSON PLEASE PASS THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RUSSELL ROWLING'S I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY
SERVICES FOR RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING AND A PEN A
LIVING CENTER SERVING SACRAMENTO
AND YELLOW COUNTIES.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL TO.
LIFT.
THE SS PEOPLE ARE SOME OF THE
SSI GRANT SO SCIENCES BE GRANT
TO THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
AND TODAY I HAVE.
A SHORT STATEMENT THAT WAS
WRITTEN BY AN INSPIRATIONAL
FIGURE OUT WITHIN THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY THAT WE JUST LOST.
I'M YESTERDAY.
STEPHEN HAWKING AND I THINK HE
PROVIDE SOME BOLD WORDS FOR US
TO THINK ABOUT AS WE CONSIDER
THIS.
I OFTEN WONDER WHAT IT MUST LOOK
LIKE TO OTHER BEINGS WATCHING
FROM DEEP SPACE.
AS WE LOOK T OUR UNIVERSE WE
ARE LOOKING BACK IN TIME.
BECAUSE LIKE LEAVING DISTANT
OBJECTS REACHES US MUCH MUCH
LATER.
WHITE LIGHT. EMITTING FROM MARK
WHAT DOES LIGHT EMITTING FROM
EARTH TODAY SHOW.
WHAT WHEN PEOPLE SEE OUR PAST
WILL WE BE PROUD OF WHAT WE ARE
SHOWN? HOW WE AS BROTHERS TREAT
EACH OTHER?
HOW WE ALLOW OUR BREATH?
HOW DO WE ALLOW OUR BROTHERS TO
TREAT OUR CHILDREN?
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S REALLY
INDICATIVE OF THE STRUGGLE THAT
FOLKS THAT ARE.
FACING POVERTY.
I WAS AMONG THEM UNTIL JUST
RECENTLY AND CLOSING ABLE TO
ACCEPT MY POSITION
SO I ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU. TO
THINK ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT AN INCREASE WOULD PROVIDE
FOR INDIVIDUALS THINK.
THANK YOU STERN QUITE TIMELY.
HELLO I'M CLEARLY KITANA SENIOR
SERVICES COALITION OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
I'M HERE TODAY TO REQUEST THAT
THE THAT THE COUNCIL ARE
COMMITTEE.
RESTORE.
AND CONTINUE TO FUND THE
INVESTMENT OF SS I SS P..
AND MANY REMAIN A CHAMPION FOR
OLDER ADULTS.
AND I'LL CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
FRANCIS SMITH.
I'M REPRESENTING YOLO HEALTHY
AGING ALLIANCE WERE PROUD TO BE
ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF
CALIFORNIA FOR SSI I ALSO
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS.
WANT TO THANK SCOTT GRAVES FOR
THAT VERY VERY INSIGHTFUL REPORT
THAT HE JUST GAVE.
I SAID LAST WEEK AT THE SENATE
AND I'LL SAY IT AGAIN IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE IT WAS WRONG FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET BY TAKING
MONEY AWAY FROM PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NO OTHER SOURCE OF INCOME. IN
THE SUBSEQUENT YEARS FROM THEN
TO TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVENTEEN
IT WAS STILL WRONG NOT TO
RESTORE THOSE CUTS.
NOW THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THIS
WONDERFUL SURPLUS.
IT WOULD BE RIGHT TO RESTORE THE
CUTS
SOCIAL WORKERS HAVE A CODE OF
ETHICS I BELIEVE GOVERNMENT HAS
THE MORAL AUTHORITY I URGE YOU
TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
I CAN.
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY WE TO STAND SUPPORT
OF THE REQUEST BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA FOR. AN INCREASE IN
THE SS I SS P. GRANT TO THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
AND.
I GUESS THE ONE THING THAT I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADD TO THAT
IS THAT. THERE BEEN A LOT OF
TESTIMONY TODAY ABOUT THE LEVEL
OF CUTS THE NUMBER OF YEARS THAT
THEY'VE BEEN IN PLACE.
THE MAGNITUDE OF HOW MUCH MONEY
THAT'S MEANT TO THE STATE
SURPLUS. NOW I GUESS REALLY THIS
IS REALLY A PLEA I THINK TO THE
GOVERNOR.
THAT.
THAT WE WOULD ASK HIM TO REALLY
THINK HARD AND LONG ABOUT
WHETHER NOT THESE CUTS REALLY
NEED TO STAY IN PLACE GOING
FORWARD WHAT THE JUSTIFICATION
FOR THAT IS.
I THINK DEMONSTRATED BY THE
INTERESTS OF THE TWO HOUSES OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS SEEMS LIKE
THERE.
STANGEL INTEREST IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE THESE CUTS
I TO REVERSE THOSE CUTS AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL JOIN WITH
THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR MAKING
THAT SHIFT YOU. THANK YOU.
SIR.
JEFF KARTIKEYA AND I WILL DITTO
THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
TO AND YOU'LL SEE ME BACK YOUR
AGAIN.
ADVOCATE.
HOME DOG FIGHTER.
CARA.
HOW?
THERE'S A FEW MORE BUT I LIKE TO
HAVE FRIENDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ON THE
DON'T WANT TO HEAR FROM
COMMUNITY RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT LEANING A WERE.
CALIFORNIA COUNTY OF ELIMIA.
I CAN HERE. AS ONE OF THE
STATISTICS IN UNITED STATES THAT
OUT OF THE TEN PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES SEEKS BECOME THE
TABLE BEFORE THE AGE OF
RETIREMENT.
SO I'M STUCK IN THE POOR TO NINE
NOW. AND IT CALIFORNIA'S HAVE
REALLY HIGH.
LEVELED OFF LEAVING SO DOES
WHERE YOU DRIVE ANYWHERE IN THAT
IN THE STATE YOU'D SEE HOMELESS
PEOPLE MORE LIKE ANTI WAR
COUNTRIES.
SO I THINK A HUNDRED DOLLARS
HE'S YES.
JUST SEEMS WE HAVE A FROZEN COST
OF LIVING ALLOWANCE FOR MANY
YEARS. THEY TOOK IT OUT NOW THEY
GAVE US A LITTLE BIT OF THINGS
FEEL GOOD. IN THE CLASSIC I'M
SORRY THAT IT DOESN'T WORK SO
ALL YOU KNOW EVERYBODY CAN
BECOME DISABLED AP TOP DEPORTED
I LIKE A ON SO. CONSIDERED THAT
WE HAVE NO FOOD STAMPS ONE OF
THE ONLY STATES IN UNITED
STATES.
THE PEOPLE RECEIVING DISABILITY
DON'T GET FOOD STAMPS.
THANK YOU.
AND I BELIEVE WE'RE THE ONLY
STATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK MAC
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CWD A.
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICE DIRECTORS AREN'T
STRONG SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME'S GEAR Y. SAT SAMEER
CENTER.
AND I SUPPORT B. THIRTY TWO.
ZERO ZERO.
IN PROBABLY FOUR ONE POINT THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIA'S UNLESS
ASIDE. A HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
TO REACH ONE HUNDRED PERCENT ALL
FEDERAL PROPERTY LEVEL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAPTAIN
SAMUELS.
.
I'M FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY ALONE.
IS ROSS FOR ME TO REALLY STAND
UP HERE TODAY BECAUSE.
I HAVE A TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER.
IN THE THIRTY O'DONNELL.
AND I HAVE TO WEAR ABOUT.
WHEN I'M NOT HERE FOR MY KIDS.
WHAT IN THE WORLD IS GOING TO
HAPPEN IDEA? I AM ON SSI.
MY YOUNGER DAUGHTER'S ON SSI.
AND.
WE HAVE A SINGLE PAYER.
TRYING TO WAITED YOUNG ADULT.
IS NOT EASY.
WE AND ALSO SECURITY.
I STAND HERE BEFORE YOU PLEASE
GIVE US A INCREASE.
WE'VE GOT IT IS HARD FOR ME TO
MAKE IT FROM ONE MONTH.
TOUR NEXT MONTH.
IT'S VERY HARD IT'S A SINGLE
PAYER.
I'M WATCHING THESE HOMELESS
PEOPLE WHERE I LIVE EACH AND
EVERY DAY STRUGGLING.
AND I COULD BECOME ONE OF THOSE
AND I HAVE AN ARTIST IS ABLE.
AND I HAVE TO WEAR ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN TO HER.
WHEN I WALK AWAY AND IT'S NOT
FAIR.
YOU KNOW YOU GLENN MANY SHOULD
GIVE US OUR RIGHTS IN THE NEXT
MINUTE THEY TAKE IT BACK THEM
ONE DAY OVER PAY US THEY WANT US
TO PAY HIM BACK WHEN THEY THREW
A WE HAVE TO PAY FOR THEIR
MISTAKES. AND WE SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO.
SO A SLIGHT WOULD NEED FOOD
STAMPS YOU KNOW OUR MONEY DOES
NOT COVER EVERYTHING.
NOT WHEN YOU HAVE A CHILD IT YOU
HAVE TO STILL CARE FOR BECAUSE
SHE CANNOT CARE FOR HER OWN.
SOME STAND UP HERE REPRESENT HER
ALSO TODAY TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE GAME.
HI MY NAME IS ONE DILLON DORSEY
I'M HERE FOR SSI THIS IS P..
I AM HERE TO REPRESENT THE
HOMELESS AMENDED DISABLE.
AND NOW.
THE INCOME THAT WE LIVE IN ON
EACH MONTH FOR MONTH MONTH IS
NOT GETTING IT BECAUSE I ONE OF
THEM I'M DISABLED. TOOL ANOMALY
SSI AND I REALLY APPRECIATE IF
Y'ALL CONSIDER RACE IN THE HOME
COST OF LIVING FOR PEOPLE ESTO
ES ASIDE TO SAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BECKY GARCON
COMING FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
AND MARIN FOOD BANK AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY A LOUD AND VERY
ENTHUSIASTIC DITTO TO ALL OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING.
I'M IN THIS ROOM ESPECIALLY
COMING FROM THE FOLKS WHO ARE
THE REAL EXPERTS ON THIS ISSUE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING ON SS
I SS PIECE SO. AGAIN I'M
SUFFERING THROUGH BANKING WE
REALLY STRONGLY SUPPORT AND THE
EFFORT INCREASED BENEFITS FOR
FOLKS.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M KATY CRAFTSMAN I LIVE ON
SSI.
I AM STUCK LIVING WITH MY MOM
BECAUSE I. CAN'T EVEN FIND A
ROOM FOR RENT THAT'S UNDER FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
FOR BOTH TO FILL HOLDS.
AND THAT'S WITHOUT LIKE CABLE OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.%
WAIT ME PRETTY SURE MOST OF YOU
GUYS PROBABLY HAVE CABLE.
I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO HAVE
CABLE I COULDN'T AFFORD IT I
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO HAVE.
A CAR PROBABLY COULDN'T AFFORD
AYE.
.
I MEAN I CAN BARELY AFFORD
GUEST.
LIVING WITH MY MOTHER AND I.
BARELY DO THAT I END UP GOING
OVER AND SHE ESTA HELPED ME
USUALLY. AND WHAT'S FUNNY I GO A
HUNDRED DOLLARS OVER.
WHICH WOULD JUST BE ANOTHER.
BUT I.
YOU NOW.
IN THE HOUSE.
.
SO.
EITHER I AM.
WHAT THE UPW PEOPLE EXPAND
MAMA'S BY AYE ACCESS REFER?
AND.
WHERE FOR ONE HUNDRED ONE
HUNDRED THINK YEP?
HUMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MAUREEN SIR HALL I'M A VOLUNTEER
WITH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK. I'M HERE
TODAY FOR THE SECOND TIME IN TWO
YEARS IN JUST IN SUPPORT OF AN
INCREASE TO THE SSI SSD BENEFIT
IN THE UPCOMING BUDGET.
AS A TAXPAYER I'M GREATLY
DISTURBED BY THE FACT THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS WILLING TO SPEND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON A HIGH
SPEED TRAIN THAT WILL SERVE SUCH
A SMALL PROPORTION OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION. GET REFUSE
TO SPEND THE MONEY NECESSARY TO
BRING ONE POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIA'S OUT OF POWER OUT OF
POVERTY.
GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TODAY WE CAN NO
LONGER COUNT ON CONTINUED
FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR THOSE IN
NEED. AND IS NOW EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT THE CALIFORNIA TAKES A
STAND AGAINST POVERTY AND HELPS
THOSE WHO MOST NEED IT. WHEN
THEY GO LOW WE MUST GO HIGH.
HI I'M EMILY WILSON FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY FAIR WITH CALIFORNIANS
PESTICIDE.
AND AS A IT'S BEEN MENTIONED.
SENIORS AND PEOPLE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES HAVE BEEN RECEIVING
ABOUT THE SAME AMOUNT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE. AND WE CAN
ALL IMAGINE AND KNOW HOW MUCH
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA HAS
INCREASED SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE.
AND.
WE HAVE SENIORS AND PEOPLE
DISABILITIES GOING HUNGRY AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS AND IT'S
NOT OKAY. AND WE NEED TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND RESTORE A
SOCIETY AND GET EVERYONE ABOVE
POVERTY LEVEL THINKING. WE CAN.
YEAH THANK YOUR TURN THIS THING
OFF.
I'M HAVING PROBLEMS WITH A SO SO
I.
BECAUSE EVERY MONTH.
THEY ARE HAVEN'T DICKEY MONEY
OUT OF MY CHECK.
SHE IS NOT SUFFICIENT WITH ME.
BECAUSE IN THAT PLEASE WITH
DRUGS OUT OF THE MONTH EVEN WITH
MY SOCIAL SECURITY CHECK. IT
DOESN'T LEAVE ME MUCH FOR THE
REST THURMOND AND THEY'RE DOING
OVERPAYMENTS ON ME AND NOT.
TELLING ME WHY.
AND I'D LIKE TO FIND OUT WHAT I
CAN DO ABOUT IT.
YOU MAKE YOU.
CARLY FINKLE AT THE FOOD BANK OF
CONTRA COSTA AND SOLANO.
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A
HUNDRED FOR A HUNDRED AND ALSO
HERE REPRESENTING ALL THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO WANTED TO
BE ON THE BUS UP FROM THE BAY
AREA WITH US TODAY BUT WHO
WEREN'T ABLE TO MAKE IT.
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN POOR
HEALTH FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT
THEY QUALIFY FOR SSI AND JUST
SAYING THAT ALL OF THE VOICES IN
STORIES THAT HAVE COME. UP HERE
TODAY IS JUST A TINY SLIVER OF
ALL THE PEOPLE ON SSI WHO
DESERVE TO BE HEARD AND WHO
DESERVE TO LIVE DIGNIFIED LIVES.
AND THE LIVES OF THEIR LIVING
BELOW NINETY PERCENT OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE THINK YOU.
HUMAN.
MY NAME IS CINDY SIEGEL AND I AM
PART OF THE FOOD BANK CONTRA
COSTA AND SOLANO COUNTY I HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING ON THE
ADVOCACY COMMITTEE.
AS A FOOD BANK AND IT'S NOT
JUST BECAUSE THEY GIVE GOOD
SWAG.
.
THE THE PRIVILEGE THAT I HAVE
ISN'T IN SERVING.
KICKED MY COMMUNITY THROUGH A
PRODUCE GIVEAWAY THAT I.
TEN THAT THE CLINIC A WHICH
SIDE YOU'RE BY WHERE I LIVE.
AND.
AFTER DOING THIS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS AYE I KNOW THE CLIENTS BY
NAME.
AND ON THE ONE HAND THAT ALLOWS
ME TO HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM THAT I WOULDN'T ORDINARILY
HAVE HAD. BUT ON THE OTHER HAND
IT PAINS ME.
ESPECIALLY THE SENIORS THAT I
KNOW WHO'S GROCERS I TAKE TO.
THEIR CARS.
AND WHO WE OFTEN I TRY TO HELP
INCLUDING COULD ADDITIONAL WAYS
IT PAINS ME TO KNOW THEIR NAMES.
BECAUSE.
BECAUSE IT MEANS THEY STILL NEED
US MUCH MORE THAN THEY PROBABLY
SHOULD.
AND I HEARD ANOTHER MEMBER OF
THE FOOD BANK TALK ABOUT HOW.
YOU KNOW WITH THE DRACONIAN.
CUTS THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS ON HAS MAJORS PLENTY TO
MAKING THE TAX CUTS.
WE GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DO A LOT MORE WITH LESS
POTENTIALLY.
AND SO HUNDRED FOR A HUNDRED YOU
KNOW.
IT'S THE ONE THING WE CAN DO AS
A STATE RIGHT.
WE OBSERVE ORGANIZATION ARE NOT
GOING TO WALK AWAY FROM OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND I'M JUST HERE
TO SAY THAT I I I KNOW YOU WON'T
WALK AWAY FROM YOURS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
TRACY PATTERSON WITH CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GRANT
INCREASE.
HERE AGAIN YEAR AFTER YEAR IS
JUST UNCONSCIONABLE THAT THE
WEALTHIEST DAY IN THE WEALTHIEST
NATION IN THE WORLD CONTINUES TO
LEAVE SO MANY PEOPLE SO FAR
BEHIND.
THANK YOU.
FUND MILTON MY NAME IS SAID
EXIT.
MEMBER OF SENIOR GROUPS THE OX
YEAR ON GOGGLE.
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT SB THIRTY
THREE HUNDRED.
PLEASE ANTONSEN
DODD DESPITE UNDER START
CHRISTMAS
IT.
THIS IS THE HIGH COST OF BELIEVE
IT AND BAY AREA.
BIGELOW BUST YOU AND THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THE HUMAN THANO
I'M WITH SENIOR IN THIS HAVE
IMMEDIATE ACTION.
.
HE NO WE JUST CELEBRATED.
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY AND
THEM THIS WILL BE VERY
APPROPRIATE.
FOR.
.
ALL OF YOU TO OF PUSH THE
GOVERNOR AND TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND.
.
MAKE WOMEN TO HAVE A BETTER LIFE
VERY STAND EARLY RP LEAVING YOU
KNOW BECAUSE. WOMEN LEAVE IN
MARCH POVERTY THAN MEN AND IT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE A PERSON THEN
LEAVE AND UNNECESSARY THEY
ALREADY ON THERE AT THEIR.
OVERLYING THE FAIRLOW PUT
FEDERAL POVERTY LEG SORRY.
I GET. MY LOOK. WELL HANG REYES
GETS.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE HERE TO.
ASK YOU TO PLEASE UP INCREASED
THEIR ONE HUNDRED PER DAY ONE
HUNDRED THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
IT IS GREAT.
WHEN ASKED THAT THIS
ME NUMBER S. MONEY AWAY LITTLE
BIGOT ASSIA.
YEAH BANG COOPER YANDLE LA
PROPUESTA.
THEY A. IN ASEAN BODICE.
MEANWHILE THE SAN FRANCISCO.
THE BUT I'M ALSO PROCESS INTO
FECES AND THAT YEAH.
BLOODIED UP AND GOTTA EAT
POLITICAL DEVELOPMENT NECESITO
THIS.
IT THE NAME MOST CANOPIC
ANOMALOUS OF MEDICAL IMAGE GET.
CRISIS IN YOUR.
OF THAT ARE GOING TOWARD A.
I. KNOW THERE'S MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO DON'T SO I HAVE
TRANSLATE.
I THOUGHT EVERYBODY WAS REALLY
SCARY.
THE SO HER NAME IS TIME LUPITA
AND.
.
SHE'S HERE.
TOO SO POOR THEY INCREASE OF
THE ONE HUNDRED FOURTH AND ONE
HUNDRED AND HAVE SHE COMES FROM
SAN FRANCISCO'S. A SHE SAID THAT
FOUND THE COST OF LIVING IN
SENTENCES CHO IS REALLY HIGH AND
SO IS NOT ENOUGH TO COVER ALL
THEIR KNEES.
SEE IS THAT THIS IDEA.
BUT I'M A HOPELESS PUBLIC ALSO
COULD NOT SUPPORT GETTING ONE
NEED A LOT LESS EITHER I WAS
POLICY IN THE LATEST MUST.
BUT ACCORDING TO THE.
WHAT DOES CUSTOM SCAN ON A
SCHOOL DAY? E. IT WAS OUT
ASSEMBLY ANTEMANO.
SO WHAT THE NCO.
AND. SO SHE SAID IT WOULD BE
FABULOUS IF YOU CAN ALISO BURRIS
IN GIVE US AT INCREASED THAT CAN
HELP US GO OVER THINGS THAT ARE
NOT COVERED BY MEDICAID.
SO I AND SHE THANK YOU. YOU KNOW
BECAUSE SHE THINKS THAT YOU'RE
GONNA BE DOING THE RIGHT THING.
HELLO UP WHEN I SPENT THIS.
WE NUMBER EFFORT THAT FALLING ON
IT TO YUKI.
AND THERE TO EAT OUT WHEN FTA
WITH ELLIS'S HIGH YESTERDAY AT
THE PUMP UP WHAT YOU ARE. LAP
REQUEST BUT IT LOOKED AT ABOUT
IT WHEN I COME HOME TO COOK THEM
AGAIN. IF I GET THERE GOSPEL
THEM HOW WE THAT INCREMENT THAT
KIND OF IT BUT IF IT WILL KEEP
HIM BETTER EVER OKAY A PLACE WE
MUST. REPLACE IT BET THEM IN
WHAT'S LEFT OF CARE BOSS CARILLO
OF.
CHEN OR DONE ON MY SCHOOL BRAND.
BUT I HIM PLUCK IT OUT WEST BUT
YEAH HOMELESS HAPPEN THOUGH
STILL. UNBLEMISHED MIDEAST
ENOUGH.EQUIPMENT SHOULD COME
OFF SKINHEAD INCOME POLKA WITH
BUT BUT I'M A SEPARATE TIME IT
WOULD HELP TO COVER ALL
THEIR NECESSITIES. OTHER NOT
COVERED BY THEIR INSURANCE
BECAUSE.
SUCH ITS SHOES AND SOME OF THE
MEDICATION THAT ARE MICHAEL.
THINK AL SHE'S. THANKING YOU
ALSO
BECAUSE SHE THINKS THAT YOU CAN
HELP.
THE GIMMICK.
HELLO MY NAME IS ESTHER CHAMBERS
AND I'M FAIRLY NEW TO COMING
BEFORE A BODY SUCH AS THIS.
ONE OF THE THING THAT STRIKES ME
IS TWO THINGS REAL QUICKLY ONE I
FEEL I'M HONORED TO REPRESENT
PEOPLE WHO CANNOT STAND HERE.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO I SPEAK
FOR.
THE OTHER PERSON WHO I REPRESENT
IS MY MOTHER WHO PASSED AWAY.
MY MOTHER WAS A LAWYER.
SHE WAS THE THIRD AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN TO GRADUATE FROM
YALE LAW SCHOOL AND SHE SPENT
HER LIFE.
STANDING IN PLACES LIKE THIS
REPRESENTING THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO COULD NOT REPRESENT
THEMSELVES.
FOR THIS SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
I TRULY WISH TO TOUCH OUR
HEARTS.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I TRULY
HOPE.
THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT CONCERNS
ME IS THAT WHEN I LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE THAT STAND HERE. IT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THEY'RE
BEGGING.
AS IF THEY'RE DOWN ON THEIR
KNEES.
CLEARLY.
PLEASE GIVE US FOOD SO THAT WE
CAN LIVE.
IS AND WHAT.
THESE PEOPLE SHOULD BE DOING.
BECAUSE FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND.
EVERYONE WHO COMES HERE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO THROW THEIR SHOULDERS
BACK AND FEEL THAT THEY'RE
SPEAKING WITH DIGNITY.
SO I ASK YOU NOT FROM A HEART.
THAT IS BEGGING.
AYE ASK YOU TO LOOK AT ALL THE
PEOPLE AND REALIZE THEY
REPRESENT.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
WHO OR HERE TO TELL YOU THAT
THIS IS NOT A FRIVOLOUS COSTS IF
THEY'RE ASKING FOR?
IT'S A NEAT WE ARE WITNESSES.
TWO A GENUINE NEED.
SO PLEASE LOOK US DIFFERENTLY AS
NOT BURGERS.
PLEASE LOOK AT US AS WITNESSES
FOR THE JUSTIFICATION OF YOU
INCREASING THE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEASE A COLEMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION SO
TWO PARTS TO THIS. ON SSI SS P.
DOES PROVIDE A SUPPLEMENTAL FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE LIVING IN
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES AND
IT IS THE LOWEST OF OUR LOW
INCOME ASSISTED LIVING HOUSING.
AND AND WE NEED MORE OF THAT IN
THIS THIS ADJUSTMENT WILL HELP
WITH THAT. BUT ANOTHER ASPECT TO
LOOK AT WIN WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
FOOD WHEN WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MEDICATION WE KNOW HISTORICALLY
THE FOURTH WEEK OF EVERY MONTH
THERE ARE MORE VISITS TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM BROWN DEPARTMENT.
BECAUSE OF MALNUTRITION.
SO AS AN OMBUDSMAN WE LOOK AT
THIS IS A WORK DETERRENT.
IF PEOPLE HAVE PROPER NUTRITION
IF PEOPLE HAVE THE ADEQUATE
FUNDS TO TAKE THE MEDICATIONS
THAT THEY NEED THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO END UP IN OUR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ON MEDI CAL. WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN A
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH MORE TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AND WE ASK
THAT WE LOOK AT THIS AS I A COST
SAVING MEASURE TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT. AND NOT JUST A HANDOUT
THANK YOU.
HUMAN.
HI I'M SHANTI PRASAD WITH
ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD
BANK IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA HUNGER
ACTION COALITION.
INCREASING SSI ABOUT FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL IS OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY HAS BEEN FOR SEVERAL
YEARS AND IT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
AND TELL IT IS RESTORED.
I WANNA TELL YOU ABOUT COMPLETE
THURLOW FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
A WHO CAN'T BE HERE TODAY.
KIPLING TOLD ME THAT THE CUTS TO
SSI TEN YEARS AGO CAUSED THE
BEGINNING OF HER DECLINE.
IT WAS THE DEATH STROKE SHE
SAID.
HER INCOME WAS CUT BY THIRTEEN
PERCENT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
SINCE THEN SHE HAS LOST TEETH
BUT SHE CAN'T REPLACE.
HER HOME IS FALLING APART AND
SHE CAN'T AFFORD TO MAKE ANY
FIXES.
LAST SUMMER SHE SUFFERED A
DEBILITATEDMILITATE IN BIKE
ACCIDENT
AND SHE IS NOW IN A WHEELCHAIR.
SHE'S NOT HERE TODAY BECAUSE
HER CAR WITH HER WHEEL CHAIR AND
IT. WAS STOLEN LAST WEEK.
THIS IS THE STATE OF AFFAIRS FOR
OUR SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S UNETHICAL.
AND IT MAKES ME FEEL ASHAMED.
WE MUST HAVE ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
FOR ONE HUNDRED PERCENT.
I SENATOR STONE SAID IN LAST
WEEK'S BUDGET HEARING TAKING
CARE OF THE ELDERLY AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES IS A
HUMANITARIAN. ISSUE ESSENTIAL
ROLES OF GOVERNMENT.
MOST PEOPLE ON SSI ARE WOMEN OF
COLOR. MANY HAVE WORKED ALL
THEIR LIVES FOR LOW WAGES LIKE
MY MOM A FORMER SSI RECIPIENT
FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA. WHO
PASSED AWAY AT NIGHT IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THE RECESSION?
THIS IS A WOMEN'S RIGHTS ISSUE
THIS IS AN ECONOMIC JUSTICE
ISSUE. AND A HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUE.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU.
GIVEN.
IRAN IS CAROL TAYLOR I'M A
RETIRED AYE IT'S ASSESS WORKER
FROM CINEMA HAVE THOUGH IS
SIMPLY IN LAID. ON OUR UNION
HELP SPONSOR YOU.
AS I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE YOU
GUYS.
YEAH. I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU
GUYS THINK ABOUT THIS AS THEM.
AN ECONOMIC BOOST BECAUSE EVERY
SINGLE DIME IS GOING TO BE SPENT
NOBODY HAS A FOR OWING QUE
NOBODY'S INVESTING IN THE STOCK
MARKET EVERY SINGLE DIME IS
GOING TO GET. SPENT IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND I I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY JOBS A BILLION DOLLARS
CAN-CREATE BUT I SUSPECT IT'S.
A LOT.
ON IN ANOTHER THING IN AND AT
THE RISK OF MAKING EVERYONE IN
THE ROOM HATE ME. I'M NOT SURE
WHY THIS HUNDRED DOLLARS IS IN
IN FOOD STAMPS RATHER THAN CASH.
THANK YOU.
TURN AROUND AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HEADER CONTRASTS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION
WERE STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION.
OF.
ARE INFINITELY CENTER IS THAT
SIR PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU SIR.
SAVE IT TO RALLY I'M AND I HSS
WORKER. FROM LAKE COUNTY.
MY SON IS ALSO IDA SOCIETIES
FORTY ONE AND HAS BEEN ON IT
SINCE HE'S TWENTY ONE AND.
AND I SHARE THE KIDS SAME
CONCERN AS THE OTHER LADY WHO IS
HERE.
THE CHANCES ARE I WILL GO BEFORE
MY SON WAS.
AND AT NINE HUNDRED ELEVEN
DOLLARS WHICH IS WHAT HE GETS
NOW. HE WILL BE HOMELESS ON THE
STREET IF SOMETHING HAPPENS TO
BE.
I WORK.
FOR FOR CLIENTS HEATH ONE ALBUM
AND THE OTHER THREE I WORK FROM
NINE IN THE MORNING TILL NINE
TEN AND ELEVEN O'CLOCK AT NIGHT.
STAYS A WEEK.
TO MAKE ENOUGH MONEY TO TRY TO
PUT A ROOF OVER OUR HEADS.
OUR LANDLORD WASN'T PAYING THE
MORTGAGE AND WE'VE BEEN EVICTED
AYE WE ARE NOW HOMELESS.
AND WE LIVED LAKE COUNTY WHERE
THREE YEARS OF FIRES HAS CAUSED
A LOSS OF EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
HOMES.
OUR RENT HAS GONE TO ELEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND MORE ABOUT.
A ONE BEDROOM HOLE.
SO.
I AM PEAK YOU CAN DO THE MATH IF
I WASN'T WORKING MY SON WOULD
HAVE NO PLACE TO GO BUT THE
STREET.
I ASK YOU DO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS
AT IT AT ALL POSSIBLE MORE THAN
THAT.
ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS IS NOT VERY
MUCH WOULD YOU'RE WRIT IS ELEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND ALSO I ADD TO THAT THAT IF
YOU DO SUPPORT IT AND IT GETS
INTO THE BUDGET. THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO KEEP COMING BACK HERE
EVERY YEAR ASKING YOU NOT TO
TAKE IT AWAY FROM US.
BECAUSE I'M AN I EIGHT JUST US
WORKER EVERYTHING WE HAVE EVER
WON ELECTRONIC TIME CARDS.
ANYTHING.
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD TO FIGHT TO
KEEP IT.
SEVEN PERCENT THAT YOUR
CONSIDERING TAKING AWAY FROM US
WE FOUGHT AND GOT IT FOR THREE
YEARS AND NOW WE'VE GOTTA COME
BACK YOU WOULD FIGHT IT AGAIN.
SO IF YOU DO GO ALONG WITH US
HUNDRED. I SUPPORTED STRONGLY
OBVIOUSLY.
DON'T LET IT BE TAKEN AWAY NEXT
YEAR OR THE YEAR AFTER. IF ITS
GOING TO GOING TO THE BUDGET
LEAVE IT THERE PLEASE
THANK YOU.
HI I'M AIMS CHRISTINE GARCIA I
AM FROM MARYSVILLE CALIFORNIA.
ACTUALLY CAME HERE WITH MY
SISTER AND HER SON SHE CAME TO
HELP.
THE BECAUSE SHE AND HER SON.
OUR FAMILY HAS BEEN.
UNFORTUNATELY.
.
MANY OF THE MEMBERS HAVE HAD
DISABILITIES AND MY BROTHER.
THAT I GREW UP WITH WAS LIKE A
FATHER FIGURE TO ME. HE HAD A
SUFFERED FROM LH IRWIN AND LOST
HIS EYESIGHT.
BECAUSE OF THE LOW INCOME THAT
HE WAS GIVEN. HIS LIFESTYLE WAS
MOST SLEEP ON THE STREETS.
TODAY HE IS DEAD.
AND.
HOW ABOUT IN MY HEART?
I LISTEN TO ALL THESE PEOPLE AND
I HEAR THEIR SORROWS.
AND I KNOW THAT ALL OF YOU UP
THERE.
YOU HAVE YOUR OWN FAMILIES YOU
HAVE YOUR OWN LIVES.
BUT GOT IS GIVING YOU A POSITION
OF POWER. AND IT'S YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO USE IT FOR THE
BETTER OF HUMAN BEINGS.
HUMAN BEINGS WHO ARE ASKING YOU
FOR SIMPLE THINGS SUCH AS FOOD
WHEN THEY CANNOT GET IT
THEMSELVES.
I MYSELF.
WISH THAT THERE WAS MORE THAT I
COULD DO AND I'M GOING TO SEE IF
THERE IS MORE OUT THERE FOR ME
TO DO TO HELP THIS BECAUSE
BECAUSE. TO SEE THESE PEOPLE
SUFFERING THE WAY MY FAMILY HAS
SUFFERED THE WAY MY BROTHER DID
SUFFERED.
IT IT'S HEARTBREAKING.
AND FOR PEOPLE TO TURN A BLIND
EYE IF THERE IS IF THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY TO GIVE EXTRA MONEY
FOR PEOPLE TO EAT. OR HAVE
MEDICATION WINNER IN WHEELCHAIRS
WHEN THEY'RE BLIND WHEN THEY
COULD NOT NOT EVEN CARE FOR
THEMSELVES HOW COULD ANYONE SAY
NO. IF THERE'S A POSSIBILITY TO
SAY YES.
THANK YOU.
AND I'M HERE WITH.
CALIFORNIA'S OUT OF.
.
THE BAY.
AND.
.
I'M HERE ALSO AS AN IN ANNA
INDIVIDUAL.
AND.
.
I'VE BEEN OUT OF PRISON FOR
YEARS.
AFTER DOING.
THIRTY.
AND.
.
I DEFINITELY.
DEFINITELY.
ME.
HELP.
BUT.
I'M NOT JUST SITTING AROUND.
CROWN ABOUT SITUATION.
I'M PUTTING IN WORK.
I WAS HERE LAST YEAR IN MAY.
AND HAD AN AUDIENCE.
YOU I RECKON.
BRADFORD SENATOR NANCY SKINNER.
THIS IS ME SPEAKING AT THEIR RE
ENTRY SUCCESS CENTER IN
RICHMOND.
GIVEN WITH PEOPLE JUST COMING
OUT OF PRISON.
THIS IS MAY. THE INUIT THAT MEN
AND WOMEN OF VALOR.
AT THE RACETRACK.
THIS IS ME AT CONTRA COSTA
COLLEAGUES STAND AROUND FRONT.
GIVEN A SPEECH.
THEN WITH THE YOU.
VIOLENCE YOU KNOW GAINES.
DRUGS.
A THIS IS THE.
JEFF GET.
FACILITATOR.
FROM MARTINEZ.
THIS YEAR THE HARRIET TUBMAN
AWARD.
THAT OUR RECEIVES.
I'VE BEEN HOME.
.
MENTORS YOU.
AWARD.
SO I'M I'M NOT JUST SITTING
AROUND.
WAITING.
I'M.
PUTTING IN WORK.
BUT.
THEY IN AWAY OUT OF SOCIETY.
THERE YEARS
AND BEING HOME FOR.
AND WHEN I'M IN SCHOOL.
NOW I'M IN BERKELEY CITY COLLEGE
WHEN I'M AT SCHOOL RIGHTS
PLAYING TO THE STUDENTS THAT
THIS SPOON. TO ME IS HARDER MORE
DIFFICULT THAN THOSE THIRTY
YEARS WHERE.
BEING CARVE OUT DIDN'T OUT OF
SOCIETY YOU NOT GONNA COME HOME
AND JUMP INTO REYES AND JUST
TAKE ALL BLENDED BANG JOHNSON
SAY. YOU CANNOT TAKE A PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN HOBBLED BY CHAINS
FOR TWO HUNDRED YEARS TAKE TO
CHANGE I'LL BRING TO US DIED
NINE IS THAT NOW YOU ARE FREE TO
COMPETE. IT JUST DON'T WORK LIKE
THAT.
SO.
I'M ON AS IF THAT.
BUT I NEED SOME MORE MONEY.
I NEED SOME HELP.
I CAN RELATE TO THIS DIRECTLY.
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH VERY I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF KYLE.
COALITION A CALIFORNIA'S
FRANCIS I.
AGAIN.
I THINK I'VE BEEN HERE SINCE
PROBABLY THE CUTS.
WERE BEING INTRODUCED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE ROUGHLY PROBABLY
ALMOST THE WHOLE TIME.
I UNDERSTAND IT THE LEGISLATION
AND OUR LEGISLATORS HAVE AN
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT.
FOR BECAUSE AND THEY WANT TO
SEE THIS.
RESTORE ALL TAKE PLACE IN AND
LET'S LET'S GET IT WE WE
INTERCHANGEABLY USE THE WERE
REYES.
AND RESTORE A LIST THIS IS NOT A
REYES THIS IS A RESTORE ALL TO
CUTS THAT WERE MADE SO LET'S GET
THAT FIRST OFF.
AYE IMPLORE YOU GUYS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN YOU WERE IN YOUR
CIRCLES AND YOUR YOU KNOW YOUR
POLITICKING AND YOU'RE SPEAKING
TO THE GOVERNOR'S PEOPLE IN
THOSE THINGS. THAT YOU.
.
SPEAK WITH THIS BECAUSE WE WITH
GREAT URGENCY AND AM AND MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
HOW HOW. DIRE THE SITUATION IS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE NEED ARE
LEGISLATORS TO DO AT THIS POINT.
IT'S THAT IT YOU KNOW.
PREACHING TO THE CROWD IF YOU
WILL WE NEED TO PREACH TO THAT
ONE OFFICE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE THAT THEY'RE ON BOARD
WITH GETTING THIS IN THE BUD YOU
ONCE AND FOR ALL.
.
YOU KNOW I.
THE BIG ARGUMENT AGAINST IT IS
IT IS COST THE COST SO MUCH TO
COST SO MUCH THIS IS A THIS IS A
THIS IS A BILLION DOLLAR PRICE
TAG WE'RE TALKING.
BUT.
IF YOU PUT THAT IN COMPARISON
TO THE CURRENT RAINY DAY FUND IS
ONLY ABOUT ONE FIFTEENTH OF THE
RAINY DAY FUNDS IS NOT A COST
THAT'S.
UNBEARABLE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT THIS POINT SO I I
THINK THAT THAT'S A BIG.
ARGUMENT THAT HAS TO BE
APPROACHED AND AND AND AND AND
NON COMBAT IT AT EVERY TURN.
.
LASTLY IF FINALLY A KIND IT TOO
THAT.
.
THE MORE IF THIS GOES ON IN THE
LONGER THIS GOES ON THIS TO ME
STOPS REPRESENTING THE.
FISCAL BATTLE OF BUDGETARY TYPE
OF.
RESOURCES IN AVAILABLE FUNDS
AND STARTS TO TO IS TURNING TO
ME IT'S A SOMETHING THAT'S.
LESS ABOUT MONEY AND MORE ABOUT.
STORING DEHUMANIZATION OF
DISABLED PEOPLE HERE IN THE
STATE. I THINK THAT WE'RE WE'RE
FLIRTING VERY DANGEROUSLY WITH A
DE HUMANIZING US. US SO MUCH
THAT I THINK THAT LE.
RHETORIC WILL WILL BEGIN AGAIN
ABOUT.
.
REINSTITUTING PEOPLE IN THOSE
SORTS OF THINGS IN AND THEY'LL
GUYS WITH DIFFERENT WORDS BUT.
AT THIS POINT I THINK THAT YOU
CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THAT THIS
IS TINY TOOL A BATTLE FOR HUMAN
EYES ATION MORE SO THAN DOLLARS
AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CARRY YOUNG
FOR MERCED COUNTY AND I
REPRESENT YOU D. W. HOMECARE
PROVIDERS UNION. WE SPEAK
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE US
AND AGAIN I WANT TO ECHO WHAT
THE OTHER PEOPLE HAVE SAID. THIS
IS A RESTORATION THIS ISN'T A
HANDOUT THIS IS IT RESCUE ME
THIS IS GIVEME BACK WHAT I
RIGHTFULLY HAD AND RESTORE IT
AND ALSO FOR THE SEVEN PERCENT
WHILE I'M UP HERE.
YOU TOOK AWAY TO BUILD A RAINY
DAY FUND NOW JUST PLEASE GIVE IT
BACK PEOPLE NEED THANK YOU.
HUMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ELLA
JONES
I'M A VOLUNTEER TO ADVOCATE WITH
DR CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FOODBANK.
I I HAVE FORMALLY SAT ON THE.
ADVISORY COUNCIL ON AGING AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND I WANT
COMMISSIONER ON THE.
.
CONTRA COSTA ON MANAGED CARE.
HERE.
.
PLANT. I JUST RECENTLY LEARNED
IT ON THE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
DO NOT HAVE BENEFITS FOR PEOPLE
ON SSI.
WOULD CAL FRESH.
I COME FROM THE EAST COAST.
AND I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT.
WHOEVER AND WHATEVER I WILL DO
SOME RESEARCH AND SEE WHEN THAT
HAPPENED AND WHY. BUT THERE IS
NO REASON WITH THE COST OF
LIVING AND I'VE ALWAYS ADMIRED
CALIFORNIANS FOR DOING THEIR
PART IN HELPING SENIORS AND
DISABLED PEOPLE.
AND.
.
I JUST KNOW IN CHARGE YOU THAT
YOU WILL TAKE THE VOTE IN
RESTORE THOSE THAT HUNDRED TO
HUNDRED BENEFIT BACK TO ALL THE
PEOPLE THEY NEED IT BECAUSE IT'S
SORELY NEEDED THANK YOU.
INCREMENT.
HELLO A MEDDLESOME PRICE THEN
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS BUT I HAVE
TO TELL MY STORY. AND AS I LOOK
UP YOUR ON NOTICE WELLS FARGO
BANK I WORKED THERE. I'M A BAKER
FOR OVER THIRTY IN A KNOWS THEY
DONATED I WORK FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS AT THE BANK.
I AM ON SSI BECAUSE I GOT ROTH I
WAS THE MANAGER OF ANOTHER BANK
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS SOMEWHAT WORK
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS. WHEN I
APPLY FOR MY S. ASIDE THEY
REFUSE IT
SO I SO THEY GAVE ME THAT A REAL
LOW AMOUNT.
I'VE NEVER BEEN OUT ON WHAT I
WOULD BUT THEY WERE GIVING ME
BUT I'M FINDING OUT THAT AND.
THEY GAVE ME THE ONES LIKE I'VE
NEVER WORKED BEFORE
SUB BUT I SUPPOSE UNITARIA I
DID.
EXCUSE ME BUT BASICALLY I'M
SAYING THAT.
IT'S HARD FOR ME.
I'VE WORKED.
I'VE DONE WELL SUPPOSED TO DO.
AND WHEN MY MONEY WAS KEPT GOING
DOWN I WOULD ASSUME IT WAS
PRESIDENT OBAMA I NEVER ASK
QUESTIONS OFF.
GIVE EVERY HOME.
ONE MIGHT. ADD PEOPLE WORK THEY
ALL WORK.
THEY DON'T NOT A MORAL BASIS
OUTSIDE IN KNOW WHO TO ASK SO I
START VOLUNTEERING IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT DON'T OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS BECAUSE I WAS
BORED SAID HOME. FOR BEING ON
DISABILITY FOR.
OF BECAUSE I CAN'T WORK
AND I'VE FOUND OUT THAT THE
PERSON OUT OF VOTED FOR.
GOVERNOR BROWN.
SOMEHOW I WOULD SAY HE DID A BUT
IT WAS FROM CALIFORNIA WHAT THE
MONEY MY MONEY WAS GOING DOWN.
SO I S. IS.
CONVEYED LEASE BRING IT BACK UP.
ABOUT THE POVERTY LEVEL.
AND.
.
GIVE ASSIST SOME.
FOOD STAMPS
THAT'S ALL I ASK IS I HAVE
WORKED.
FORTY YEARS AND I PUT INTO IT
AND I MADE LOOK FUN ATTORNEY SO
I CAN START IN THE RIGHT MONEY
THAT I NEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MA'AM.
THE MONEY I'M SURE WATER FROM
OAKLAND.
AND THE REASON WHY I CAME
BECAUSE.
IT IN WE NEED A HUG STATE.
SOME.
NO PERCENT MONEY FOR IT PEOPLE
DOWN ON SSI AND OPUS PLUS NEAT
FOR LIKE IN THE COUNTRY.
IT THAT MANY PEOPLE HAVE ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT ON A PACK EASY
WITH A PACKET WITH THE MONEY
FOOT BY FOOT GROCERY IN FOOD.
AND THEY NEED TO HAVE
MORE INCOME FOOT HUNG PROCEED.
QUALITY WITH THEM MORE PEOPLE
NEED A NEED TO HAVE.
A COMMUNITY AND WE NEED TO FEEL
BETTER THAT WAY.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
CHAIRPERSON ARAMBULA. MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS EITHER PAN INTO ONE
AND I'M WOOD ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK.
AT THE FOOD BANK.
OUR WORK. AND EVERYTHING WE DO
REVOLVES AROUND A MODEL.
AND THAT MOTTO IS
FOOD IS A BASIC HUMAN RIGHT.
NOW TRUST ME WHEN I SAY.
THAT WE UNDERSTAND AND
COMPREHEND FULLY.
HOW BOLD THAT STATEMENT MIGHT
SOUND?
IT IS MENTIONED IN THE UNITED
NATIONS UNIVERSAL DECLARATION OF
HUMAN RIGHTS.
BUT WE THINK THAT WE OUGHT TO
THINK ABOUT IT IN A DIFFERENT
WAY.
AND THAT MODEL.
IN TRUTH IT'S NOTHING MORE THAN
AN ARTICULATION OF A BASIC
PROMISE
THAT EACH OF US.
HAVE.
TO EACH OTHER AS MEMBERS OF ONE
SOCIETY.
AND I PROMISE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
IS THAT WE YOU SHALL INSURE.
THAT NOBODY WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS OR IN OUR
STATE.
CHAU EXPERIENCE ANYTHING LESS
THAN A LIFE
OF DIGNITY.
CHAIRPERSON ARAMBULA TODAY WE
ARE FEELING THAT PROMISE.
SO WE COME HERE TODAY AND WE ASK
FOR ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT.
PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE
NOT VIEWING THIS THROUGH THE
LENS OF A BUDGETARY ITEM THOUGH
IT IS THAT.
YOU'RE NOT NECESSARILY LOOKING
AT IT THROUGH A A PIECE OF
SOCIAL POLICY THOUGH IT IS THAT.
THE RATHER WE COME HERE.
AND WE VIEW IT AS THE DEMAND
THAT EACH OF THE FOLKS WHO
YOU'VE LISTENED TO.
DESERVE TO EXPERIENCE THE LIFE
OF DIGNITY THAT SO MANY OF US
TAKE FOR GRANTED.
AND THAT IS A LENS WHICH I
REQUEST THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
YOU THIS ISSUE AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
YEAH YOU KNOW THEY IS YELLOW AND
MY NAME IS OUT AND FOR IT I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY.
AND I'M ALSO GRAY BLOOM OF
CALIFORNIA.
I'M.
EX MEMBER MEMBER OF THE UNITED
STATES MARINE CORPS.
AND I'M ALSO SSI.
I DON'T GET NO VETERANS AND
NOTHING FROM VA.
IN NO AND.
.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE HAVE TO
SAVE THE REST OF US DIDN'T SAY
YES WE NEED TO HUNDRED DOLLARS A
YES WE DO NEED IT. WHY WE WILL
HAVE TO KEEP COMING BACK THE
NEXT FOR THE SAME MONEY ALL OVER
AGAIN I DON'T MAY NO SIX? BUT.
.
AND WE ALSO NAY FUSCO.
VALUE HER LAWS OF MOTHERS AND
AMY'S IN THEIR FATHERS TO HAVE
CHILDREN IS IN WHEELCHAIRS THIS.
DEATH HAVE AN S..
YES HAVING PROBLEMS.
THEY NEED THAT MONEY THEY NEED
TO.
YOU KNOW I COULD MYSELF I GO
RECYCLING.
I HAVE MYSELF BY DOING RECYCLING
FOR LIVE TIME WE CUT ME I DO WE
CITING.
YOU KNOW IN THERE IS NO RIGHT DO
I HAVE TO REALLY DO THAT I GOT
BETTER PROBABLY CAME STAY HERE
TOO LONG.
I'M BREAKING A SWEAT JUST FOR
STANDING HERE TALKING.
I HAVE BROUGHT CLOUDS
HOW HAVE ENCOURAGED ME ANYTIME.
TO ONE UP PIC OF A TEN HAVE AND
THE REASON.
YOU KNOW YEAH I GET YOUR MONEY
BACK WE GET.
I GET THAT BUT I GET TO GO TO
THE TO.
LIKE KICKING A GUEST.
NO WAY ANYWAY.
WE NEED TO HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
WE NEED TO STEP AS WELL OKAY I A
RAY LIKE WE GO TO TABLE AND
COOKING NO HAVE DO ALL THAT CAN
HOOK IT UP.
I KNOW HOW TO KEEP IF BELLY FAT.
NO STAND BUT.
FOR THE REST OF US THEY NEED.
BACK THEN THEY BACKED DE TALK
ABOUT HOW CHILDREN. YOU KNOW TO
ME PLEASE HAVE THEM.
HAVE DONE VERY YOU KNOW ANYONE
WHO WE GET KEEP CUTTING HER BACK
YOU COULD ME TOO BUT I KNOW HOW
TO GO OUT. AND MAKE ENDS MEET.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO THAT.
I DON'T WORK FOR NOBODY I WORK
FOR ME.
I SAID YO FLASH TO YOU KNOW
CAN'T YOU GO AWAY I'LL GO OUT
AND PICK HIM UP BUT THE GODS
CAN.
YES SAKE FOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU SIR.
ANY FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE ISSUE.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING IT BACK UP
THE DIES FOR ANY COMMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
I I'D LIKE TO START WITH.
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE THIS ONE
OUT.
AND I ENCOURAGE.
THE LA O. IN.
PART A FINANCE AND ALL YOU TO
WORK WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
AND GET THIS.
DAWN.
ARM. REAL QUICK GOING TO
ADDRESS.
.
ONE OF THE WOMEN THAT SPOKE.
MENTION THAT HER SERVICES HER
DOLLARS WERE BEING CUT AND SHE
DIDN'T KNOW WHY.
MA'AM I.
CLEARLY ENCOURAGE YOU THERE YOU
ARE.
I ENCOURAGE YOU REACH OUT TO
YOUR MEMBERS OFFICE WE DO
CONSTITUENT SERVICE WORK WERE
NOT JUST YOUR LEGISLATURE'S TO
SIT UP HERE ON THIS DYESS.
WE'RE ALSO HERE TO SERVE YOU IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES.
AND WHEN THESE ISSUES ARISE
REACH OUT TO OUR STABS AT HOME.
WE CAN OPEN UP THE CASE FILE AND
FIND OUT WHAT IS GOING ON AND
GET YOU SOME ANSWERS.
FIND OUT WHO YOUR MEMBER IS.
CONTACT THEM THEY HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THAT FOR
YOU SO PLEASE MA'AM DO THAT.
THAT IS ALL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO.
THANK YOU ABA IT'S
I'M VERY PROUD TO PARTNER UP
WITH US AND MEMBER KALRA ON THIS
ASK.
AYE AYE NEW TO THE ASSEMBLY
THIS IS MY SECOND YEAR IN MY MY
A QUESTION HAS ALWAYS BEEN IF
WE.
WE DO IT IN OUR OWN BUDGETS IF
IF WE CUT OUR BUDGETS THE HOPE
AS.
THAT WE RESTORE THEM TO.
THE LEVEL THAT THEY WERE BEFORE
AND YOU ARE CORRECT THIS IS NOT
AN ADDITIONAL REQUEST ASSISTANCE
TRYING TO RESTORE WHAT WE. HAVE
TAKEN AWAY FROM YOU THROUGH THE
BUDGET CRISIS AND I I THINK YOU
FOR COMING UP TO US AND. HA
ADVOCATING FOR FOR YOURSELVES
AND ADVOCATING FOR MEMBERS OF
YOUR FAMILIES AND YOUR
COMMUNITIES.
I THINK THAT
FOR US UP HERE AND I DO SPEAK
FOR THIS COMMITTEE I'VE BEEN
WITH THEM FOR FOR THE LAST YEAR
AND WE. WE FEEL YOU WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH. OUGHT WE'VE SEEN MANY
OF YOU MULTIPLE TIMES AND WE
APPRECIATED AND I DO AGREE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS YOU MUST
REACH OUT TO YOUR. OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BUT ALSO REACH OUT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE MAKE THOSE
PHONE CALLS TO HIM TOO BECAUSE
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE CAN
ADVOCATE FOR YOU BY. THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS ONE THAT
ULTIMATELY MAKES THOSE DECISIONS
AND SO WE APPRECIATE HEARING
FROM YOU BUT THEY ALSO NEED TO
HEAR FROM YOU AS WELL. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE WE APPRECIATE YOU
AND I WE WILL DO WHAT WE CAN TO.
HOPEFULLY GET SOME OF THAT MONEY
RESTORED.
HOPEFULLY THE HUNDRED PERCENT
BUT IF WE CANNOT MORE WORK FOR
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT WE CAN THANK
YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHAT.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE REPRESENTING
ALL THOSE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T BE
HERE TODAY AND I KNOW THERE ARE
THERE ARE LOTS AND LOTS OF
PEOPLE OUT THERE. THIS IS
ALWAYS.
.
AS ALWAYS REALLY HEART WRENCHING
FOR US TO HEAR THE STORIES OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING IN THE
WAY THAT THAT YOU ARE.
WE WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO RESTORE THE HUNDRED.
TWO HUNDRED PERCENT.
IT'S A.
IT'S MIND BOGGLING THAT HERE WE
ARE POST RECESSION.
AND WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
RESTORE THIS AND YET WE'VE
RESTORED SO MANY OTHER PROGRAMS
IN THE STATE TO THE FULL LEVEL
THEY WERE AND EVEN INCREASED
OTHER PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE TO DO BETTER AND YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO COME BACK YEAR
AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR AS WELL.
WE'RE GONNA WORK TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN FOR YOU AND I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
TODAY BRINGING YOUR STORIES. AND
I KNOW IT'S NOT EASY TO TRAVEL
HERE.
BUT WE HEAR YOU AND WE'LL WE'LL
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN FOR YOU
THANK YOU.
I TOO WANTED TO. SHARE WITH THE
FACT THAT SO MANY OF YOU
TRAVELED SO FAR TO COME AND
SHARE YOUR TESTIMONY.
THE NEED FOR INCREASING SSI IN
ESSAYS P. FOR RECIPIENTS IS
CLEAR.
PLEASE KNOW THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT STRATEGIES ON HOW WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH SOMETHING MEANINGFUL
IN THIS AREA AS WE COMBAT SENIOR
POVERTY OR. JUST POVERTY IN
GENERAL. IN A CALIFORNIA THAT'S
DIVIDED AND MORE.
INTO A DEEPENING INCOME
INEQUALITY.
WE'LL BE LOOKING CLOSELY AT ALL
OPTIONS THAT ARE ON THE TABLE AS
WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AND
WE'RE CRAFTING OUR ASSEMBLY
VERSION. OF THE BUDGET.
BUT I DO FEEL INCLINED TO SAY
THAT LAST YEAR THIS BODY WANTED
TO INCLUDE A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT.
INTO OUR BUDGET AND BELIEVE THAT
WE WILL WANTS TO MAKE AND
CONTINUE THAT SAME STYLE OF
DISCUSSION.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN HELP TO
RESTORE.
WHAT WAS TAKEN FROM THOSE
BEFORE?
FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
WE ALSO WILL BE LOOKING AT HOW
WE CAN BE ASSISTING.
ON.
FIGURING OUT IF THERE IS A
PATHWAY FORWARD WITH
FOOD STAMPS.
THE LAST YEAR AS YOU WILL SEE ON
ISSUE TO WE WILL BE DISCUSSING
IF THERE IS A POSSIBILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA. TO BE THE FINAL
STATE TO INSIST THAT FOOD STAMPS
SHOULD GO TO THOSE WHO ARE ON
SSI AND ASSESS BE.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE ONE
OPEN AND MOVE ON.
TOO I BELIEVE ISSUE FOR JUST
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE HAVE TO MAKE
A FLIGHT.
SO WE CAN HAVE WILL LIGHT BORN
STAY THERE. JUSTIN GUARANTEES TO
COME OUT.
GO FOR THAT.
THANK YOU ARM AGAIN WILL LIGHT
BORN DIRECTOR OF THE STATE STATE
PARTNER SOCIAL SERVICES. ARMS
THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM AS YOU KNOW IS
ESSENTIALLY THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIANS HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED.
SERVICE SYSTEM.
ON WHAT IT IS ON.
LARGER BY A MEASURE OF MANY
TIMES THE NEXT LARGEST STATES
OFFERING ON THIS KIND OF H. CBS.
ON AND IT'S A MATTER OF I THINK
SATISFACTION AND PRIDE TO
CALIFORNIA BUT WE'RE ONE OF THE
FEW STATES.
THAT SPENDS MORE OF OUR MEDICAID
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
DOLLARS IN HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES RATHER THAN
INSTITUTIONAL CARE SO WITH THAT
I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER AGAIN
TO. W. THOMPSON FROM ADULT
PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON AGAIN DEBBIE THOMPSON
WITH ADULT PROGRAMS.
CDSS
AND YOU ALSO HAVE A HAND OUT TO.
THAT WAS PROVIDED THAT GIVES AN
OVERVIEW OF THE I. H. SAYS
PROGRAMS AND SOME OF THE
ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE. BEEN GOING
ON IN THAT PROGRAM IN THE LAST
YEAR.
LA I WILL AYE AGAIN WALK
THROUGH THE POWER POINT AND
POINT OUT WHAT IT CONTAINS.
HAPPY TOO THEN RESPOND TO ANY.
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IN ANY PARTICULAR
AREA OR QUESTIONS ON THIS.
HAND OUT OF IT ALSO COVERS
ANOTHER ITEM ON THE AGENDA
AROUND THE ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION SO.
WE CAN CERTAINLY COVER THAT. THE
OTHER TIME THIS WELL.
THE BEGINNING OF THE POWER
POINT.
GIVE SOME INFORMATION GENERAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE I JUST US
PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY WERE SERVING OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND RECIPIENTS
AND CLOSE TO.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND CARE
PROVIDERS THAT PROVIDE SERVICES
TO. THOSE INDIVIDUALS ON THAT
SLIDE THREE BREAKS OUT A LITTLE
BIT OF INFORMATION REGARDING.
THE AGE GROUPS THAT WE SERVE
WITHIN THE POPULATION NOW
FIFTEEN PERCENT OVER EIGHTY FIVE
YEARS OLD.
THEN BECAUSE SITE FOR. COVERS
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THIS
PROGRAM IS IS FUNDED.
WILL BE ACTUALLY HAVE FOUR
COMPONENTS TO THE AYE TO SUSS
PROGRAM. FROM THREE OF AT TWO OF
THEM ARE SHARE.
HAVE A FIFTY PERCENT SHARE THE
COMMUNITY FIRST CHOICE OPTION
PROGRAM HAS A FIFTY SIX PERCENT
FEDERAL SHARE AND THEN WE HAVE
OUR.
SMALL REMAINING RESIDUAL
PROGRAM THAT IS FUNDED WITH
STATE AND COUNTY FUNDS.
.
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN PROTECT
PROJECTED BUDGET.
FOR.
AYE HHS IS ELEVEN POINT TWO
BILLION.
.
THAT'S ON SHOWS YOU THAT BREAK
OUT ON PAGE FIVE.
AND THEN THE NEXT FEW PAGES GO
THROUGH SOME ADDITIONAL AYE DATA
AROUND THE MAKEUP OF OUR
PROGRAM.
ON PAGE SEVEN YOU'LL SEE SOME
SOME GENERAL INFORMATION THAT
OFTEN INDIVIDUALS ARE INTERESTED
IN. SUCH AS.
MORE THAN HALF OF OUR RECIPIES
PROVIDERS LIVE WITH ARE
RECIPIENTS OF CARE.
.
ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT OF OUR
PROVIDERS WORK FOR A SINGLE
RECIPIENT.
.
FOR IT GIVES YOU A BREAK OUT AT
THE BOTTOM OF THAT SLIDE OF KIND
OF THE RELATIONSHIP.
OF OUR PROVIDERS AND RECIPIENTS.
SLIDE EIGHT BRINGS US INTO SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FAIR LABOR
STANDARDS ACT RULES AROUND OVER
TIME THAT CHANGED.
.
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO NOW. AND
THEN THE NEXT FEW SITES PROVIDE
INFORMATION. OF.
THAT.
LIVE SHARED WITH YOU A NUMBER
OF TIMES AROUND VIOLATIONS AND
EXEMPTIONS.
HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS
ON THOSE.
WE ALSO HAD LAST YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE OF CODIFYING THE
EXEMPTIONS.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF.
IMPLEMENTING ALL OF THOSE NEW
RULES.
DISC THAT COUNTIES WILL BE
TAKING OVER DECISION MAKING OF
THE EXEMPTION TO USE.
AND THE STATE WILL HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW PROCESS
THAT WILL BE PUT IN PLACE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH. THE ADVOCATES
THAT SUPPORTED THIS LEGISLATION
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION PROCESSES
WE HAVE DIRECTION THAT WILL BE.
RELEASED SHORTLY AND THE
TRANSITION TO THE COUNTY SYSTEM
HAPPENED IN MAY.
I BELIEVE YOU'RE PRESENTING ON
ISSUE SIX CAP AND MY TIME HOMES
OR EVEN. IF I CANNOT WE DON'T DO
UNTIL A LITTLE SIX.
YEAH IF THAT'S OKAY FOR NOW AND.
.
STOP. TECH. IS THERE ANYTHING
ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE
CURRENTLY ON THE STATE COUNTY
COST SHARING CHANGES.
IF I MAY JUST INTRODUCE IT AS
YOU'LL RECALL THAT WHEN THE
STATE INITIATED COORDINATED.
CARE THE CONTINUE THE
COORDINATED CARE INITIATIVE
WHICH WAS.
IS AN ATTEMPT TO BRING ALL OF
THE LONGTERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS INTO A MANAGED CARE
ENVIRONMENT STARTING OUT IN.
WHAT AMOUNTED TO SIX COUNTIES IN
THE EXPECT?
POSSIBILITY OF EXPANSION.
AFTER THE FIRST OF SEVERAL YEARS
OF THE CCI IMPLEMENTATION IT WAS
DETERMINED THAT IT WAS NOT IN
FACT.
ARM COST ADVANTAGEOUS TO THE
STATE HAS HAD ORIGINALLY BEEN
PROJECTED.
AND.
BASED ON THAT THE EYE EXERCISE
PROGRAM WAS DE LINKED FROM THE
OF THE CCRI.
NOT HAVE AN AFFECT ON THE
FINANCING ARRANGEMENT HE TO PUT
IN PLACE AND SO OVER A PERIOD OF
SOME MONTHS.
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
COUNTIES THROUGH C. SACK
ALL NEGOTIATED A REPLACEMENT
SYSTEM OF FINANCING THAT IS NOW
IN PLACE.
IT INVOLVES A.
CHANGED COST SHARING RATIO IS
INVOLVED THE MAINTENANCE OF
EFFORT COMPONENT OF MAINTENANCE
ABOUT BUT GROWTH COMPONENT.
PROVIDES THAT OF
AFTER TWO YEARS OF THIS PROCESS
THERE WILL BE A LOOK BACK.
AT WHICH POINT.
DISPUESTOS OF OUR. GROUP
EXAMINATION OF HAVE THE
REALIGNMENT FUNDS FLOWED IN THE
WAYS THAT WERE EXPECTED.
ARM THEN DOESN'T NEED ANY
FURTHER ON.
COMMENDATION.
ON ADDITIONALLY IN THE CURRENT
YEAR AND WITH LEGISLATION JUST
ADOPTED LAST WEEK INSIDE THIS
WEEK BY THE GOVERNOR. ARMED
THERE WERE SOME CHANGES MADE TO
THE SUPPLEMENTAL WAGE
PROVISIONS.
ON DOT A SPY SENSUALLY ARE
INTENDED TO FACILITATE COUNTIES
THAT WISH TO ANTICIPATE
INCREASES IN THE MINIMUM WAGE.
TO FORM THOSE WITHOUT. TAKING ON
ALL OF THE COST OBLIGATIONS OF
SUBSEQUENT MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES
THOSE ARE NOW IN PLACE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE.
AND WE
EXPECT THAT TO SORT OF.
FLOW FORWARD PALM.
QUESTION THAT WAS POSED LAST
WEEK AND SENATE HEARING WAS HOW
HAS THE BARGAINING RELATIONSHIP
GONE THAT POINT I SAID AS FAR AS
WE KNOW SMOOTHLY THAT WE WEREN'T
AWARE OF ANY.
ALL.
SITUATIONS IN WHICH LABOR HAD
REQUESTED THAT COUNTIES GO TO A
VERY.
FACT FINDING MEDIATION PROCESS
WHICH SUBSEQUENTLY LEARNED THAT
THERE ARE FIVE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH THAT HAS HAPPENED
SO.
MORE TO COME SEE HOW THAT
RESULTS IT'S.
I THINK IT DIRECTOR.
JUST UNDER THE SEAT.
HOW IT JUSTIN GARRETT OUTLETS
THAT REPRESENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES SOMEONE I THINK THE
CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO? TALK THE
TODAY TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE
ACCESS FISCAL STRUCTURE.
ALSO WANNA OF KNOWLEDGE THE
STRONG PARTNERSHIP WITH THAT
TIME AND SOCIAL SERVICES AND
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ON
IMPLEMENTATION.
HE'S BEEN REALLY SUBSTANTIAL
CHANGES IN COUNTIES OF PARTNER.
TO. ACHIEVE SUBSTANTIAL
PROGRESS IN IMPLEMENTING THEM
THROUGH THIS FIRST YEAR. ON THIS
PROGRESS IS INCLUDED
ESTABLISHING THE NEW COUNTY
MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT. AS WELL
DETERMINE THE PROCESS FOR HOW TO
REDIRECT THE REALIGNMENT GROWTH
FUNDING HARM TO SOCIAL SERVICES
TO OFFSET. AYE SAYS CASAS IS
FUNNY WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN
USE FOR VITAL HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
ON THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
FRONT WE AGAIN APPRECIATE. THE
PARTNERSHIP IN ATTORNEY NAM HOW
THE BEST WAY TO IMPLEMENT THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES THERE WERE
AND.
IT'S PRETTY THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL ADOPTING AB ONE TEN AND
THAT GOING INTO ON THAT ARE
REALLY ALLOW. A VITAL GUIDANCE
TO MOVE FORWARD TO COUNTIES ON
HOW THESE TOOLS TO WORK AND HOW
TO CALCULATE COSTS FOR POTENTIAL
INCREASES SEWER.
APPRECIATE THE PROGRESS THERE.
FOR COUNTY ADMINISTRATION
FUNDING WITH THE CHANGES THAT
ARE YOU KNOW WE'RE REALLY. ARE
LOOKING FOR IN SUPPORT OF THE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS TO
DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING NAM TO ENSURE THAT. I
COUNTY COST ADMINISTER THIS
PROGRAM ALIGN APPROPRIATELY WITH
STATE FUNDING.
I'M LOOKING AT THE BIG PICTURE.
YOU KNOW COUNTIES ARE MANAGING
TO.
YOU HANDLE THE IMPACT OF THIS
THIS NEW KASHIF THEM IN THE
FIRST TWO YEARS IN MOVING
FORWARD ON IMPLEMENTATION BUT
I'M. YOU KNOW WE COUNTIES
MAINTAIN THOSE OUT YOUR CONCERNS
ABOUT WHAT THIS DEAL WILL LOOK
LIKE COME YEARS DOWN THE ROAD
AND SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I'M.
HIGHLIGHTING THE OVERCOME THAT
WE OPEN A PROVISION ON THE SKIN
IT REMAIN A TOP PRIORITY FOR
COUNTIES.
THE ABILITY TO REEXAMINE THIS
FUNDING STRUCTURE AND AND LOOK
AT THE IMPACT ON OTHER
REALIGNMENT PROGRAMS I'M WITH
THE REQUIRED JANUARY TWENTY
NINETEEN REPORT. NOW MIDDLE BE
VITAL FOR THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE I COUNTIES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO WORK TOGETHER TO
IDENTIFY A LONG TERM SOLUTION TO
THE ENSURE THAT COUNTIES CAN
CONTINUE TO ADMINISTER. I
POSSESS AND OTHER CRITICAL
SERVICES ON BEHALF OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU.
CLICK.
I LEN DEPARTMENT FUNDS.
AS THE PANEL MENTIONED AT THIS
YEAR THE ADMINISTRATION WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE COUNTIES
DEVELOP A REVISED BUDGET
METHODOLOGY AS IT RELATES TO I
JUST US ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND
COSTS AND AS MENTIONED IN THE
AGENDA AND THE STAFF COMMENTS
ON.
OUR OFFICE.
NOTED THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS SIGNALED AND RE EVALUATING
THOSE ARE VICE BUDGETING
METHODOLOGIES AS A PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET.
I'M SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT
PARTICULAR DATA OR MEASURES TO
ASSESS THE.
.
ACCURACY OR THE REASON ABILITY
OF THE REVISED BUDGETING AND
ASSUMPTIONS MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ASSIST IN ANY WAY THE MEMBERS
AND. CRAFTING THAT LANGUAGE
YOU'RE LOOKING AT PARTICULAR
MEASURES THAT YOU MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER. THANK YOU.
WE CONTINUE COMMITTED TO THE
BUDGET DEAL REACHED LAST YEAR
AND ARE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH COUNTY AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
BUT THIS TIME WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE FOR AND IF I
MAY ASK THOSE WHO HAVE FLIGHTS
IMMINENTLY. IF THEY CAN GO FIRST
AND THEN AND IN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THE CHANNEL RESTORING OF OR
SOMEHOW THE URBAN CARRIES A
CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO CONCUR
WITH THE COMMENTS BY C. SACK.
NOTE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
THEIR URGENCY OR THAT NECESSITY
NECESSARY. FOR THE ROPER CLAWS
AND ALSO WANT TO KNOW.
MANY OTHER URBAN COUNTIES.
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE KITCHEN
ITIS ADMIN COSTS WHICH WE ARE
GETTING TO WORK WITH THE
INDUSTRY GENERALLY WHEN I THINK
THE RESTORATION. FOR GETTING TO
WORK THESE ISSUES OUT AND CLEAN
THE WAGE SUPPLEMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
SHANNON PRIMER FROM SAN DIEGO
VERY THANKFUL FOR YOU GUYS
MOVING THIS UP SO THAT I HAVE A
CHANCE TO TESTIFY BEFORE FLYING
HOME. I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
AND IF I DON'T GET A TEST FIND
THE OTHER I JUST US ONCE I'M
ALSO IN SUPPORT. OF THOSE.
I DID REALLY QUICKLY WANT TO
SAY ABOUT THAT EVEY V. PAR AS A
PARENT OF A DISABLED CHILD WHO
HAS PROTECTIVE SERVICES IF I
HAVE TO TAKE THE TIME TO DO THIS
THING.
I'M NOT GONNA BE KEEPING MY EYES
ON MY KID AND I'M NOT GONNA BE
DOING WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS PAYING ME TO DO.
SO WE NEED TO WORK WITH THE
FEDERAL.
GOVERNMENT TO TRY TO FIX THIS
PROBLEM I SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
TAKE MY KID OFF MY EYES OFF MY
KID WHEN YOU'RE PAYING ME TO
KEEP HIM SAFE.
SO I JUST LEFT AGO.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
ISSUE FOR.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING IT UP TO
THE DICE TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT AS WE
PREPARE FOR THAT WE OPEN OUR
CONVERSATION NEXT YEAR CAN I ASK
THE LA GO TO ASSIST US WITH
DRAFTING SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE.
FOR US TO CONSIDER THAT WOULD
CAPTURE THE ADDITIONAL DATA
GOALS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS
WOULD WANT TO HAVE.
THIS WOULD BE HELPFUL TO FURTHER
THE CONVERSATION AS WE CONSIDER
THE ADMINISTRATION'S JANUARY
TWENTY NINETEEN REPORT. ON THE
STATUS OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE NEW AND WE.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE FOR
OPEN.
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO
THE GROUPS ARE WITH YOU JACQUI.
I'M GOING TO BE SPEAKING FROM A
HANDOUT THAT.
SHE'S BEEN PASSED OUT THERE
ALSO OUT IN THE HALLWAY IF
PEOPLE DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO
PICK THEM UP JUST REALLY DOING A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE POTENTIAL
EFFECTS OF ENDING THE SS I CASH
OUT THEN ON PAGE ONE REAP
BRIEFLY DESCRIBE WHAT THE SS I
CASH OUT. IS IT REALLY IS A
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR STATES
WERE GIVEN THE OPTION. OF
INCREASING THE MONTHLY ASSIST P.
GRANT WHICH IS THE STATE PORTION
OF THE S. LACES P. GRANT.
A BY TEN DOLLARS IN LIEU OF
RECIPIENTS BEING ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL FOOD BENEFIT SO THIS
EFFECTIVELY CASH THEM OUT.
A FEDERAL FOOD BENEFITS CALLED
BECOME FRESH PROGRAM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE WOULD KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY IS THE ONLY STATE WITH
THIS.
WITH THE CASH A POLICY IN PLACE.
AND IF YOU MOVE.
TO PAGE TWO WE JUST NOTE THAT
AS A PART OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS ARE OFFICE WAS
TOSSED
TO WRITE A REPORT LOOKING AT THE
POTENTIAL PROGRAMMATIC AND
FISCAL AFFECTS OF ENDING THE
* I CASH OUT. AND IN THIS
REPORT WE DID FACE SIGNIFICANT
DATA LIMITATIONS BUT LUCKILY WE
WERE ABLE TO RELY ON PASSED
ANALYSIS DONE BY MATHEMATICA AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO GET A AT LEAST OF A
HIGH LEVEL PICTURE OF THE
POTENTIAL OF FACTS WHICH WE LAY
OUT. AND PAGE THREE MAINLY
THROUGH A PIE CHART AND AS YOU
SEE.
THE MAJORITY OF HOUSEHOLDS THAT
WOULD BE AFFECTED IT'S ESTIMATED
THAT THEY WOULD BENEFIT FROM AND
INDEED SSI CASH OUT MOST OF
THESE HOUSEHOLDS WOULD BENEFIT
IN THE FACT THAT THEY WOULD
BECOME. NEWLY INELIGIBLE AND
THEN AND ROLE IN CAL FRESH AND
IT'S ESTIMATED THROUGH THE
ESTIMATES FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT THEY WOULD
RECEIVE. ON AVERAGE SEVENTY FIVE
DOLLARS IN MONTHLY FOOD BENEFITS
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE THAT THERE
ARE SOME HOUSE SONGS THAT WOULD
BE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY
ENDING%
THE SSI CASH ON THIS IS MAINLY
THROUGH THE FORM OF SEEING A
REDUCTION.
AND FOOD BENEFITS THAT THE
HOUSEHOLD WOULD RECEIVE MAJORITY
OF THOSE HOUSEHOLDS INTERNET
WILL BE AFFECTED AS SEEN IN THE
PART CHART WOULD STILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR CAL FRESH BUT WOULD
RECEIVE A LOWER FOOD BENEFIT
AMOUNT. AND AGAIN IT'S EXPECTED
THAT THEIR FOOD BENEFITS ON
AVERAGE WOULD DECREASE BY EIGHTY
EIGHT DOLLARS A MONTH.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT ACROSS AND
THESE HOUSEHOLDS THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT WOULD BENEFIT IN
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS THAT WOULD BE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED. IN GENERAL
THOSE HOUSES THAT WOULD BENEFIT
TEND TO HAVE LESS INCOME THAN
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS THAT WOULD BE
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED AN OVERALL
WHEN YOU NET OUT THE LOSSES ON
THE STATEWIDE TOTAL. AND IT IS
EXPECTED THAT THE STATE BY
ENDING THE US I CASH OUT COULD
POTENTIALLY DRAW DOWN AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FOOD
BENEFITS.
MOVING ON TO PAGE FIVE.
THE S. ORAL ALSO TIME STAR
OFFICE AND TO LOOK AT POTENTIAL
OPTIONS ON FOR HOLDING
HOUSEHOLDS NEGATIVELY AFFECTED
BY AND AND YES I CASH OUT
HARMLESS. AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THE COST AND COMPLEXITY OF ANY
HOLD HARMLESS POLICY REALLY
VARIES ON. BASED OFF OF HOW YOU
STRUCTURE IT
I'M WE LAY OUT ME I MADE MAIN
FACTORS AND TO BE CONSIDERED A
CONSTRUCTING A HOLD HARMLESS ONE
BEING WHO IS ELIGIBLE. WOULD IT.
BE A TARGETED HOLD HARMLESS BUT
TARGET SPECIFIC HOUSEHOLDS BASED
OFF OF VARIOUS CRITERIA SUCH AS
NEED POVERTY HOUSEHOLD SIZE
WHETHER HOUSEHOLD HAS A CHILD
WHETHER HOUSEHOLD IS ON CAL
WORKS SIX CETERA OR WOULD IT BE
MORE EXPANSIVE APPROACH THAT
WOULD TRY TO CAPTURE. ALL
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE NEGATIVELY
HARMED.
I'M AND AGAIN THE MORE
INDIVIDUALS WITH KNOWLEDGE OF
FOR THE HOLD HARMLESS THE MORE
COSTLY THE HOLD HARMLESS WOULD
BE. ANOTHER FACTOR WOULD BE THE
DURATION OF THE HOLD HARMLESS
WOULD IT BE ISHQ A TEMPORARY
MORE LONG TERM PERMANENT HOLD
HARMLESS.
ANOTHER FACTOR TO CONSIDER IS
WHAT WOULD THE BENEFIT AMOUNT BE
WHAT THE HOLD HARMLESS SEEK TO
FULLY BACK FILL THE LOSS IN FOOD
BENEFITS OR WOULD IT SEEK TO
ONLY.
PARTIALLY.
RESTORE A THE PORTION OF THE
LOS FOOD BENEFITS THAT HOUSE
WITH MAY SEEM. AND LASTLY
ANOTHER FACTOR TO CONSIDER THAT
CONTRIBUTES TO THE COSTS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AUTOMATION
COMPLEXITY OF THE OF IT ALL IS.
AND HOW COMPLICATED WITH THE
HOLD HARMLESS BE.
AND THAT'S REALLY INFORMED BY
THE THREE FACTORS WE DISCUSSED
ABOVE.
NOBODY GOING TO MORE DETAIL OF
THE HOLD HARMLESS POLICY OPTIONS
BUT. THOSE* JUST THE BIG
OVERVIEW NOT I'LL END MY
COMMENTS WITH THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE LAY OUT IN PAGE SEVEN WHICH
WE JUST IDENTIFIED AS KEY ISSUES
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION
MOVING FORWARD. ONE IS
DEVELOPING MORE UP TO DATE
ESTIMATES ON THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT ENDING THE SSI CASH COULD
HAVE ON HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE.
GIVEN THE FACT BUT SINCE DSS
DEVELOPED THEIR ESTIMATES AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THERE'VE BEEN A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES
THAT MAY AFFECT THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT ON HOUSEHOLD SIZE THAN
THAT. AMOUNT OF BENEFITS THAT
HOW A NEWLY ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS
COULD RECEIVE AND IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY WORKING
ON UPDATING THEIR ESTIMATES.
ANOTHER KEY ISSUE FOR
CONSIDERATION IS THE STATE
REALLY IDENTIFYING WAYS TO
MAXIMIZE CAO FRESH PARTICIPATION
RATE AND THIS REALLY MATTERS AND
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE NEWLY
ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS BECAUSE.
JUST LIKE IN THE CURRENT
HELFRICH PROGRAM NOT ALL
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE ARE
PARTICIPATING IN CONFERENCE
THEY'RE NOT AND ROLLING. SO
REALLY IN THE CONTEXT OF HOW
DOES THE STATE MAXIMIZE THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FOOD
BENEFITS WE COULD DRAW DOWN BY
ENDING THE SI CASH OUT. LOOKING
AT WAYS TO FURTHER SIMPLIFIER
STREAMLINED THE APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR THOSE NEWLY ELIGIBLE
HOUSEHOLDS.
AND LASTLY IDENTIFYING WAYS TO
MITIGATE POTENTIAL AUTOMATION
AND ADMINISTRATIVE CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED BOTH WITH ENDING THE
SSI CASH OUT AND ANY POTENTIAL
HOLD HARMLESS POLICY. IS
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MAY SEEK TO FURTHER UNDERSTAND
AND THINK ABOUT.
AT WAYS TO MITIGATE ANY
CHALLENGES THAT MAY ARISE AND
WITHOUT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT LOVE MIKE HERALD
FROM.
SENATOR LONG PUBLIC.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YES MY CAR WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY AND I'M HERE
WITH LISA LOPEZ UNNECESSARY
RECIPIENT WILL SPEAK IN A MOMENT
ABOUT HER SITUATION.
SO I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT I THINK
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF. OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR US TO SIGN THE
WESTERN CENTER.
.
YOU KNOW I THINK OF THIS ISSUE
BACK CASH OUT IT'S BEEN ON THE
TABLE FOR MANY MANY MANY YEARS
THIS IS NOT A NEW SUBJECT AND.
I DO FEEL LIKE.
WITH THE REPORT THAT WAS
COMMISSIONED BY THIS BODY AND
WAS PUT TOGETHER BY THE LA EL I
THINK HAS. SORT OF. RAISE THE
GAME IF YOU WILL ABOUT. WHETHER
OR NOT THIS IS THE TIME TO BE
REALLY MOVING FORWARD ON ANY
CASH OUT AND GETTING. A SNAP
BENEFITS TO RECIPIENTS ANDI
WANT TO JUST SAY THAT WHEN YOU
TALK TO RECIPIENTS ACROSS THE
BOARD YOU HEARD MANY OF THEM
TESTIFIED JUST A FEW MINUTES
AGO.
THEY REALLY WANT SNAP BENEFITS
AND THEY KNOW WHY TO BECAUSE.
NGUYEN SNAPPERS INCOME THAT
CAN'T BE TAKEN AWAY BY RENT
INCREASES
STAYS AND WITH THEM IT'S
SOMETHING THAT PROTECTS THEM
ALLOWS HIM TO HAVE THAT FOOD
THAT THEY. ARE RIGHT NOW HAVING
TO GO TO SO MANY THE FOOD BANKS
AND OTHER FOOD PANTRIES TO GET
ASSISTANCE FOR. BUT WHEN WE'VE
SPOKEN WITH CLIENTS THAT WANT TO
BE REALLY CLEAR WE SHARED WITH
HIM THE RESULTS OF THE ALLEY
REPORT AND SHOWED HIM THAT THERE
WERE GOING TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF FAMILIES WHO WERE
GOING TO LOSE BENEFITS.
THEY WERE LIKE NO WE DON'T WANT
IT TO END CASH OUT ON THE BACKS
OF OTHER PEOPLE.
THIS HAS TO BE DONE IN A WAY IN
WHICH EVERYONE GETS TO KEEP
THEIR BENEFITS IF THEY ARE
CURRENTLY GETTING THEM WE DON'T
WANNA HURT ANYBODY. YES WE WANT
TO GET OUR SNAP BENEFITS AND WE
THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
DO BUT WE HAVE TO FIGUREOUT A
WAY TO DO THIS IN A WAY WHERE IN
WHICH WE DON'T HARM FAMILIES WHO
WERE LIVING IN POVERTY ALSO. SO
I'D I THINK THERE WAS THERE'S
SOMETHING QUITE NOBLE ABOUT THAT
AND I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT.
ALL OF US WHO WERE WORKING UP
HERE IN THE CAPITAL NEED TO TAKE
NOTE OF AND REALLY TRY TO
ENDEAVOR AND MOVE TOWARDS.
YOU KNOW.
.
YOU KNOW WE FEEL LIKE WE'RE AT
THIS POINT NOW WHERE WE MUST
MOVE BEYOND. YOU KNOW LET'S
COULD PRODUCE ANOTHER REPORT
LET'S.
LET'S THINK ABOUT IT SOME MORE
AND WE NEED TO MOVE TOMORE OF
AN ACTION ORIENTED APPROACH. AND
SO WHAT WE ARE RECOMMENDING FOR
THE SUBCOMMITTEE IS TO DIRECT
THE DEPARTMENT. OF AND THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND PARTLY SO
SERVICE THAT IS TO WORK WITH US
WORK WITH ALEJO AND OTHERS TO
TRY TO REALLY DIG DOWN INTO SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE JUST
BEEN RAISED BY THE LA GO.
BY THE TIME THE MAY REVISE AND
GIVE THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
OTHER THIS OTHER COMMITTEE IN
YOUR.
COUNTERPART IN THE SENATE
INFORMATION ON A NUMBER OF KEY
QUESTIONS WHICH WE THINK WE NEED
TO GET ADDRESS.
ONE WE WE WE THINK THAT APART WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT APARTMENT
COMEBACK TO THE LEGISLATURE INTO
ADVOCATES AND STAKEHOLDERS WITH.
SOME OPTIONS FOR HOLD HARMLESS
WHAT WOULD HOW WOULD THEY WORK
WHAT WOULD BE THE COST OF THEM
WHAT WOULD BE THE WAYS THAT
WE'VE DELIVER THAT BENEFIT TO
PERSONS AND WHAT ARE THE TRADE
OFFS. OF USING ONE DELIVERY
SYSTEM OVER ANOTHER ONE AND WHAT
ARE THE COSTS THAT MIGHT BE
IMPLICATED FROM THOSE VERY STE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND
TECHNOLOGIES WITH AFTER. HAVE.
SECONDLY WE THINK THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE A PLAN FOR HOW WE'RE
GOING TO DO TWO THINGS ONE HOW
DO WE IN ROLE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY SSI RECIPIENTS BUT
NOT.
IN SNAP WHAT IS THE ROLL OUT
PLAN MUCH AS WE DID WITH COVERED
CALIFORNIA WHEN WE HAD THE ACA
THE STATE HAD TO DEVELOP A VERY.
SOPHISTICATED AND SMART PLAN
AND WE KNOW HOW TO DO THIS THE
STATE IS REALLY GOOD AT IT BUT
WE NEED TO HAVE THAT PLANET
NEEDS TO BE THOUGHT THROUGH AND
I WOULD SUGGEST THIS COMMITTEE
NEEDS TO KNOW WHAT THE COST OF
THAT'S GOING TO BE. SO THAT WE
DO IT EFFECTIVELY AND QUICKLY.
AND THEN THIRD.
WE WOULD THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN OURSELVES WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW WHAT ALL THE LEGAL
STEPS IN TIME LINES ARE TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THIS POLICY.
WHAT'S REQUIRED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS TERMS OF
PERMISSION IF SUCH A THING IS
REQUIRED WHAT WAIVERS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT NEED TO SEEK IN WHAT
WOULD BE THE TIMELINE. FOR
SEEKING THOSE IN GETTING THOSE
BACK.
AND THEN I THINK.
YOU KNOW HAVING ALL THAT
INFORMATION IN HAND.
THEN I THINK IT WOULD BE.
MORE POSSIBLE FOR US TO ARRIVE
AT A DECISION ABOUT WHETHER NOT
WE WANT TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
ENDING CASH OUT OR NOT.
AND I WANT TO UNDERSCORE AGAIN
THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISIONS ARE REALLY
CRITICAL.
WE IF WE CAN ARRIVE IT I THINK
A COMPROMISE AMONG ALL THE
PARTIES ON THIS.
THAT WOULD BE REALLY SOMETHING
SPECIAL AND I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING TO REALLY STRIVE FOR
IF WE CAN GET IT DONE IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET.
IF NOT I THINK WE AT LEAST HAVE
A GAME PLAN SET DOWN WE WILL
KNOW WHAT ALL THE ANSWERS ARE
ALL THE STEPS ARE EVERYTHING IF
WE CHOOSE IN THE FUTURE. TO MOVE
ON ENDING CASH OUT WE WILL BE
FARTHER MUCH FURTHER ADVANCED IN
ACHIEVING THAT GOAL IN THE TIME
COMES.
FOR NOW THOUGH I THINK WE ARE
TO KEEP OUR.
FOOT TO THE PANEL.
IN THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS AND
TRY TO SEE HOW FAR WE CAN GET
AND.
SEE IF THIS IS THE YEAR THAT WE
CAN FINALLY BEGIN TO END CASH
OUT IN CALIFORNIA AND JOIN THE
OTHER FORTY NINE STATES.
AND WITHOUT I'M GOING TO ALLOW
MISS LOPEZ TO TELL YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HER SITUATION.
I'M MY NAME'S LISA LOPEZ.
I AM ON THE BOARD AB SHE
COMMITTEE FOR THE FOOD BANK
ACCOUNT CONSTANCE LONG COUNTY.
LIKE I SAID I AM ALSO NECESSARY
RECIPIENT WHO DOES NOT QUALIFY
FOR CAL FRESH
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
YOU'RE.
I'M FROM LOS VEGAS NEVADA WHERE
THEY YOU CAN GET YOUR SSI AND
FOOD STAMPS
OKAY.
WHY IS CALIFORNIA STATE WHAT
MAKES US SO?
NOT UP TO PAR TO BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE FOOD STAMPS
WHAT MAKES US LESS ELIGIBLE OR
LESS OF A HUMAN BEING.
IF ANYBODY.
GOD FOR BID. ANYBODY'S FAMILY
MEMBERS WAS GOING TO WHAT WE
WERE GOING THROUGH WOULDN'T YOU
BE UP HERE FIGHTING TO.
SITTING HERE GOING WHY CAN'T MY
MOTHER MY FATHER MY SISTER WHY
CAN'T THEY GET.
FOOD STAMPS.
BECAUSE TO GET US A SCIENCE A
PUNISHMENT FOR US.
I THOUGHT WE WERE TO HELP EACH
OTHER I THOUGHT WE WERE SUPPOSED
TO.
STAND UP FOR EACH OTHER HELP OUR
FELLOW MAN.
YOU KNOWN FAR BE IT FOR ME TO BE
WHAT THEY WOULD CALL A HOLY
ROLLER BUT I KNOW GOD THAT'S
WHAT GOD WANTS.
GOD WANTS US TO TREAT EACH OTHER
EQUALLY AT LEAST THAT'S WHAT I
WAS TAUGHT WHEN I WAS GROWING
UP.
OKAY IF I SEE SOMEONE ON THE
STREET AND THEY'RE STARVING. AM
I SUPPOSED TO WALK BY.
AND JUST LEAVE AMERICA.
ME I HAVE TO RELY ON FOOD BANKS
JUST TO SURVIVE.
BECAUSE I LIVE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE BAY AREA PARDON ME I'M NOT
TRYING TO BE MEAN.
BUT GUESS IT'S A BEAUTIFUL PLACE
TO STAY AND BEAUTIFUL PLACE TO
LIVE BUT WHY SHOULD EVERYTHING
BE SO HIGH PRICE.
IT'S LIKE NOBODY KNOWS WHAT THE
STORES ARE NOWADAYS DO YOU KNOW
WHAT GROCERIES COST.
IF IT'S IF.
RIDICULOUS.
OKAY BUT YET WE NEED THE FOOD TO
SURVIVE.
BUT IF RUN S. IS SAYING SHAME ON
US.
THAT'S HOW WE FEEL WE FEEL WE'RE
BEING PUNISHED BECAUSE RON SSI.
OKAY I DIDN'T ASK TO BE PUT HERE
I GOT INTO A CAR ACCIDENT TOOK
BY PROFESSIONAL WAY.
OKAY.
THAT'S NOT FAIR TO ME BUT IT'S
ALSO NOT MY FAULT.
JUST LIKE IT'S NOT ANYBODY
ELSE'S FAULT WHO WAS ON IF IF I.
BUT WE'RE TREATED THAT WAY WE'RE
TREATED THAT WE SHOULD BE
ASHAMED BE ON SSI.
BECAUSE WE DON'T QUALIFY.
WHY DON'T WE QUALIFY I DON'T GET
IT ON HUMAN BEING IF I GO TO LAS
VEGAS I'M APPOINT SOMEONE ELSE
TO HUMAN BEING TO?
WHY DO THEY?
WHERE BE ELIGIBLE TO BE ABLE TO
LIVE HUMANE?
AND WHY AM I IN CALIFORNIA
BEAUTIFUL STATE.
BUT I'M LIVING TO HELP BIG FOR
MY MONEY BACK OR FOOD.
DOES ANYBODY KNOW HAS ANYBODY
BEEN HUNGRY.
HAD YOU BEEN OUT OF FOOD HAVE
YOU GOTTEN YOUR FRIDGE. AND
LOOKED INSIDE AND SEEN IT EMPTY.
EXCEPT FOR COAL WATER MAYBE.
AND YOU DRINK COLD WATER JUST TO
FILL YOUR STOMACH UP.
YOU KNOW A BIG PERSON TRUST ME I
KNOW MY BIG PERSON PROBABLY
THERE'S PEOPLE SAYING YOU KNOW
WHY DID SHE WANT FOOD STAMPS.
I LIKE TO LIVE I WANNA LIVE.
I'M TIRED OF FEELING.
LESSER HUMAN BEING BECAUSE I GET
SSI.
WHAT DID I DO WRONG?
I CAN DO ANYTHING WRONG TO IN
BUDDY. I TRY TO HELP PEOPLE.
EVEN ME BEING ON THIS ASSIGNMENT
THERE IS SOMEONE OUT OF SIGHT
HUNGRY I KEEP IN MY PLEA.
I DON'T WANT THEM TO FEEL LIKE I
FEEL.
I DON'T WANT THEM TO BE HUNGRY
OR TO WATCH SOMEONE EAT.
YOU KNOW HOW HORRIBLE IT FEELS
WHEN YOUR BODY IS TRYING TO BUY
YOU SOMETHING TO EAT BECAUSE
THEY FEEL BAD.
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T AFFORD IT.
I CAN'T EVEN AFFORD MY
PRESCRIPTIONS.
WE'VE GOT SIX DOLLARS OVER LOVE.
AND I CAN GUARANTEE EACH ONE OF
YOU HAVE AT LEAST SIX DOLLARS IN
YOUR WALLET.
I DON'T.
MY READ IS EACH SEVENTY FIVE I
MADE NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
DOLLARS.
EMPATE.
NO YOU TELL ME IF ANYBODY COULD
TELL ME WHERE I TO PAY RENT. PAY
MY BILLS.
WITHOUT BEING WORRIED IF I'M
GOING TO BE SHUT OFF OR KICKED
OUT WHICH MERRY CHRISTMAS TO ME
I JUST GOT EVICTED TO.
BECAUSE MY WHERE MORE TO THE
WHAT A FIX ANYTHING IN MY
APARTMENT.
I'M LIVING WITH ROACHES AND MICE
WOULD YOU KNOW HOW EMBARRASSING
THAT IS TO SAY RIVER THE PEOPLE.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE TO LIVE
THROUGH.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH TO SURVIVE.
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S RIGHT AND
I DON'T THINK WITH YOUR FACE IS
THAT I'M LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW. I
KNOW YOU DON'T FEEL IT'S RIGHT
EITHER.
I KNOW YOU HAVE HEART.
WHY CAN'T WE USE THEM AND HELP
OF?
I DON'T KNOW FORMER TO BE ON THE
STREETS ARE NOT.
BUT NO MATTER WHERE I'M LIVING.
AND I WAS NEVER GIVEN A REASON.
THAT'S SAD.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE PEOPLE GO
THROUGH THAT I WANT TO SEE WHAT
I SEE IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD. LITTLE
KIDS WALKING AROUND GOING IN
DUMPSTERS TO LOOK FOR FOOD.
REALLY.
I HAVE THE SORRY PLEASE FORGIVE
ME BUT I'M VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO SEE
PEOPLE HURT.
WOULD BE TO BE ARE HURTING THE
CAN'T FUNCTION THE KIT PICK A
BATTLE EAGLE HOW ARE THEY GOING
TO HELP ANY KIND OF WAY OF
THINKING OR WORKING.
AND THEN YOU'VE GOT A CUTE
LITTER GOING WITHOUT.
BECAUSE THEY GOT S. ASIDE WE DID
GET FOOD STAMPS LOW. BUT THEY'VE
GOT TO PAY THESE OUTRAGEOUS
BILLS AND RAMPS.
IT'S NOT WHERE THERE'S A NOTE
WE'RE RIGHT NOW AND NO WIN
SITUATION.
WE NEED TO BE ON A WINNING
SITUATION AND I KNOW YOU ALL.
HAVE HEART AND COMPASSION
UNCONSCIOUS.
THEN I KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO
SEE IF SUFFER. SO PLEASE MAKE
THE RIGHT CHOICE.
GIVE US A CHANCE GIVE US A
CHANCE JUST LIVE.
BUT ALL I WANT I DON'T WANT A
CAR I DON'T WANNA BE LAMBORGHINI
I DON'T WANT A MAN SHE HAD.
LIVE.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S REALLY
TOO MUCH
ASKED IF ANYBODY.
THANK YOU LISA FOR YOUR PASSION
YOUR COURAGE IN IRAQ.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK.
DIRECTOR LIKE WARNING
CHEMICALLY WAITED FROM CAL FRESH
TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS.
OF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WILL
LIKE BORN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
ALL THEM THE.
IT DIDN'T IN MANY RESPECTS
OF.
WHAT YOU WHEN MIKE WAS SAYING
THE POLICY MOMENT MAYBE NOW?
ON.
GOOD IS WISDOM TO THAT AND BACK
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHEN
CASH OUT WAS DONE.
THE ACTUAL FOOD STAMP BENEFITS
THEN LOT RECIPIENT WOULD OVERSEE
IT WAS ABOUT TEN DOLLARS AND.
AT THAT POINT CALIFORNIA THE
BELIEF WAS IT WAS BETTER MORE
DIGNIFIED TO GIVE SOMEBODY THE
CASH AND LET THEM MAKE THEIR
DECISIONS. THEN IT WAS TO SPUR
CONTROL.
WE'RE IN A DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT
NOW.
WE HAVE A HOUSING MARKET
DASSAULT RAPACIOUS.
THAT.
ANY LITTLE GRANT INCREASE OR A
SUPPORT RIGHT INCREASES BUT I
GUARANTEE YOU THEY'RE GOING TO
GET HEAD UP.
I MEAN WE LIVE IN.
DIDN'T UNCONTROLLED MARKET YOU
HAVE A LOT OF POLICY BUT THAT.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF ADVANTAGE I
THINK POTENTIALLY AS WE CONSIDER
THE.
POLICY CHOICES IN THE NEXT
MONTHS
TWO LOOKING PARTICULARLY AT THE
END OF THE ADVANTAGE OF. ENDING
CASTRO DOING CASH AND WHATEVER.
HOME CERTAINLY THE ARMED
DEPARTMENT IS.
ABSOLUTELY WILLING AND READY TO.
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WORK WITH WORK GROUPS AT CENTER
TO BRING. INFORMATION BACK THE
WATERS.
CLEARLY I MEAN NEVER INSIDE IT
IMPEDED THE CONVERSATION TO THIS
POINT IS THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
WINNERS AND THE LOSERS.
AND HOW WE CAL IN NEVADA I DON'T
THINK THEY WOULD CARE ABOUT THE
LOSERS FRANKLY THAT.
YOU KNOW JUST.
GIVEN YOU DON'T GIVEN TO THE
FIRST PERSON IN PARLIAMENT AND
PRESSURE.
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T DO THAT SO
SOMEHOW WE HAVE TO CALIBRATE.
HOW WE MITIGATE THE IMPACT ON?
THE LOSERS PEOPLE WHO WOULD
COULD NOT BE ADVANTAGE BY THIS.
AND REALISTICALLY I THINK WE
WOULD MAKE A MISTAKE TO LOWBALL
THE ESTIMATES TO SAY WHAT'S MORE
THAN THAT. TRUTHFULLY THE.
CONSTITUENCIES WOULD BE
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED WILL BE HERE
NEXT YOU KNOW NEXT YEAR LET'S BE
UP FRONT MATURE ABOUT IT AND
SAY.
WE HAVE A POLICIES.
M. POINT
LETTING COMPASSES PEOPLE WHO
WOULD BE A DISADVANTAGE THAT
WE'RE PREPARED TO DEFEND AS A
POLICY. AS BEING REASONABLE AND
JUST NOW TO THE MECHANICS OF OF
WHAT WILL BE INVOLVED IN SORT
OF.
ARE ARE WORKING WITH GROUPS AND
THE POTENTIAL STEPS INVOLVED I'M
GOING TO TURN TO.
CHEMICALLY WADE WHO RUNS THE CAL
FRESH PROGRAM FOR THE STATE.
THANK YOU.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
GROUP PROPOSED TO LAY OUT SOME
OF THE SPECIFICS ON
IMPLEMENTATION WE HAVE BEEN
READING OF SCENARIOS FOR QUITE
AWHILE AND THINK WE DO AS A
STATE KNOW HOW TO DO IT ROAMING
CAMPAIGNS WITH COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND WITH
COMMUNICATIONS.
WE KNOW HOW TO STREAMLINED
ENROLLMENT WITH FAST ANSWERING
PHONES AND LEVERAGING ELECTRONIC
VERIFICATIONS WE KNOW HOW TO GET
OUT OF SUPPLEMENTAL STATE
BENEFIT WE DO IT FOR DROUGHT.
WATER WE DO IT FOR DISASTERS WE
DO IT FOR THE WINS PROGRAM THESE
ARE ALL THINGS WE KNOW HOW TO DO
WE SEEM TO PUT IT TOGETHER.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES US
LOOKED AT THIS ISSUE IN THE PAST
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
ALSO WILLING TO PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WILLNOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE TO.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS.
AND SHANE COMPANY CESSATION OF
FOOD BANKS TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH
THE COMMENTS.
ALREADY MADE AND APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENTS AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTEREST IN THIS
WE DO THINK THAT NOW IS THE TIME
LET'S ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS
LET'S GET IT DONE BY THE REVISED
AND LET'S. PUT OURSELVES IN A
POSITION TO REALLY MAKE SOME
DECISIONS ABOUT THIS IT'S BEEN
TOO LONG THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PER CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT ENDING THE SSI CASH OUT
AS WELL. YEAH IT'S REALLY PRETTY
INTERESTING I'M NOT SURE HOW
MANY OF US IN THIS ROOM WERE
HERE TWENTY YEARS AGO AS PART OF
WELFARE REFORM. LOOKING AT THIS
VERY ISSUE ON HOW WE COULD CRACK
THIS NIGHT. TO ACTUALLY AND THE
CASH OUT.
AT THAT TIME AND WE KEPT
BUMPING UP AGAINST WHAT I THINK
WERE SEEN AS THE WINNERS AND
LOSERS.
THAT.
ELIMINATING THE CASH OUT
ULTIMATELY.
ENDS UP WITH BUT I THINK THE
WITH THE FINE WORK THAT'S BEEN
PLAYED OUT I THINK IN IN THE.
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA AND ALEJO
WAS DONE WERE PROBABLY BETTER
PREPARED THAN WE EVER HAVE BEEN.
WITH THE NUMBERS IN THE
APPROACHES.
WITH THAT BEING SAID IT IS
CRITICAL FOR THE.
DISABILITY COMMUNITY THAT
INDEED THERE BE A TOTAL HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION.
HERE AND AS WE'VE SEEN IT WAS
OFTEN PICKING BETWEEN. DISABLED
CHILDREN OF FAMILIES AND
DISABLED ADULTS AND AND I THINK
THERE ARE.
AS YOU'VE HEARD REPEATEDLY WAYS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN BE
EQUITABLE AND IT SHOULD BE.
.
TOTAL HOME HARD HOLD HARMLESS
NOW AND AS WELL INTO THE FUTURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
MARTY MOTO CALIFORNIA
DISABILITIES COMMUNITY ACTION
NETWORK SO YOU CAN ALSO A FAMILY
MEMBER STRONG SUPPORT. FOR THE
PROPOSAL ESPECIALLY ON THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISIONS. IN THE POP
PARTNER PROPOSAL BRINGING PEOPLE
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER TO WORK
OUT A SOLUTION. THAT CAN BE
ADVANCE IN THE MAY REVISION THIS
IS ABOUT JUSTICE THIS IS ABOUT
EQUITY AND WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR.
TRACY PATTERSON CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES REALLY WANT TO
COMMEND THE HARD WORK OF FOLKS
ON THE PANEL EVERYONE IN THE
ROOM WE KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
GREAT MINDS HERE WORKING TO
SOLVE THIS VERY COMPLEX PROBLEM.
AMEND WE REALLY URGE YOU TO WORK
WELL THOUGHTFULLY AND QUICKLY TO
DEVELOP AN ACTUAL PLAN THAT
COULD REDUCE HARM. I'M WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ESTABLISHING ALL PROCESSES
AVAILABLE TO AUTOMATICALLY
ENROLL OR IS CLOSELY TO
AUTOMATICALLY ENROLL NEWLY
ELIGIBLE PEOPLE SO THAT WE DON'T
FALL INTO THE LOW PARTICIPATION
RATE THAT WE CURRENTLY SEE NOW
WITH ALL THE BILL SENIORS. A WE
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WERE
STREAMLINING ADMINISTRATION TO
FEDERAL BENEFITS CAN BE
MAXIMIZED FOR EVERYBODY NEED. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
ENSURE NO LOSS OF RESOURCES FOR
THE SS I HOUSEHOLDS THAT WILL
REMAIN INELIGIBLE FOR CAL FRESH
AFTER THE END OF CASH OUT. AND
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE MITIGATING OR ELIMINATING
THE LOSS OF BENEFITS FOR THE
MIXED SSI HOUSEHOLDS FAMILIES
ARE TAKING CARE OF DISABLED
FAMILY MEMBERS. SO THAT THEY
DON'T END UP MORE FOOD INSECURE
AND WE ARE VERY GLAD THEY ARE
WORKING TOWARDS AN ACTIONABLE
AND THOUGHTFUL PLAN BECAME.
I GOT UP THERE ARE GOING I SIT
IF CITY BOMB.
SEND YOUR SEPARATE OPTION ON
GOTTA.
WE SUPPORT THIS THEORY IS SHOWN.
GOD RISK FOR SENIOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES UNDER INCOME
COLONEL.
GO. HOLE DEB DEBT DIRE INDEED
OR PROP IN BALANCE
DIED IN OR DID NOT THE BE IT.
RIGHT NUMBER SIX IN NAY BUT THE
GUN OUT OF THE WAR.
I JUST THAT GOD THOUGH IT YOU
CAN DO IT TOLL IN CALIFORNIA
HILTON ISSUED SIMILAR INITIAL.
THANK YOU.
HI SHANTI PRASAD OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY COMMUNITY FOOD BANK
CALIFORNIANS FOR SSI IN
CALIFORNIA HUNGER ACTION
COALITION. I WANT TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL OF A
HOLD HARMLESS
SOLUTION TO CASH OUT I
PERSONALLY HELD A LISTENING
SESSION. IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND IT CONFIRMED EVERYTHING
THAT.
MISTER HAROLD MENTIONED ABOUT.
THAT THE NOBLENESS OF SSI
RECIPIENTS AND OTHER ADVOCATES
WANTING TO FIND A AT A HOLD
HARMLESS AND TO CASH OUT. THERE
ARE SSI RECIPIENTS IN EVERY
COUNTY IN THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE SIXTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. INCLUDING
ORANGE COUNTY THANK YOU BECAME.
CARLY SINGLE WITH THE FOOD BANK
OF CONTRA COSTA AND SOLANO.
.
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
CLOSELY WITH LISA LOPEZ WHO GAVE
A POWERFUL TESTIMONY.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS ARM.
I'M ISSUE OF SSI. AND FIGHTING
HUNGER AND POVERTY MORE BROADLY
ON AIRPORT ADVOCACY COMMITTEE.
AND ARM.
I AM HAPPY THAT AT LISA RETURNS
TO NEVADA THAT SHE WILL BE ABLE
TO.
FOR HER BASIC NEEDS BETTER.
IF THE.
SHAMEFULLY LOW SSI BENEFITS AND
THAT SHE WILL BE ABLE TO QUALIFY
FOR SNAP FOOD ASSISTANCE.
BUT I'M.
WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO WAIT ANY
LONGER ON THIS BECAUSE WE'RE
LOSING MEMBERS. OF OUR COMMUNITY
EVER LOSING.
A FIRST FAMILY.
THEY AREN'T.
I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE REGULARLY
URGENCY.
OF RESTORING BENEFITS AND
RESTORING SNAPPED ELIGIBILITY
FOR EXCIPIENTS THINKING.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU BECAME.
IT ONCE AGAIN CAPTORS SAMUELSON
HOME. I SUPPORTED BECAUSE NUMBER
ONE.
YOU KNOW I'VE EMPATHIZE WITH THE
YOUNG LADY THAT DATA SITTING
THERE RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE I'M ON SSI.
AND.
IT'S REALLY HARD WHEN YOU GO IN
THE STORE.
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO LIVE OFF OF
SO MUCH A MONTH YOU GOING TO
STORE YOU GO TO GET YOUR
GROCERIES.
YOU GET UP TO THE CASH REGISTER.
AND YOU HAVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MONEY YOU GET AFTER YOU HAVE TO
PUT STUFF THAT BECAUSE YOU DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY. TO PAY FOR
YOUR FOOD.
YOU TALKED ABOUT BE ANY LOW
GRADE EIGHT PHILIP EMBARRASSMENT
WHEN YOU GOING TO START A BY
GARCES AT ALL I CAN'T BY THIS
BECAUSE I CAN'T AFFORD IT.
AND NO ONE EIGHT YOU NEED IT BUT
YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO BUY CERTAIN
THINGS.
SO THE NOT GIVING PEOPLE ON SSI
FOOD STAMPS
JUST BECAUSE THEY SAY ARE S.
ASIDE MONEY IS SUPPOSE TO BE
INCLUDED IN OUR COST TO LIVE AND
THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK FOR
PEOPLE S. ON SSI. A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T NOT WANT TO BE ON
SSI.
MY DISABILITY KEEPS ME FROM WORK
AND PARTLY BECAUSE FACT IT WORK.
I WOULD BE AT WORK
BECAUSE WHAT YOU GIVE ME TO LIVE
OFF IS NOTHING.
AND IT NOT GIVE ME FOOD STAMPS I
HAVE A TWENTY YEAR OLD OUT OF
ONE YEAR OLD CHAP HE LIKES TO
EAT.
SO THAT'S LIKE A JUG OF I TAKE
HER SOMEWHERE TELL OSHITA GET
HAPPEN IF YOU DON'T LIKE WHERE
SOME MALES TO GO WITH A HAPPY
MEAL.
SO THAT'S A JOKE NASA FOR OVER A
ONE.
SO WE TALK ABOUT SOMEBODY LIKE
TO EAT.
IN IS VERY HARD IN A SLY.
WHERE I LIVE AND I LOOK AT THE
HOMELESS ALL THE TIME? A I HAVE
TO GO TO LIKE EVERY OTHER DAY TO
BRIBE Y. WERE RALLY IF TO
SURVIVE TO TOMORROW IT IT MAKES
ME FEEL BAD WHEN I HAVE TO GO
TAKE A SOMETIME LEVI DO HAVE
FOOD I FEEL LIKE. I'M TAKING
AWAY FROM OTHERS BUT I HAVE
STILL HAVE TO MAKE ENDS MEET
FICKLE LASTED ABOUT A MAKE SURE
ME AND MY CHAO HAVE A FULL
STOMACH WHEN I GO TO BED AT
NIGHT. SOLVE PLEASE SUPPORT KEEP
ANY FOOD STAMPS GOING THANK YOU.
YOU.
I WENT ON AND AGAIN I'M UP HERE
TO TALK ABOUT SSI IN FULL STAMPS
ON NORMAL SS SOUND DISABLE IN
MIND I LOOK LIKE I'M JUST A WEE
BUT I KNOW I HAD TWO SURGERIES
ALREADY LAST YEAR THE YEAR
BEFORE LAST.
AND HIP REPLACEMENT AND ARE HIT
REPAIR. AND I'M HERE TO OUR
SUPPORT TO HOME FULL STAFF SSI
BECAUSE AYE A SUPPLEMENT INCOME
EACH MONTH AND I'M BARELY MAKING
IT. AS ANYONE ELSE DOES ON SSI.
SO I'M HERE TO SUPPORT TO PUT A
FULL STEPS BACK FOR THAT PEOPLE
ON SSI TO DISPEL PEOPLE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HI A BY NOW YOU KNOW SORT OF WHO
I AM. AND I HAVE TO GO TO FOOD
BANKS TO LIKEWISE TO DO THE
BASIC FOOD NEEDS.
AND I KNOW THIS WILL ALSO
REQUIRE FEDERAL SO WHEN ACT
BATTLE COMES ALONG YEAH I'LL BE
THERE TOO BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S
GOING TO BE A VERY UPHILL
BATTLE.
ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL SO PLEASE
CONSIDER WHAT'S NEEDED.
THANK YOU SIR.
I AM RUSSELL RAWLINGS
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY
SERVICES ARE RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING AND A MEMBER
OF THE.
CA FOR SSI.
COALITION. AND WE HAVE.
FOUNDED OUR COALITION ON AN
EQUITABLE IN TO CASH OUT.
I THINK FOR THE FIRST TIME YOU
ARE REALLY HEARING THE STORIES
THAT HAVE OCCURRED. FOR WELL
OVER A DECADE.
LEASES SITUATION WAS MY OWN
SITUATION.
AND WE SEE PEOPLE DAY AFTER DAY
AT RESOURCES FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING. THEY'RE PAYING NINETY
PERCENT OF WHAT THEY'RE GETTING
A MONTH.
TO RANT
AND HAVING TO FIND WAYS TO MAKE
FOOD HAPPEN.
WITHOUT ANY KIND OF ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY GO AND PURCHASE OR
MAKE.
THROUGH DECISIONS AND ANY KIND
OF STORE THAT THE REST OF US DO
YOU.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE PURSUE
BASS.
AND THE TIME IS NOW THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS REBECCA ALMOST
ONLY A FIFTH AYE BUT I DON'T GET
HUSSEIN IS SOME REAL HARM SO WE
GOTTA HAVE THE MIL HARMLESS.
WE'RE NOT FOR EVERYBODY BENEFITS
AND TEN DOLLARS BY THE LOT MORE
BACK IN NINETEEN SEVENTY BOARD
THAT DOESN'T TWENTY EIGHT AM.
YOU GOT CONSIDER THAT.
WHAT CAN BE BUT YEAH AND TWENTY
EIGHT PEOPLE OR GALLONS OF MILK
A MEZZO HOLE IF THE U. GIVEN TEN
BUCKS?
SO IT LIST SAG GET BUSH GET THE
STOCK BACK TOGETHER MOSSAD THE
PROM.
I GET IT WOULD BUT ONLY A FEW
ASIDE THAT WOULD BE A ARE HELD A
PROPOSED THEM BUT NOBODY WILL IS
LEFT BEHIND THANK YOU.
I AM A HUMAN THAN A WITH SENIOR
IN THIS OF AND THE ACTION.
.
SO YOU KNOW WE HADN'T NAMED BEAR
THAT COMES TO OUR REGION NOW
MEDIAN EVERY MONTH.
AND THIS PERSON.
.
HER RENT IS ACTUALLY OVER HER IS
SOCIETY CURRENT
AND SO.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE.
AB PENNY LEFT AFTER PAYING HER
RENT
BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY. WHO
COLLECT MONEY HAD HER AT THE
OFFICE
TO SEND HER A LITTLE EXTRA SO
SHE CAN?
PEAK FOR HER BRENT.
AND SO. THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS HAPPENING HOME FROM SAN
FRANCISCO SO YOUNG YOU GUYS.
PARA OUT SOME FRANCISCO
SITUATION LOOK AT.
REALLY REALLY BAD SO A MANY HAVE
TO SUFFER A THROUGH THAT AND SHE
HAS BARRIERS.
.
HEALTH CONDITIONS THAT PREVENT
HER FROM DOING MORTGAGE WORK
REALLY HARD.
AND LOW WAGES ARE THE ENEMY ALSO
OFF POOR PEOPLE YOU KNOW BECAUSE
I WHEN THEY RETIRE THEY DON'T
GET ENOUGH MONEY AND THEY END
UP.
NEEDING SSI AND AND I HEAR
PEOPLE SAY ALL THURMOND SOCIETY
PROBABLY NEVER WORK IN THE LIFE.
THEY HAVE WORKED
AND EVEN IF THEY HAVE NEVER
WORKED.
WE SHOULD NOT EVEN OF BE AT
PUNISHING PEOPLE FOR BEING POOR.
AB SO.
PLEASE ARE LOOK INTO MAKING A
DAY'S WORK FOR EVERYBODY SO IT
IS NOT HARM FOR THOSE THAT CAN
BE A LOSING SOME INCOME.
I MEAN. FOR STEPS.
I CAN.
SCENE ONE ASPECT OF THE MOMENT
THEY.
WHAT'S GONNA FISCAL SOLVENCY ON.
A.
BUT I'M HE.
I DIDN'T SOME FRANCISCO ESCUDE
GOTTA.
CITING GAY.
BUT I DON'T NOT INTO THIS A
SIMPLE STOLEN IT'S GOOD YOU KNOW
I.
BUT BELOW SCOTT SAID ALMOST
GETTING COURTED OF THIS DEBATE
IN THE STOMACH BUT ACCORDING TO
MUCH LENT US.
NORMAL SKIN ANOTHER BETTA.
BUT ACT ONE BUT I LUCK WITH ME
THAT CAN RESTRICT WITNESSES SEAT
THAT.
HOW DO SO I'M HERE AGAIN?
YOU KNOWS AS SERVICES BELIEVING
IN SAN FRANCISCO'S REALLY
EXPENSIVE AND.
SOME SOMETIMES WE LOSE OH.
WE TEND TO OF GET EVICTED IF WE
ARE PAYING SIX HUNDRED AND SIX
HUNDRED IS ALREADY ALLOWED AND
IT BUT THE LATIN OR STAY ONE
MORE MONEY FOR THE.
PLACES THAT WE LIVE IN AND SO.
.
WE WE CAN REALLY ASK FOR MUCH.
SEE IF I DON'T KNOW THE AT THE
SUN WITHOUT REALLY.
A.
THIS. DOES SEEM POSSIBLE IT BUT
I'M ALSO PROSPER HIM BLOOM
EQUIPMENT ON IT ON THE CHIN
AFFECT US.
NOT ONLY DON'T ASK THAT UNLESS.
E. EQUAL MET SOME LOVELY QUESTA
MUST DONE THEY.
BUT A WHOLE MONTH AND IT IS SO
THE AT THE.
E..
ORAL GIMMICK TO YOU THAT THIS.
DISCUSSING POSSIBLY.
AND SO.
MAINTAINING A HEALTHY DIET IS
IS VERY DIFFICULT YOU KNOW I
DON'T TOLERATE LACTOSE AND I
DON'T TOLERATE MEET AND SO.
.
WITH WHAT I GET AFTER PAYING MY
RENT IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME
TO AFFORD TO HAVE A HEALTHY
DIET.
SEAT BUT ON THE COMPETITIVE HIT
DYNASTY FOOL DOES IT LOOK AT ME
WHAT PUBLIC GETTING. IS THIS
MOVIE GOT ALL E. E. DRIVE AT
ABOUT.
NO SURPLUS IS THAT HAMAS MUST
COMPTON THOSE.
SINGLES THE ITEM FOR THIS AMP
BURKE ACCOMPLICE W. WE ARE
COMPATIBLE UNISYS HEAP.
IT ACCESS.
AT LEAST SO.
BUT FOR ME TO BUY THE STUFF THAT
I'D REALLY NEED AB HE WOULD BE.
GOOD IF I CAN GET THE FOOD
STAMP BECAUSE I WOULD BUY WHAT I
REALLY NEED.
AND SO THANK YOU.
I WANT HAS COME TO AT THAT MY
WALK.
.
CHIU LIMIT THE KIND OF COMMON
THAT LAKE GUILT WHEN NOT.
YEAH OF INCOME HAS TO CLOSE WE
CANNOT BROWN WITH THEIR.
IF PLAYERS AND LSS HER YOU SEE
IF THE WAY WE CAN GET A FAIR
ORDER HAVE TALKED.
FATAL EST ENSUITE PC AND PIPPEN
WHO LEFT A MESSAGE YEAH COME
WIDELY THOUGHT. ESTO MOST
THEY'LL WIN A MUSCLE HAVE YEAH.
YOU IT BEFORE THAT SOME.
ASSEMBLY OUT WHEN I GO TO MY
HOUSE. BUT I'M WHEN THEY GOT THE
LIMITS BUT INTO GIVING UP A
LITTLE.
FIFTY
YEAH.
HELLO AGAIN.
AS YOU HARRIS AND LEGAL.
LIVE AND OF IF WE GET FOOD
STAMPS THAT WOULD HELP.
.
HE NO IS IS HARD TO GET THE THE
HEALTHY FOOD THAT WE NEED.
SEE UP TO WOMEN BUT MEN TECH AND
BLAH BUT THE OTHER FOOT STOMPS.
MHM OKAY A CANNELLA SAYS HI MOM
EXIT THE HOPELESS NAM CAN WEAPON
THE AND THAT.
IF DON'T TASTE IF PROGRAM.
LF EMP ADDRESS HOW DEMANDING Y.
WHAT YEAH IF IT WERE A CANNOT.
LOOK FOR THEM WELL DONE.
GET THE LATEST NOW FOUST NAM.
THIS A BROKEN NECK AND WOOD OKAY
HIM OUT OR NOW WITH FAR MORE AN
IDEA.
YOU WHEN WERE YOU MUSTN'T BE EYE
AND LITERACY WE.
AND IT IS UP DOESN'T ALL USE
IN.
FORTY.
YEAH.
SO SHE'D TRY TO APPLY FOR SSI.
I'M AIMING FOR FOOD STATUS AND
THEY SAID WELL YOU THAT IS TO
SAY YOU DON'T NEED FOOD STEP AND
SO.
DOWN SOMEONE ELSE.
ENCOURAGED HER TO APPLY AGAIN
FOR IT OF FOOD STAMPS AND SHE
WENT TO A APPLY AGAIN LOOK TO
TRY IN. AND THEY SAID WELL YEAH.
.
WE CAN GIVE YOU TEN DOLLARS
AND BAD I UNIQUE TO.
FILL OUT THIS FORUMS AND. AND
SHE REALLY. COULDN'T BELIEVE
WITH
IT'S HAPPENING AND SHE FELT
REALLY BAD ABOUT IT AND SO. AND
NOTHING REALLY MOVE AFTER THAT.
WHEN I PLACED.
WELL HELLO I'M UP WE HAVE A SEAT
IDEA ONE HOW IN MY FIELD.
IF GMEZ OPEN TO MY BOSS ITEM
MUSCLE GOING GET GET WITH LOGAN
MIGHT TELL I AM NOT PRESSED
CLOSE ETHNIC SETTING ASSEMBLY
AND.
IF LATEST WANTED TO HURT THE
REST OF WATER SO. GOOD BUT IF
SOMEONE AGO THEN.
IF THEY HAVE A GOOD THING I'M
ONE OUT WHEN.
NOT.
SO IT WOULD BE GOOD IF YOU CAN
HELP IS.
TO GET FOOD STAND WOULD REALLY
HELP AND NAM.
IT IS SO I AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU SHE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT YOU CAN AT THE
VERY THING.
BUT IT FELT.
HIGHER EVERYBODY MY NAME IS
FRANCESCA ACOSTA I WORK AT THE
SF WHEN FOOD BANK.
AND I ACTUALLY DO OUR REACH
RECALL FRESH ALL THE TIME SO I'M
OUT THERE TELLING EVERYBODY HOW
AMAZING THIS PROGRAM IS HOW IT
CAN CONNECT YOU TO THE FOOD THAT
YOU CHOOSE DIVIDES LIVE A
HEALTHY AND FULFILLED LIFE.
AS I'M SURE YOU'VE HEARD A LOT
OF REALLY.
POIGNANT STORIES TODAY WE HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS OF FOLKS
EVERYDAY AND TELL THEM THAT
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY'RE.
ON EARNING HER RECEIVING LESS
THAN THE. POVERTY LINE THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL FOOD ASSISTANCE SO.
I WANTED TO ECHO THE URGENCY
FOR THIS AS WE ALL HAVE HUMAN
BODIES WE KNOW THAT A COUPLE
DAYS WITHOUT FOOD IS TOO MANY.
IT AND ALSO WANTED TO SHARE.
SOMETHING I FIND.
REALLY IMPACTFUL JUST GOING TO
ANY OF OUR FOOD BANK PROGRAMMING
SITES GOING DOOR PANTRIES GOING
TO CFP DISTRIBUTIONS. OF COURSE
WHEN ANY CONGREGATE MEAL SITES.
NEARLY EVERYBODY HAS SSI IT THIS
IS A SYSTEMIC FAILURE.
AND SO I URGE YOU TO.
EXPEDITE I'M HANDLING THIS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE I TELL
PEOPLE ALL THE TIME THERE'S SO
MANY PEOPLE WORKING ON THIS.
LOOK UP YOU KNOW HOW YOU CAN GET
INVOLVED IN ADVOCATE ON YOURS ON
YOUR BEHALF.
SO I I REALLY URGE YOU TO GIVE
US ALL THE ATTENTION IT DESERVES
BECAUSE IT REALLY DEPENDS
PEOPLE'S LIVES DEPEND ON IT.
THEY THINK.
HI MY NAME IS BECKY YOUR SON
ALSO FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
MARIN FOOD BANK.
IN OUR SERVICE AREA ALONE THERE
ARE ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
WHO RECEIVE SSI SSD. I AM AS YOU
HEARD MY COLLEAGUE FRANCESCO SAY
I'M A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WHO COME
TO OUR VARIOUS WHO BEING
PROGRAMS ARE ON SSI.
CLEARLY THE BENEFITS OF A
RECEIVER NOT ENOUGH YOU'VE HEARD
A LOT FROM FOLKS FROM WHO CAN
SPEAK FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
ABOUT THAT. AND AND AGAIN I JUST
WANNA SAY I'M ECHO THE URGENCY
FACTOR AND ALSO ON EXPRESSED
GREAT GRATITUDE THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WERE ALL SEEM SEEM TO
BE WORKING ON RIGHT NOW.
.
IT'S TAKEN A LOT OF YEARS TO GET
TO THIS POINT I REALIZE I'M AND
SO THANK YOU FOR I'M PUTTING A
LOT OF THOUGHT AND EFFORT INTO
MAKING THIS HAPPEN THIS YEAR WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
WE CAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO GET PART OF
OUR TO DO MY NAME WE DON'T WE
DON'T WANT TO YEAH. I USED TO
LEAVING CYPRESS HIS GO WORK
THERE.
AND I WAS LIKE EVERY SHE AYE.
BUT ONE DAY I BECAME DISABLED.
AND THEN HOW YOU HAVE TO MOVE TO
THE EAST
BAY AND NOW I'M A NARCOTICS
CHEAPER.
BUT.
GET OUT THANKS THAT.
.
I PRESS HERE AND CLINTON PAUSE
THEY WERE GOOD SOME MIGHT ON
LAW.
SO THAT YOU KNOW BEFORE THEY
TOOK EVERYTHING FROM THE
SUPERMARKETS THEY DONATE THAT.
TO THE CHARITY LIKE SALVATION
ARMY ILL CHURCHES AND THEN
PEOPLE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT.
BUT IT'S A STRUGGLE BETWEEN A
USED TO READ STAY GET ME. EVER
BECAUSE I USED TO MAKE GOOD
MONEY I WASREQUIRED TO WORK
OVERTIME.
BUT BECAUSE I IT WAS PUNISHED
BECAUSE THEY WERE SINGLE WE KNOW
PROPERTIES SELL OR MY OR TIME
WAS TO PAY TAXES.
NOW I'M DISABILITY I'M DOUBLE OF
BONDAGE.
BECAUSE I AM GET FOOD STAMPS AND
AND YOU KNOW YOU CAN I LEAVE
WITH NINE HUNDRED TEN OF MONT.
AND.
.
AND YOU KNOW YOU'D GOOD. SO MY
WIFE IS HE HOMES SUPPORT TO
SERVICE HIS SO SOCIAL SECURITY
TOLD US LIKE YOU CHU LIVES WITH
ME AND SHE MAKES MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED A MONTH. I LOSE MY
BENEFITS I JUST WENT TO STANFORD
LEGGIO TO IN THE BEGINNING A DID
YOU HAVE TO SOMEHOW OR
SURGERIES.
AND.
SIXTY SEVENTY THOUSAND A YEAR
IN MEDICAL BILLS.
I CANNOT AFFORD TO LEAVE WHEN MY
WIFE AND MAKE A POOR PART OF
BEING.
LIVING WITH UP OF PERSONAL
DISABILITY. SO.
I'D REMEMBERING COALITION
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE A
PROFESSOR SAY LIKE. WELL
CALIFORNIA FEES INDEPENDENT
UNITED STATE OF.
UNITED STATES COULD BE IS HAVE
EMPOWER.
ECONOMIC POWER EIGHT
INDEPENDENT.
AND THAT WE'RE NAY I GO PICK UP
BREAD EVERY DAY FOR THE
SALVATION ARMY. AND I GO TO
WILL.
THE NEIGHBORHOODS AND I SEE
PEOPLE FAMILIES KIDS.
LIVING IN TENTS ISN'T REALLY
SET.
SO YOU'RE NOT.
THE LAST DAYS OF WRONG MY HOPE
IS NOT.
WHAT I FEEL? BUT DO NOT IN
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE CARE DO
NAUTICAL TWENTY FIFTH YOU CAN
GOOGLE. UNITED NATIONS
DECLARATION OF HUMAN RIGHTS.
THE GORE MINUTES IS SUPPOSED TO
PROVIDE THE C. DISTANCE.
WITH FOOD. GLOATING INTO CATIA
HOUSING.
OKAY SO WIDOWHOOD.
OR THINGS THAT ARE OUT OF THEIR
CONTROL.
SO DO YOU KNOW.
FAMILIES ARE THE CENTER OF THIS
SOCIETY BUT WE'RE SEPARATING
POPULOUS BECAUSE THEY GONNA
LEAVE TO GETTING HOUSING.
BECAUSE IT THE GREEKS
IN THE IT THE THIS DISPLACEMENT.
PEOPLE CAN KNOW HOW BARBECUES
ANYMORE.
FAMILY MEMBERS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO MOVE TO FAR AWAY.
SO. YOUNGSTER BUT THAT NO I'M A
POOR PERSON BUT.
PLEASE THAT HELD ME NOT TO GET
MORE PUNISH
I PAY MY PART.
YES GOOD AFTERNOONMAYES
PATRICK FLANAGAN I LIVE WITH THE
ROSE HOTEL.
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M NOT ON
SSI BUT I HAVE FRIENDS.
WHO ARE ON SSI?
AND.
.
TOWARDS THE END OF THE MONTH OR.
THROW IS KNOCKING ON MY DOOR.
PATRICK YOU HAVE ANYTHING.
YOU GOT ANY RAHMAN NOODLES JEFF
MACHEN'S.
AND.
.
AND I SAID.
WILL.
DON'T HAVE FOOD STAMPS TO BUY US
SOME MORE NOW OR UNNECESSARY AND
WE DON'T GET THREE CENTS ON.
ALRIGHT SO.
YOU KNOW WE GO TO TARGET WE GET
A.
THE A SIX PACK OF RAMAN NOODLES
FOR TWO BUCKS RIGHT I MEAN MAC
AND CHEESE IS WHAT.
HE KEPT THREE FOR A DOLLAR I
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S WHAT IT'S
LIKE.
BUT OR AT YOU KNOW HORMEL. A
CHILI BEANS LIKE WHAT'S A
CADILLAC SO WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR
A YOU KNOW STEAK AND LOBSTER IN
ANYTHING LIKE EXTRAVAGANT THESE
CHRIS.
MAC AND CHEESE OKAY RAMAN
NOODLES PLEASE HELP THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
ARE.
KYRIE FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
I GO TO SAY MEMBER CENTER BE.
LUNCH EVERY OTHER.
DAY OF SOMETHING LIKE THAT ALSO
OUTRIGHT A CLIP COUPONS AND
SUBWAYS. MACDONNELLS.
AND BURGER KING WHEN HE THEY SAY
YOU CAN GET TO.
FOR ONE DAY WHEN I GET DALY
FOUND THEY POLICY NOW AT THE
STORE YOU GOTTA GO TO ANOTHER
STORE WAY ACROSS TOWN SO POLITE
THAT NIGHT IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
YOU CAN GET. TWO FOUR TWO TWO
FOUR ONE.
AND THE.
I TRY TO GO BREAST BILLS.
OMAR.
ON BALCONIES I COULD EAT BETTER
OF.
IN A IS JUST TOO SMALL PLACE TO
REALLY GROW FOOD.
SO I SUPPORT A.
WHO STANDS FOR SS I PEOPLE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH?
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY MY NAME IS CINDY SIEGEL
THE FOOD BANK OF COMP CASA. DOWN
THE A COUNTY AND I'M NEARLY
OBVIOUSLY NOT JUST BECAUSE HE IS
SO. AND IT THE THING THAT I TOLD
YOU BEFORE ABOUT KNOWING THE
NAMES OF THE SENIORS THAT I
HELD.
SERVE MY CLIENTS YOU KNOW THE
KIDS NAMES TO.
AND I I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
BECAUSE.
I KNOW IT'S IMPLICIT AND
EXPLICIT EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN
SAID DATA HOW MUCH THIS HELPS
CHILDREN.
BERNARD ONE TO REMIND YOU THAT
WHAT YOU ALREADY KNOW WAS THE
NUMBER CHILDREN IN. CALIFORNIA
THAT LIVE IN POVERTY AND HOW.
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS RIGHT THAT
THAT FOR KIDS THIS IS AN EXTRA
EX NUMBER DOLLARS FOR THE
PARENTS THIS IS THE DIFFERENCE
MANY TIMES BETWEEN SUCCESS AND A
LACK OF SUCCESS IN SCHOOL RIGHT?
TO DIFFERENTIATE AND HAVING LESS
OF A DIFFERENTIATION BETWEEN
THEIR NON IMPOVERISHED APPEARS
READY ALERTS YOU TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT. YOU HAVE A LOT OF ADULTS
SPEAKING BUT DAHLE LOT OF US ARE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
POPULATION THIS IS LIKELY TO.
HELP BENEFIT THE MOST
AND THE OTHER THING I WANTED TO
REMIND YOU OF IS THAT THE THING
ABOUT.
FOOD STAMPS CALL IT WHAT YOU
WILL DEPENDING ON YOUR POINT OF
VIEW IS THAT A LOT OF PLACES
WILL MATCH.
FOOD STAMPS WERE ENABLE YOU TO
DOUBLE IT OR IF YOU'RE USING IT
THEY'LL GIVE YOU A BENEFIT. AND
ALL OF THE CLIENTS I TALK TO ON.
THE REASON THAT THEY LIKE THAT
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY GO INTO A
GROCERY STORE OR A FARMER'S
MARKET.
BECAUSE REMEMBER IN THAT SOUNDS
LIKE A SILLY THING THAT MANY OF
US WHO NEVER EXPERIENCES TAKE
FOR GRANTED. AND THAT IS THE
ABILITY TO TRY SOMETHING NEW.
TO HAVE YOUR HAVE A HEALTHIER
DIET PRISON ACTUAL LITERAL COST
OF THAT.
AND.
PARENTS WERE TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE THEIR CHILDREN TO EAT
HEALTHIER FOODS OFTEN ARE FACED
WITH A RIDICULOUS CHOICE OF.
HOPING THAT THE LIKE THE
VEGETABLE.
AND KNOWING THAT IF THEY DON'T.
THEY'RE STUCK WITH SOMETHING
THAT BASICALLY THEN BECOMES
WASTEFUL SO. IN ESSENCE AGAIN
THIS THIS IDEA OF.
.
A BENEFIT ON THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
ACTUALLY PURCHASE MORE FOOD OR
DIFFERENT HOOTERS DOUBLE
ACTUALLY ALLOWS THEM TO
INTRODUCE THEIR KIDS TO A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF FOOD IN
OFTENTIMES MORE NUTRITIOUS TYPE
OF FOOD SO. AGAIN YOU KNOW DON'T
TO SEE IT AS YOU KNOW THE SET
AMOUNT THAT YOU'RE ON.
GIVEN TO PARENTS SO TO SPEAK
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS ACTUALLY
HELPING THE NEXT GENERATION TO
GROW TO THEIR FULLEST POTENTIAL.
THANK YOU.
GIVEN.
BUT I AM IS ALSO VERY FOR.
CALIFORNIA'S FOR SSI.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I'M A
SUPPORTER OF ENDING CASH OUT.
PENDING OR DEPENDENT UPON A
COMPREHENSIVE AND PERMANENT HOLD
HARMLESS.
POLICY AT LEAST.
FOR YOU KNOW CURRENT RECIPIENTS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ADAM
GREEN PREMIER YOU W..
I'M UP HERE NOT ONY TO TALK
ABOUT MYSELF.
BUT ALSO OTHERS WHO WERE IN THE
SAME NEED.
I'M THE CARETAKER OF AN ELDERLY
VIETNAM VETERAN.
WHO IS ON YOUR SSI PROGRAM?
WHO GETS THE BARE MINIMUM OF
YOUR SSI PROGRAM?
SHE HAS NOT GOT ANY COST
INCREASE.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS THIS YEAR SHE
FINALLY GOT A THREE DOLLAR COST
INCREASES WHILE.
HOW NICE IS THAT?
MY SELF
I'VE APPLIED FOR YOUR SSI
PROGRAMS
BEEN DENIED.
I LIVE OFF YOUR CAL FRESH
PROGRAM I GET THE BARE MINIMUM.
HOW FAIRS UP TO ME?
I'M ALSO A VETERAN OF OUR
NATION.
I HAVE A LETTER RIGHT HERE.
OF DENIAL.
FROM MY VIEW OF IT.
I ALSO HAVE A LETTER DENIAL
FAMILIES TO CALIFORNIA.
WHAT'S UP WITH THAT.
POSTOPERATIVE MAKING.
BRADFORD OTHERS.
WE DON'T ASK FOR MUCH.
WE DON'T WANT MUCH.
I NEVER TOOK MY SALT.
I'M ALSO DISABLED FIREFIGHTER
RAMONA XIN.
I GIVE ALL THROUGH THE STATE.
I GOT HURT BY THIS STATE.
I HAVE ALL TERMINATION.
GOT HURT BY MY NOTION AMONG.
WHAT DO I HAVE TO DO?
WHAT DID WE HAVE TO DO?
YOUR LITTLE SOMETHING.
REPAIRED HIS PROGRAMS LOOK ADAM.
I DO LIKE THE IDEA OF YOUR CASH
OUT.
I THINK THAT MIGHT HELP MY
ROOMMATE OUT.
THE MARKET OFFERS SOME OPEN
BUT OUT BILL.
BUT ALSO LOOK AT ALL THE OTHER
PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF. WHO ARE
TRYING EVERY SINGLE DAY GOING
THROUGH YOUR SYSTEM? DOING
NETWORK TOLD AND BEEN TOLD NO.
LET YOUR YES FOR WANTS.
BUT YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'D CARRYING REPRESENTING
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS HOME
CARE PROVIDERS UNION.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE TO SAY
YOU'VE HEARD IT.
THIS IS A CRY FOR HELP LOT AND
ASK FOR A HANDOUT. PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS.
I CHRISTY THOUGHT APART SAID ON
BEHALF OF EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND
EMPOWER FAMILY CALIFORNIA. WE WE
JUST ASK AND YOU END CASH OUT.
AND PROVIDE A FIX
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WOULD BE
HURT BY THAT.
THAT'S THE PRIORITY THANK YOU
BECAME.
HI.
MY NAME IS JOYCE.
AND I'VE SEEN HERE ARE NOT
LISTEN AND LISTEN.
AND THERE'S ONE THING THAT I
WANT EVERYBODY TO REALLY KNOW IN
THIS ROOM.
THAT EVERY LAST ONE OF US CAN
REALLY DO.
S. KEEP OUR HEAD UP.
HAVE FAITH.
AND HOPE.
KNOW THAT THOSE TO GO.
YOU GUYS CITY NOW APPEAR.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT HIGHER BODY
ELSE FEEL ABOUT YOU BUT I KNOW
YOU CAN ONLY DO SO MUCH.
YOU CAN ONLY SAY SO MUCH.
THIS WHOLE ROOM WE HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER.
WE HAVE TO COME TOGETHER.
WE HAVE TO.
THINK ABOUT.
EACH OTHER THIS GOING THROUGH
STAFF
AND LIKE WE SAID OUR NEXT
GENERATION.
AMONG SSI.
I HAVEN'T GOT A RAISE IN FIVE
YEARS.
BUT I DON'T CARE.
BECAUSE THERE'S A GUY.
OKAY.
I DON'T WANT VOTE FOOD SCARE.
I'VE WORKED ON MY LIFE.
I'M A CARE GIVER.
I'M DOING THE BEST I CAN GIVE MY
FOOD STAMPS TO SOMEBODY.
THERE IS A LOT OF THOSE I KNOW
THAT WE DON'T WANT FOOD STANDS
LET OTHER PEOPLE THEY'RE REALLY
NEED IT AND WANT IT.
I WORKED HARD ALL MY LIFE
MY MOM HAVE REALLY RAISED ME.
TO LOVE EVERYBODY I DON'T CARE
WHAT COLOR WOULD CREE WE
SUPPOSEDLY HELPING EACH OTHER.
THIS IS LIKE EVERYBODY CA WERE
NOT BEGGING.
AND ONE NIGHT.
WE WANT TO KEEP MY HEAD ABOVE
WATER.
SO THE ONLY THING I CAN REALLY
SEE IN THIS ROOM I DROVE DOWN
HERE TODAY FROM STOCKTON. OPEN
THE UNION A UNION THAT I LOVE
AND THE UNION THAT WE REALLY ARE
WANT TO HELP EACH OTHER.
COME TOGETHER THERE'S A THING
THAT THEY WANT US THERE.
CLOCKING IN. AND SO THAT THEY
CAN KEEP A WHERE ALL THE CARE
GIVERS THAT THAT'S NOT
IMPORTANT.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT I GIVE
CARE TO MY CARE.
MY CLIENTS THAT NEED THE CARE.
AND THE GUIDE THE DISRUPTIVE BE
ABOUT A VETERAN.
I'M TAKING CARE OF A VETERAN
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE TAKING CARE OF
HIM FOR SIXTEEN YEARS.
AND I JUST STARTED GETTING PAID.
THREE YEARS AGO.
I DON'T ASK FOR BACK PAY CARE.
AND I JUST WANT TO TAKE CARE OF
HIM THE WAY HE NEEDS TO BE
TAKING CARE OF.
AND I DID I ASK FOR A RAISE
BECAUSE.
THREE YEARS TAKING CARE SOMEONE
HE'S GOING DOWN.
HE NEEDS MORE DIAPERS HE NEEDS
MORE MEDICATION. THEY TELL ME
THEY COULDN'T GIVE ME ANY MORE.
THAT I WAS GIVEN THE MAX.
MOHAMMED GET THE MAX.
IF THE COST OF LIVING IS GOING
TO KEEP GOING I'M GONNA.
BUT I WANT ALL OF YOU TO KNOW.
I'M I DON'T GIVE UP ON THE KEEP
MY HANNAH.
FAYE AND THE HOPE.
AND I KNOW YOU GUYS GONNA DO
WHAT YOU CAN FOR US AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM.
WILL BRING NOW BACK UP TO THE
DIET SEEING NO MORE PUBLIC
COMMENT ASSEMBLYMEMBER REVEAL.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
GIVEN THIS CONVERSATION TODAY AT
LIKE TO MAKE A REQUEST ON BEHALF
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS ALLIANCE
WITH WHAT WAS DISCUSSED IN THE
SENATE HEARING LAST WEEK.
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ESTABLISH A
WORKING GROUP TO INCLUDE
PARTICIPATION OF KEY ADVOCATES.
THE LA SHOW THE LEGISLATIVE
STAFF TO DEVELOP AN OPTION OR
SET OF OPTIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. AT THE
PENDING MAY REVISION FOR
REVERSING THE CASH OUT AND HE
HOLD HARMLESS APPROACH.
MY HOPE IS THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAPPENED
BETWEEN NOW AND THEN.
AND THE WORK PRODUCT THAT COMES
TO US AND MAY HELP FLUSH OUT AND
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS BEING
RAISED BY THE ADVOCATES HERE
TODAY AND THE THOSE THAT ARE
LISTED IN THIS AGENDA.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE TO
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE.
FIVE
.
THIS TIFFANY CHEN STILL HERE
FOR THE MOMENT WE'RE SKIPPING
ISSUE THREE AND GOING TO ISSUE
FIVE I JUST WANTED TO ENSURE
THAT TIFFANY CHEN WAS STILL
.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA WILL LIKE BORN
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES AND
AGAIN I'M GOING TO HAND IT TO
DEBBIE THOMPSON.
I MEAN ORGANS I MEAN IF I CAN
TAKE IT OUT OF ORDER WORTH TEN.
TO HAVE.
CHEN PRESENT FIRST.
POSSIBLE.
AND. ONCE AGAIN MY NAME IS
TIFFANY CHEN AND I'M A NINETY
EIGHT SS PROVIDER.
AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW I CARE FOR
MY SON.
AND I'M GONNA ASK FOR SILENCE IN
THE ROOM IF I CAN FOR A
PRESENTER HERE IN FRONT
THANK THINK YOU.
I CARE FOR MY SON HE'S FIVE AND
A HALF YEARS OLD. AND HE LIVES
IN OUR HOME IN ROCKLAND.
I HE'S ON THE SEVERE AND OF THE
AUTISM SPECTRUM DISORDER AND A
AND NEEDS MY FULL ATTENTION.
AND I HAVE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
SUPERVISION FOR HIM.
I'M I'M ALSO PROVIDER FOR MY
BROTHER HE SAID ON AYE H. SS AND
HE'S FORTY FIVE YEARS OLD WHO
LIVES IN SACRAMENTO. AND HE
LIVES WITH SCHIZOPHRENIA.
HE AND MY SON OR MY ONLY FAMILY.
SO.
MY HUSBAND MY SON'S FATHER
PASSED AWAY WHEN HE WAS EIGHT
MONTHS OLD.
AND THAT.
SORRY.
IN THE PAST.
I ALSO CARED FOR MY TWO
GRANDMOTHERS AS WELL AS MY
MOTHER.
AND I AM I'M HERE TODAY.
TELL YOU HOW WORRIED I AM.
AND OTHER KAREN.
CARE GIVERS AND CLIENTS ARE
ABOUT THE ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION.
WELCOME.
WITHOUT IT WITHOUT IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES WE DON'T I
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER HELP.
THAT'S ALL I'VE GOT.
AND.
.
AS HE CAN KNOW.
CARE GIVING IS A VERY INTENSE
AND UNPREDICTABLE.
DEMANDING JOB.
AND I'VE WORKED A VARIETY OF THE
INDUSTRY'S BEFORE MY SON WAS
BORN.
AND. THIS BY FAR IS THE HARDEST
JOB I'VE EVER HAD BUT ALSO THE
MOST REWARDING.
AND.
AT LEAST IN MY FAMILY'S CASE A.
WE DO MULTIPLE TASKS AT ONCE.
YOU KNOW. WE CAN'T JUST DO ONE
AND I COULD BE PREPARING HIS
FOOD FOR ONE SECOND.
HI COULD THEN BE IN THE MIDDLE
OF CHANGING HIS DIAPER HE'S NOT.
TOILET TRAINED HE DOESN'T SELF
FEED.
AND IF I DON'T GET TO THAT
TOILET TRAINING ARE CHANGING THE
DIAPER YOU CAN BE ASSURED
THERE'S A HUGE MESS ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
I HAD A SITUATION WHERE I DID
LITERALLY SIX TASS
TOOK SIX DIFFERENT TYPES OF
TASKS THAT ARE LISTED ON AYE H.
ASSESS.
WITHIN TEN MINUTES.
HOW MY SUPPOSED?
CHANGED PASS EVERY TIME YOU KNOW
AND ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT.
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE BUT.
.
IN THE NEWLY BBB SYSTEM IF WE
ARE FORCED TO LOG IN EVERY TIME
FOR EVERY TASK.
I DON'T SEE HOW THAT'S POSSIBLE
AND CERTAINLY NOT.
KEEP HIM SAFE AT THE SAME TIME.
AND THEN.
HELLO. SORRY. THAT.
THE ADMINISTRATION.
TIME THAT IT'S GONNA TAKE FOR
US TO DO THIS.
IT CAN'T COME FROM MY SON'S
HOURS
YOU NO HE GETS THE MAXIMUM
AMOUNT OF HOURS AS IT IS.
AND I'M STILL USUALLY UP TELL
MIDNIGHT MAN I GET BACK UP AT
FIVE THIRTY. AND I DON'T GET A
DAY OFF.
BUT THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT IT
SOMEWHAT COMPLAINING I'M JUST
SAYING.
YOU KNOW ADDING MORE TO IT.
WE REALLY DO NEED TO LOOK AT
HOW THIS IS GONNA BE.
IMPLEMENTED.
AND IN DOING SO WE ALSO HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE SERIOUS MATTER IF
THE INVASION OF THE PRIVACY AND
AT LEAST IN MY SON'S CASE. OF A
MINOR.
IT'S REALLY NOBODY'S BUSINESS
HOW MANY TIMES BECAUSE THE
BATHROOM IN A GIVEN DAY.
.
AND THE PRIVACY OF OTHERS YOU
KNOW.
A YOUNG OR OLD YOU KNOW NOBODY
WANTS TO HAVE THEIR LIVES
INVADED SO THE LEAST.
RESTRICTIVE MANNER IS A KEY TO
HAVE LESS.
.
I HEARD YOU GUYS CAREFULLY. TO
CONSIDER HOW YOU'RE IMPLEMENTING
THIS.
KEEP OUR VOICES IN MIND HAPLESS
PARTY NOW PARTY TO YOUR
DECISIONS.
AND.
BEFORE MOVING FORWARD AND.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
OUR CLIENTS GET THE BEST
POSSIBLE CARE IN THE SAFEST
MANNER I MEAN.
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR
IS TO KEEP OUR. OUR LOVED ONES
SAFE SO THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU TO.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO RETURN
BACK TO.
I CAN FOLLOW UP ON A CRISTINA
DYLAN TIFFANY WOULD.
HI W. THOMPSON. I DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ADULT PROGRAMS.
AND VIA ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION AS YEAR.
PROBABLY ALL AWARE WAS.
PART OF THE FEDERAL CURES OCT.
THE END OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
AND.
SO.
THE FIRST THING I I WANNA SAY IS
THE STATE IS INCREDIBLY
COMMITTED.
TO DOING EXACTLY WITH WHAT WITH
WHAT WAS SHARED WITH US JUST A
MOMENT AGO. WHICH IS TO LISTEN
TO AND HEAR THE VOICES OF OUR
RECIPIENTS ARE PROVIDERS.
ARE STAKEHOLDERS IN LOOKING AT
HOW TO APPROACH
THIS IMPLEMENTATION.
AND WE HAVE STARTED THAT
PROCESS.
WE STARTED IT LAST FALL.
WE BROUGHT TOGETHER MANY
STAKEHOLDERS ON THERE WAS ABOUT
TWO OR THREE HUNDRED THAT
PARTICIPATED IN.
.
I CAUGHT WORKS WORKGROUP THEN.
THAT WAS TO INFORM OUR INITIAL.
OUT REACH FOR A REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION.
TO FIND OUT ABOUT
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO LOOKING
AT ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION
TO SEE OF ANY OF THEM WOULD.
WORK FOR THE WAY I AM THE
PROGRAMS ARE OPERATED HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT REQUEST FOR INFORMATION
WHEN OUT IN NOVEMBER. RESPONSES
CAME BACK IN DECEMBER AND WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT THOSE LAST WEEK
WE HAD ANOTHER STAKEHOLDER
MEETING TO START SHARING ON THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE LEARNED
FROM THAT.
ONE OF THE.
.
OTHER THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO.
ASSASSIN IS ANY OTHER
INFORMATION COMING FROM.
THAT SEE A MASS THE PHONE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AROUND THIS
HOUSE FOREST LOOKING OUT WHAT.
.
WHAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE THIS WORK
THE BEST WE CAN IN IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS?
THE WAY WE OPERATE THE I
SUSPECT PROGRAM.
WE DID AT THAT.
STAKEHOLDER MEETING TRIED TO
START SHARING WHAT WE KNOW AND
THINGS THAT WE WANTED TO SHARE
WITH WET WITH FOLKS. ABOUT HOW
WERE ABOUT PHONE APPROACHING
THIS US FAR TO HELP TRY AND
START ALLEVIATING SOME OF THE
FEARS AND CONCERNS THAT.
INDIVIDUALS ARE HAVING.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WAS.
I STARTED. ON.
THAT IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE DO A THOUGHTFUL AND
DELIBERATE AND LISTENING
APPROACH TO THIS.
THAT ACTUALLY A PART OF THE
STATUTE DOES SAY THAT IT IS TO
BE INVOLVING STAKEHOLDERS AND
THAT IT IS TO.
DO THE LEAST CUMBERSOME PROCESS
AND WE TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY
AND WE LOOK AT OUT THAT AS THE
CORE OF OUR APPROACH TO THIS AND
KNOWING THAT.
WHILE THIS IS A REQUIRED.
IMPLEMENTATION BY JANUARY NIGHT
BUT TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE
KNOW THAT TO DO THAT IN
CALIFORNIA IS IS NOT POSSIBLE.
AND THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH CM BASS AROUND GOOD
FAITH EXTENSIONS SO THAT WE CAN
DO THIS CORRECTLY AND THAT WE
CAN ENSURE THAT WE HEAR ALL OF
THE VOICES THAT.
.
THAT WE NEED TO AND HOW WE
APPROACH THIS.
SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT DURING THAT
STAKEHOLDER. MEETING IS THE
ENGAGEMENT PLAN FOR STAKEHOLDERS
AND ARE RECIPIENTS AND PROVIDERS
AND AND THE DIFFERENT. WAYS THAT
WE INTEND TO. UMPS.
SHARE AND LISTEN YOU YOU GOT A
COPY OF SOCKS TODAY.
ONE OF THE FEARS THAT CAME UP.
LAST FALL WAS THE CONCERN ABOUT
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE TO ONLY
RECEIVE SERVICES IN THE HOME.
AND NOT BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE COMMUNITY.
WE ASSURED PEOPLE THAT THAT IS
NOT IN ANYWAY THE INTENT OF.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT THE STATE
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE WILL
CONTINUE AND.
THAT WE WILL IMPLEMENT THIS SO
THAT PEOPLE CONTINUE TO BE ABLE
TO RECEIVE SERVICES WHERE THEY
NEED THEM IF THEY'RE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY THEN THAT'S WHERE THEY
GET THEM. IT EBV SHOULD NOT
CHANGE.
ANYTHING ABOUT HOW SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED IN THAT IN THAT SENSE.
ON ANOTHER THING THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP JUST BY THE THE WOMAN
THAT SHARED WITH US A FEW
MOMENTS AGO. ON THE FEAR AROUND
HAVING TO CHECK IN AND CHECK OUT
BY SERVICE.
NO THAT'S NOT HOW IT WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED HERE AND SEE A MOUSE
HOUSE ALSO. SHARED THAT THAT IS
NOT THE EXPECTATION THAT THINGS
ARE GOING TO BE AT A MUCH HIGHER
LEVEL AS FAR AS TYPE OF SERVICE.
FEAR FEARS AROUND.
GPS AND BEING TRAPPED WHERE
PEOPLE ARE.
IT'S GPS IS NOT A REQUIREMENT
OF EBV AND THE STATE DOES NOT
INTEND TO UTILIZE THAT AS AN
IMPLEMENTATION APPROACH. ALSO I
I THINK THE MAIN THING THAT I
WANT TO SHARE WITH ALL OF YOU
TODAY IS OUR COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUING TO LISTEN TO THESE
FEARS AND CONCERNS. AND LOOK AT
WAYS THAT WE CAN DO THIS THAT
WILL BE.
ON THE LEAST BURDENSOME AND.
THAT WE CAN ON THEM.
I'D ADOPT A WAY TO DO THIS FOR.
CALIFORNIA AND THAT MAKES
SOME SENSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA HAVE CRISTINA
ABOUT HIM.
THINK YOU DOCTOR A BILL AND
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
BEING FLEXIBLE IN ALLOWING OUR
OUR MEMBER TO TESTIFY EARLIER.
I DON'T REALLY HAVE MUCH MORE TO
A OUTSIDE I THINK SHE SPOKE VERY
ELOQUENTLY.
EXCEPT TO SAY THAT UW IS.
OPPOSED TO E. V. V. WE DO
UNDERSTAND IT'S A FEDERAL
MANDATE.
SO IT'S COMPLICATED BUT JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION
TO THE CONCEPT IN GENERAL BUT
ALSO.
APPRECIATION TO THE DEPARTMENT
FOR EXPRESSING. GENUINE.
.
CONCERNED WITH DOING IT DOING
THIS IN A WAY THAT'S NOT HARMFUL
THANK YOU.
IF ANYONE AT THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
I'M WE APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
BY THE DEPARTMENT TO PROTECT THE
DIGNITY AND THE PRIVACY OF THE
RECIPIENTS AND PRIVACY.
AS WELL AS INDICATING THAT THE
STATE WOULD NOT BE READY TO ROLL
OUT IMPLEMENTATION ON JANUARY
ONE HOWEVER WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
ABSENT GUIDANCE FROM CMS AND A
REAL COST ANALYSIS BEFORE
IMPLEMENTATION THERE'S TOO
LITTLE INFORMATION TO MOVE
FORWARD EBV IS A BURDEN SOME
REQUIREMENT THAT CAN POTENTIALLY
LEAD TO A DECLINE IN AUTHORIZED
HOURS. IS INVASIVE OF CONSUMER
PROVIDER PRIVACY AND YET ANOTHER
REQUIREMENT PLACED ON AYE AGES
AS PROVIDERS THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE TO FULFILL WITHOUT
COMPENSATION ARE PROVIDERS WANT
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE QUALITY
CARE TO THEIR CONSUMERS. AND THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE WAY IN EBV
WOULD JEOPARDIZE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WILL HAVE
MICHELLE ROSSI.
OKAY A GOOD AFTER DID IT TAKE
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY. UP MANY SPECIAL ROSY OF
HHS CONSUMER ADVOCATE HERE AT
THE STATE. OF.
EVEN THE REAL WORLD AS MANY OF
STATE EVER. PUT.
THINGS HAVE PLACE BETTER REALLY
BAD FOR THE HSS PROGRAM AS A
CONSUMER. I HEALTH CONCERNS
THAT.
OF MAKE KATIE BY CARE PROVIDER
THAT I'VE HAD FOR OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS BECAUSE WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING. HOMES. OF
REQUIREMENTS DAY THAT IS MORE
CUMBERSOME.
IT IN MANY AREAS WE HAVE NO
ACCESS TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT.
YEAH. I ISSUES JUST IS ALREADY
SUFFERING FROM. A STRUCTURAL
PROBLEMS THAT COULD SCRATCH THAT
THREAT OF BUDGET CUTS HIGH
WORKER TURNOVER. TABLE PAYROLL
DELAYS COMPLICATED REGULATIONS
DIRE POVERTY BOTH CONSUMERS AND
PROVIDERS IN THE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT PROCEDURE REQUIRED TO
CORRECT TIME SHE ERRORS. TODAY
OF A FEW.
DON'T ADD ANOTHER LAYER OF
POTENTIAL DYSFUNCTION WITHOUT
FIRST FIXING CONSIDERED WRITING
ISSUES AND PROBLEMS.
EVGA WILL DIMINISH QUALITY OF
CARE AND ADDED LATER OF
REPORTING AND RED TAPE BE ROLLED
OUT THROUGH OUT THE CHARACTER
THE. THE COUNTRY AND NOT
REALISTIC IN TERMS OF DR GUPTA
BANDS OF THE WORK. PERSONAL CARE
IS THE VARIABLE IT INTERPRETED
AND NOT CONFINED TO THE HOLD AN
AWFUL ARE.
RFID INVOLVES WE'LL TALK MULTI
TASK.
FLEXIBLE FLEXIBILITY IS IT
ESSENTIAL IN ORDER FOR CONSUMER
DIRECTED CARE TO SUCCEED.
CALIFORNIA'S ATTEMPT TO CONFORM
TO THE FEDERAL MANDATE. IS
TRYING TO FIT A ROUND PEG INTO A
SQUARE HOLE.
YEAH.
YOU KNOW WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT
TRYING TO FIND WAYS FOR THE
SEVEN PERCENT TO TO NOT BE.
CONTINUE CUT DOWN THE ROAD
THERE'S OTHERS SEEING STATE THIS
STATE. NEEDS TO LOOK AT AND
FIXING THE PROGRAM. EVENINGS WE
HAD THIS STATE SHOULD NOT BE
IMPLEMENTING.
I THINK THAT.
IT'S NOT FUNDED.
TO THE EXTENT THAT IT MEANS TO
BE EVERYBODY TO LOOK AT OTHER
WAYS TO MAKE THE PROGRAM I
BETTER TAKE SUCCESSFUL FOR ITS
CONSUMERS THINKING. THINK USUAL.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA A.
WE JUST LIKE TO ECHO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT FOR
A ROBUST THEY CALLED OUR PLAN
AND IMPLEMENTATION DOES NOT THAT
DOES NOT ALTER THE HOMES THAT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SALABLE SHAPE YES GROUP
OKAY OF.
ALTHOUGH I I FEEL SAID THAT
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT THE
STATE HAS IMPLEMENTED. IS IS.
IT'S SECOND THAT'S GOOD I THINK
THAT.
SINCE SEE SEE SEE I WENT AWAY
AT THAT THE THAT I JUST ESTATE
RESTORING THE CONSUMER. OF THAT
I HAVE COMMITTEE WAS.
DEMOLISH BASICALLY TAKEN OUT OF
PLACE AND I THINK SINCE IT WAS
TAKEN OUT OF PLACE AS CONSUMERS
THEY WERE PART OF THAT
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND
COMMITTEE. OF. ARE FINDING WAYS
TO TO WORK WITH THIS STATE RTV
V. BUT I THINK IT'S SHOULD LARGE
OF A PROCESS THAT THEY'VE
IMPLEMENTED RIGHT NOW THERE'S
TOO MANY CONSUMERS INVOLVED.
TOWARD TO BE SUCCESSFUL I THINK
IT NEEDS TO BE BROUGHT DOWN TO A
SMALLER GROUP OF CONSUMERS AND
PROVIDERS SO THAT WE COULD
REALLY LOOKING GET ANTICIPATED
GRADING OF REALLY WORK AT.
DO YOU THINK YOU.
WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE FIVE.
HELLO AGAIN.
.
I'VE BEEN SITTING HERE ALL
AFTERNOON TRYING TO DECIDE
WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO GO AND
APPROACH THIS WITH YOU GUYS.
I KNOW THAT THIS IS A FEDERAL
MANDATED THINGS SO MY FINALLY
WHAT I CAME TO THE CONCLUSION
IS.
IS TO BAG OUR SENATORS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO REACH WASHINGTON
DC AND LET THEM KNOW HOW STUPID
OF A PLAN ON THIS THE IS THEY'VE
COME UP WITH.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR TWENTY
FOUR YEARS
I AM PROUD OF MY.
WE TAKE CARE OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO
NEED HELP.
TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES WE SAVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED STATES MONEY EVERY DAY
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT HAVING TO
PAY TO KEEP THESE PEOPLE. PEOPLE
AND INSTITUTES BUT EVER SINCE I
WENT TO WORK FOR AYE H. AYE SASS
I AM ALWAYS HAVING TO DEFEND
MYSELF.
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE ALWAYS TELLING
ME THAT I AM A. THIEF
OF FRAUD AYE THREE I TAKE DRUGS
NONE OF THE ABOVE EVER IN MY
LIFETIME.
AND NOW YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO TAKE A PROGRAM
WHERE WE'RE ALREADY.
WE HAVE A GUIDELINE.
WE'VE HAD A GUIDELINE.
THERE ARE ONLY A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF HOURS THAT OUR PLANES GOING
OUT PER MONTH.
AND IF ANYBODY IS WORRIED THAT
THE PROVIDER IS NOT DOING THOSE
HOURS THEN LET THE SOCIAL WORKER
DOING HER JOB AND GO IN AND
PROVE THAT.
BUT DON'T PUT IN OUR COUNTY
WHERE THE LARGEST EMPLOYER.
WE HAVE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
PROVIDERS IN OUR COUNTY.
ALL OVER EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
PROVIDERS ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE
TIME TO GO CHECK GUINEAN CHECK
HIM OUT I'VE GOT FOR CLIENTS ONE
OF THEM IS MY SON WINDOW I
CHECKED IT OUT FOR HIM.
HE LIVES WITH ME I TAKE CARE OF
HIM IN THE MORNING I TAKE CARE
BUT THAT NIGHT I TAKE CARE MEAN
THE DAY.
SO I CLOCK IN PLUCKED OUT
SERIOUSLY.
I DON'T NEED TO BE MONITORED.
IN MY JOB.
I DON'T BELIEVE YOU GUYS ARE
MONITORED IN YOUR JOB AND I KNOW
OUR PRESIDENT IS IT OTHERWISE WE
WOULD BE GO THROUGH WHAT WE GO
THROUGH.
NOW I'M SORRY I I KNOW I WAS
GOING TO TRY TO BE CALMER THAN
THIS.
BUT.
IT ISN'T REALLY DISCOURAGING TO
ME.
THAT TWENTY FOUR YEARS I'VE HAD
TO DEFEND MYSELF.
AND MY HONOR.
AND YOU HAVE JUST SLAPPED ME IN
THE FACE WASHINGTON DC WITH ONE
ANOTHER THING THAT YOU WANT TO
SAY I'M A CROOK.
WHO'S GOOD IN THIS IS MY OTHER
ISSUE.
WE DON'T WE JUSTFINALLY ARE
STARTING TO GET A QUALITY OF
LIFE LIVING WAGE FOR THE NEXT
FOUR YEARS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MINIMUM WAGE IS
GOING TO BE GOING UP EVERY YEAR
UNTIL WE GET TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS
AN HOUR.
HOW MANY YEARS DID IT TAKE ME TO
GET TO THAT FOLKS?
WHAT DID NINE YEARS BY THE TIME
HE GETS THERE?
AND ALL THAT TIME MY FOOD COSTS
BY EVERY OTHER COST HAS GONE UP
BUT MY WAGES HAVE IT.
AND NOW YOU WANT TO SPEND MONEY
IMPLEMENTING A PROGRAM TO DO
WHAT.
JUST TELL ME THAT I'M A PRODUCT
THAT'S WHAT IT'S TELLING ME YOU
GOTTA CHECK ME AND CHECK ME OUT.
THE MY GET A CHECK OUT TO THE
BOAT TO THE GROCERY STORE FOR MY
CLIENTS THAT I HAVE TO CHECK
BACK IN WHEN I GET BACK WITH THE
GROCERIES INSTEAD OF. PUTTING
ICE CREAM IN THE FREEZER.
I'M SORRY.
PLEASE CONTACT WASHINGTON DC I'M
TELLING HOW FOOLISH THEY ARE
WITH THIS FOLLY.
WE DO NOT NEED THIS PROGRAM.
IT'S GOING TO COST MONEY THAT WE
DON'T HAVE I'M TOLD IN MY COUNTY
FARM A BORDER SUPERVISORS THAT I
CAN HAVE A COST OF LIVING WAGE
IN MY CONTRACT.
BECAUSE THE MONEY ISN'T THERE.
BUT YOU HAVE THE MONEY TO
IMPLEMENT EVEY V.. REALLY.
SORRY.
YOU MAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON BUTTONS USING MY
NAME AS A SIGN OFF ON DINAH. I
AM FOR MERCED. AND I AM A PROUD
UNION MEMBER WOULD YOU W..
AND THE I'D DO HAVE A SON HIS
NAME IS. MARIO ADDRESS AND THIS.
AND HE WAS BORN SPECIALS SOUL HE
NOW REQUIRES THIRTY ONE YEARS
OLD BUT HE REQUIRES. TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN CARE I'M ONLY HERE BECAUSE
MY HUSBAND HELPED ME OR MY
DAUGHTERS WOULD HELP ME TO. COME
OVER HERE.
AND THERE ARE WHAT I WANT TO SAY
IT I REALLY HOPE THAT THIS DOES
NOT GO THROUGH BECAUSE EVER
SINCE I HEARD OF THE EVP I WAS
LIKE WOW REALLY I MEAN COME ON.
YOU KNOW WHAT ABOUT WHEN MY
SENATE SITTING ON THE COUCH AND
HE TELLS ME MOM THAT WILL PUT.
AND THEN I GO OKAY HERE I GO.
RING UP AND TAKEN I SOMETIMES MY
BUSINESS ELSEWHERE W. WALKER
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T WALK.
BUT THEN I WILL SHOOT YOU TO BE
PUT IMPACT THE WHOLE BIT ARE
GONNA GO TO PUT MY CARTER. YOU
KNOW IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE
WHAT I DO DROP HIM ON THE FLOOR
SO I CAN GO SIGN IN BECAUSE I
WANT MY MINUTES.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE HE
REQUIRES TWENTY FOUR HOUR CARE
WHETHER IS AT NIGHT WHEN I'M
ASLEEP. AT THE CHECK ON HIM
SOMETIMES I SLEEP WITH HIM AND
HE ENTERED THE ETHNICITY WITH
HIM SO DO I WHEN I WAS HAPPY TO
SEE THEM TO AYE CLOCK AND THEN
BY CLOCK OUT. I MEAN IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE I REALLY REALLY
HOPE THAT THIS DOES NOT GO
THROUGH.
BECAUSE IT JUST.
KELLY IT'S.
I'M IT IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE TO ME AND I'VE BEEN TAKING
CARE OF HIM WITH IT JUST US FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND OTHER TIMES I
WAS BY MYSELF WITHOUT AYE
JUSTICE. AND I DID IT THEN. AND
I KIDS CONTINUE TO DO IT YOU
LOVE THESE CHILDREN THERE IS NO
WAY YOU EXCEPT FOR EVEN YOU WILL
NOT ACCEPT THEM TO GO TO A HOME
OR FOR SOMEONE ELSE TO TAKE CARE
OF THEM IF IT'S NOT YOUR FAMILY.
BUT PLEASE YOU KNOW IF YOU GUYS
HAVE SOME WAY TO BOIL BUT PLEASE
DO NOT PERMIT. TRUMP TO DO THIS
TO US BECAUSE THE ONE THAT IS A
VVV AT HIM ON HIS LEG OR HIS
WHAT SOMEWHERE ON HIM TO KEEP
TRACK OF HIM.
NOT OF I THINK YOU.
GIVEN.
HUNDRED INSURERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION.
I ATTENDED LAST WEEK.
WHAT IT MEANS?
EVEN THOUGH WE OPPOSE.
I DO
AMEND THE DEPARTMENT FOR
LISTENING.
FEARS AND.
AS THEY CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS OAKLEY SUCCESSFULLY IN
A WAY THAT PROTECTS EVERYONE.
I ALSO WANT THEM TECHNOLOGIES
THAT.
I'LL SEE FOR FORTY YEARS AGO
ADVOCATING.
AYE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES TO
ASSIST SUPPORT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES LIVE INDEPENDENTLY.
SCHUMER DIRECTED.
IF THE BASIC TENET OF THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING PHILOSOPHY.
SO WE ARE CONCERNED OR IF.
WE GO.
TOO FAR IN THE OTHER DIRECTION.
THIS COULD ACTUALLY REPRESENT OF
RETREAT
FROM THAT IMPORTANT PHILOSOPHY
FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING.
AND SO WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL
KEEP IN MIND ANY POTENTIAL.
PITFALLS THAT COULD.
REDUCE CONSUMER IN PARLIAMENT.
SELF DETERMINATION.
CHOICE.
M. DECRY DECREASE IN THE BATTLE
OF INOPPORTUNE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR.
IT AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AND THE PANEL OF WE APPRECIATE
THE PANEL'S EFFORTS THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO THE IMPOSSIBLE.
THAT'S A MY NAME IS BRADLEY I'M
A HOME CARE WORKER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO MY TO CLIENTS.
.
ARE VERY FRIGHTENED OF THIS.
PAPER A TIME SHEET WILL GO AWAY.
I TRY TO TEACH MY CLIENT TO A
USE THE DIAL. OF. A DOWN ON HIS
PHONE AND YOU KNOW YOU'VE PUT IN
THE NUMBERS.
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW WE'RE GOING
WE ARE GETTING INTO THIS ON
THAT.
PERSONAL LEVEL
I APPRECIATE YOU TRYING BUT YOU
HAVE TO TELL THEM NO. A. GOOD
FAITH EFFORT ATTEMPT.
WELL WE HOPE THAT THAT THAT
THERE SOME PEOPLE AT CMS THAT
AREN'T CRAZY LIKE THE REST OF
ADMINISTRATION AND THAT THEY'LL
DO THAT'LL GIVE US SOME READING
TIME.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO TAKE THE
PENALTY. I THINK FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND NOT IMPLEMENT
IT AND THE FIRST TWO YEARS WE
CAN AFFORD IT I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT AFTERWARDS HOPEFULLY WILL
BE A GOVERNMENT CHANGE.
.
A.
LOOKING AT THE COMPANIES THAT
WE'VE ASKED FOR THE REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION IT'S NOT INSPIRING.
MAXIM HEALTH.
OF.
THEY HAVE HAD CLASS ACTION
LAWSUITS.
UP FROM THEIR EMPLOYEES FOR
OVERTIME VIOLATIONS
YOU KNOW AND WE KNOW THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT'S GOING TO BE
RELYING ON A PARTNERSHIP WITH
THESE ARE AT FAULT YOU KNOW SOME
OF THEM WERE ONE OF THEM OR
WHOEVER YOU SELECT.
.
THE THE PRIME CARE.
FROM A STONE'S THROW AWAY FROM
STONE MOUNTAIN IN SUBURBAN
ATLANTA. THEY THINK IT'S OKAY TO
HAVE AN EMBLEM THAT LOOKS LIKE
THIS.
AND YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S SCARY.
THAT MY INFORMATION MY CONSUMERS
INFORMATION WOULD BE ACCESSED BY
PEOPLE THAT THINK THIS IS AN
OKAY EMBLEM.
FOR A A HEALTHCARE COMPANY IF
PEOPLE CAN SEE IT IT LOOKS LIKE
A MODIFIED SWASTIKA.
SO YOU KNOW.
WE.
WHAT'S THE LIFE.
WHAT'S THE LIFE TERM OF THE
INFORMATION ON OF OURS THAT
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE ARE THEY
GONNA BE RE PURPOSING IT.
MONETIZING IT IN ANOTHER WAY I
MEAN YOU KNOW I KNOW YOU GUYS
ARE GOING TO TRY TO CONTROL THAT
AT SOME LEVEL BUT. WE HAVE BEEN
TALKED ABOUT THAT YET. AT ALL
AND YOU KNOW BIOMETRICS IS A
BILL BE FINGERPRINTS FACE PRINCE
WHATEVER I MEAN MY CLIENT. I
TRIED HIS WE HE DOESN'T ALLOW
ONLINE ANYMORE BECAUSE IT IT WAS
FLOODED AND IT DOESN'T WORK YOU
KNOW FINALLY GOT A MINUTE.
AS A CELL PHONE BUT HE YOU KNOW
HE'S NOT EVEN ABLE TO LIKE YOU
KNOW. MANAGE THAT BUT WE'RE WORK
AT WORK AND MAYBE YOU KNOW HE'S
GOT WHAT HE NEEDS HE WOULD NOT
SURVIVE. OUTSIDE INSTITUTIONAL.
BUT WITHOUT MY TO ASSESS
SO YOU KNOW WE THINK YOU FOR THE
PROGRAM AND ALL AND YOU'RE
LISTENING BUT IF YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO THE IMPOSSIBLE BUT LET'S
NOT DO IT. OKAY.
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAN YOU
RESIDENT BECKONED I'M A UW.
I JUST AS PROVIDER.
I'M.
THE YEAR IS IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS PROGRAM WILL REALLY AFFECT
THE QUALITY OF CARE MY CLIENT IS
SEVENTY THREE YEARS OLD AND HE
HAS MULTIPLE MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
AND IT WOULD.
JUST STOP AND START IN ORDER TO
LOG IN AND OUT. OR HOWEVER THE
GOING TO RUN WHATEVER FORMAT IS
GOING TO BE USED. ISSUES IS JUST
NOT FEASIBLE IT'S IT'S NOT
PRACTICAL AND IT WILL AFFECT THE
QUALITY OF CARE. MY CLIENT ALSO
HAS.
PRIVACY CONCERNS AS WELL AS YOU
KNOW TECHNOLOGICAL CONCERNS HE
HE HE HE DOES NOT USE A
CELLPHONE LET ALONE.
.
PARTICIPATE IN ANY KIND OF VVV
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND. BUT YOU KNOW THE THE THE
WHOLE PART OF THIS IN IN THE OF
THE.
CENTURY HERE'S ACT WAS TO.
.
WAS ENHANCE AYE FROTHING THROUGH
THIS TO SOLUTION TO A PROBLEM
THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I AM HERE JUST MONITORING THE
HEAD THIS THIS LADY IN FRONT OF
YOU KNOWS. THAT I GO TO THESE
THINGS BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
AND NO OPPOSITION YOU NEED TO
DOCUMENT ALL OF THE PROBLEMS
WITH. THIS SERVICE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MAY BE
MANDATING IT BUT YOU NEED TO
SHOW WHAT THE PROBLEMS ARE
BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A TOUGH
THING.
AND THE FACT THAT WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO.
REALLY IS LIKE THE
FINGERPRINTING ISSUE BEFORE AND
IS SOMETHING THAT TAKES SO MUCH
EFFORT.
IT DOESN'T WORK WHILE WE KNOW
YOU I JUST NEED YOU TO STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD IN THE.
EACH JUROR NICOLE YES.
JEFF TORTILLA ARAB TICKET.
SORT OF RESIDENT HERE IT SEEMS
LIKE IT THIS CAPITAL.
.
CARA.
THAT'S A MILLION YEAR CLASS.
HOWL OLDER WOMEN'S LEAGUE UMP
DOG FIGHTER BECAUSE IT'S AN
ISSUE THE EQUALITY AND.
I GUESS THAT'S THE GIFTS YOU
THE NAME JEFFREY.
HARD.
KEY UP THANK YOU JEFFREY.
HELLO MY NAME IS TAMARA ANY SHE
CAN ONE I'M A HOME CARE PROVIDER
AND A PROUD MEMBER OF SEIU
TWENTY FIFTEEN. I TAKE CARE MY
SON WHO'S SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD
WHO HAS AUTISM. HIS AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY WOULD
NOT ALLOW HIM TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
PART IN ANY TYPE OF ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION.
.
YOU THINK. I'M AND I WORRY ABOUT
ALL OF THE CONSUMERS EXPENSIVE
THE PEOPLE WITH DEMENTIA.
WHO WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO?
TAKE PART IN THIS HOW WOULD
THAT WORK.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT ALL
DISABLED AND PERSONS WHO AM WHO
USE AYE TO ASSESS HIS ARM
PRIVACY AND ON THE USE OF THEIR
INFORMATION OF THE INFORMATION
CAPTURED.
EXIT CONCERT AT BECAUSE.
ALREADY ON THE INTERNET IS IS
ABLE TO. SELL AT THEIR PEAK
INFORMATION AND LAWS CHANGE SO I
WONDER HOW I'M.
ANY ORGANIZATION THAT.
IS BEING PAID BY THE STATE TO
CAPTURE THIS INFORMATION WOULD
BE ABLE TO USE THAT INFORMATION
AND SELL IT TO OTHER THIRD PARTY
VENDORS. LIKE SAY A PERSON WHO'S
BEING SEEN AS USING THE BATHROOM
A LOT GETTING AND IN AN EMAIL
ABOUT DEPENDS DIAPERS.
I'M ALSO EXTREMELY CONCERNED
ABOUT.
THIS STATE ON PAYING A THIRD
PARTY ORGANIZATION TO IMPLEMENT
THIS BECAUSE.
THEIR GET THEIR FIRST CONCERN
IS IS MAKING SURE THAT THEY MAKE
MONEY OFF OF THIS SITUATION IN
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE MADE MONEY OFF OF I ASK
THAT THIS.
THAT THE STATE NOT IMPLEMENT
THIS BUT IF THEY DO TO KEEP IT
AS A STATE. I'M RUN.
PROGRAM AND NOT AT A PRIVATE
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SHARON THE CHESSIE
I'M FROM PLASTER COUNTY OUR
PROBLEM IMPROVE UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS OF MY UNION IN THAT
COUNTY.
UP I HAVE SEVERAL CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS PROGRAM.
.
IN SIR AM ALSO MY I'M I'M
PRIVILEGED ENOUGH TO BE ALSO MY
COUNTY RAP. WITH MY UNION AND
TALKING TO SOME OF OUR MEMBERS.
WE HAVE MEMBERS OUT IN VERY
RURAL AREAS WHERE IT'S SPOTTY TO
GET. ANY SELF SERVICE AND
LANDLINE SERVICE SO I OUT
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT HOW IS
THAT GOING TO AFFECT THEM. ON
TOP OF THAT IN WITH ME RIGHT FOR
MY CLIENT I LIVE WITH MY CLIENT.
OF. IT WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT
FOR ME TO DO ANY KIND OF LOGGING
IN ARE LOGGING OUT. BECAUSE I
MIGHT SPEND TEN MINUTES IN THE
MORNING AND THAT COUPLE HOURS
OFF TO DO MY OWN THING AND THEN.
I'M DOING SOMETHING ELSE FORM
FOR A COUPLE HOURS AND IT'S AN
ALL DAY THING ABOUT MY DAY
YESTERDAY.
OR ACTUALLY SATURDAY LAST WEEK
WOULD HAVE BEEN A PERFECT
EXAMPLE I WOKE UP AT SIX IN THE
MORNING TO HELP HIM HE JUST HAD
BACK SURGERY.
TO HELP THEM TELL THEM GO TO THE
BATHROOM I WENT BACK TO BED FOR
A COUPLE HOURS I HAD TO GET UP
AND MAKING BREAKFAST THAT I HAD
TO HELP HIM GET DRESSED.
THEN I WAS ABLE TO CLEAN THE
KITCHEN. AND IT GOES ON AND ON
AND FINALLY BY THE TIME I WAS
ABLE TO GO TO GO TO SLEEP IT WAS
TWO O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING.
BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN I HAD TO
HELP THEM WITH OTHER ISSUES.
SO.
ALONG IN ANALOG OUT TIME I'M
HOPING THAT WE CAN USE SOME SORT
OF COMMON SENSE ON THIS IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO DO IT BIT
BY BIT.
MAYBE JUST LOGGING AND MAYBE
JUST USING OUR ELECTRONIC TIME
SHEETS.
THAT WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED NOW OF
MIGHT BE THE ANSWER BUT JUST.
WE KNOW WHAT'S COMING WE KNOW
WHAT'S GONNA WE WE KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO COME AROUND I'M JUST
ASKING YOU GUYS USE COMMON SENSE
ON THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MA'AM.
CHRISTOPHER MORENO.
DISTRICT FOR STANISLAUS COUNTY
BEEN WITH U. DW'S. TWO THOUSAND
TEN.
I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE YOUR
PERSONAL STORY BECAUSE IT'S NONE
OF YOUR BUSINESS.
BUT WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT WE
ARE.
CALIFORNIANS AND WHEN WE'RE
STRONG ARM BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WE NEED LEADERS TO
PAY ATTENTION.
LIKE THE YOUNG MAN UP THERE IN
THE BLUE.
AND I LISTEN TO WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SAYING.
BECAUSE.
WE REPRESENT A MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS
THEN SOME STATES.
OKAY.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS WERE
BRINGING IN ALL LARA MORE MONEY
THEN THOSE SAME STATES. THAT
DON'T HAVE THAT POPULATION
COMBINED.
SO IF IT'S A MONEY ISSUE AND
IT'S ABOUT TAKING THAT TAKEN A
HIT. DON'T PAY TAXES.
THE PRESIDENT DOES IT WE DON'T
NEED TO PAY FEDERAL TAXES EITHER
LET'S KEEP THAT MONEY AT HOME.
AND LET'S LET'S FUND THE SOCIAL
PROGRAMS THERE'S MONEY HERE SO
DON'T TELL THESE PEOPLE THAT
THERE'S NOT MONEY BOTH FIND IT.
WE HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
WITH FIFTY OR A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR VEHICLES TOYS AT THAT.
DO SOMETHING DO SOMETHING GO
FIND THE MONEY IT'S THEIR.
I AYE IMPLORE YOU TO BE STRONG.
AND COURAGEOUS.
MY NAME IS ADAM GREEN UT W..
I HAVE AN IDEA.
FOR YOU.
THAT MIGHT BE AN IDEA THAT THESE
PEOPLE LIKE YOU MIGHT NOT LIKE.
WHY DON'T WE CREATED NUMBER?
KEEP ACCOUNTABILITY IF YOU
FOLKS.
AND OUR GOVERNMENT.
HOW WOULD YOU GUYS LIKE THAT?
YOU WANNA KEEP ACCOUNTABILITY
ABBAS.
I FIND THIS VERY INTERESTING.
MY EMPLOYER FINAL DO MY WORK
WILL KICK MY REAR END OUT THE
HOUSE.
BECAUSE THAT'S MY JOB I TOOK ON
THAT RESPONSIBILITY.
M. I TAKE IT VERY SERIOUSLY TO I
LOVE WHAT I DO I LOVE THE FACT
THAT I CAN TAKE CARE OF THIS
PERSON. AND MATTER FACT WHEN
THESE DAYS ALL OF YOU TO MEET
THIS PERSON SHOES AMOENUS
CURRICULA EVER MEET.
SHE'S A VIETNAM VETERAN WHO'S
GIVEN OUR ALTER COUNTRY.
SHE HAS OUT ATTITUDE FROM
VIETNAM OVERNIGHT NOTHING BUT A
THING.
ASSEMBLY MITCH CARRIES UP VERY
WELSH SPOUSE ANATOMY EVEN
BETTER.
M..
SHE LIVES LIFE FREELY.
RIGHT NOW
SHE IS A BREAST CANCER SURVIVOR.
JEFF TITANIUM RODS UP AND DOWN
HER BACK.
WHICH IS STILL WALKS AROUND SHE
STILL GETS AROUND SHIELDS ENJOYS
LIFE AND SHE MADE SURE THE SAME
FOR ME.
IF IT WASN'T FOR HER I WOULD
HAVE QUALITY OF LIFE HOW DOWN IN
THE STREET.
I LOVE HER DEARLY EVERYDAY.
THAT'S WHY I DO THIS FOR.
SO WHAT COMES TO ACCOUNTABILITY
I THINK THERE'S OTHER OPTIONS.
AND I LIKE THAT IS AN IDEA YOU
CAN TELL MY GOVERNMENT.
THAT THE MOM ON THEIR NOT
WORKING FOR US IT IS TIME THAT
WE HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE AND I
THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO. GET A
NUMBER ONE FOR US AND HAVE THEM
CALL US AND LET US KNOW THE
WORKING FOR US.
BUT YOU VERY MUCH
SIR.
I'M MY NAME'S NICOLE CARTER I'M
FROM YOLO COUNTY I ALSO WORK
WITH THE PRIVATE AGENCY. I DON'T
REALLY SEE JUST THE EVENING THE.
NOT ONLY IS IT JUST.
UNREALISTIC TO CLOCK IN EVERY
TIME YOU HAVE A TASK
BUT IT IS A BIGGER ISSUE OF
PRIVACY.
YOUR PHONE STORE OR THE
RECORDING EVERYTHING YOU SAY I
GET ADS ABOUT SOMETHING I SAID
TWENTY MINUTES AGO AND. SO
HAVING A CAMERON SOMEBODY'S HOME
RECORDING THEM IF THEY GO TO THE
BATHROOM OR EVEN EATING A MALE.
IT'S NOT REALLY REALISTIC IF
YOU GUYS CAN'T TRUST US TOMORROW
EVEN WORKING FOR YOU. LIKE THE
PREVIOUS MAN SAID FEW GUYS CAN'T
TRUST US THAT WE CAN'T TRUST
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN.
CURRENTLY.
CASH REVEREND STAR.
AND.
I'VE BEEN IN HOME HEALTH CARE I
HAVE EIGHTY YEAR OLD MOTHER THAT
I LIVE WHERE. I ALSO LIVE WITH
MY DAUGHTER THAT JUST PREVIOUSLY
SPOKE.
AND. THERE'S A LOT ISSUES HERE
TODAY BACK REGARD ADDRESS EVD MY
MOTHER IS EIGHTY. ABSOLUTELY AS
TERRIFIED OF GAS.
SHE DOES NOT WANT CAMERAS IN HER
HOME.
I HAD TO FIGHT TO GET OUTSIDE
CAMERAS ON.
THERE'S NO WAY.
IF YOU GUYS DID A POLL.
AS THE GENERATION THAT WERE
CARING FOR. THEIR UNIT TELL YOU
THEY DON'T WANT THIS SYSTEM.
THESE PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING TO GET
AND.
DECENT NOT EVEN DECENT ACTED
SELECCION OUR.
FOR JOB THEY DO EVERYDAY WITH
OPEN HEARTS AND LOVING CARING.
THEY CARE.
WE NEED OUR GOVERNMENT TO CHAIR
BACK.
AND I ACTUALLY SAID THIS NIGHT
OF THE MURDER WAS IN MY HEAD SO
I THINK YOU. THINK YOU HAVE.
I MY NAME IS BONITA MANY US AND
I'M FROM SONOMA COUNTY.
AND I AM I TAKE CARE OF MY SON
TOLD ME AND REQUIREMENTS.
AND.
.
TOBIN HAS CONCERNS THAT. YOU
KNOW OF THIS GETS IMPLEMENTED
THAT IT'S GONNA AND VADIAS
PRIVACY.
HE WON'T BE ABLE TO DO YEAH
HE'S DOING A FIASCO THE BATHROOM
SOME MONEY OF WE WATCHING THEM.
AND HE'S HE'S NOT TOO HAPPY
ABOUT IT. AND FOR ME TO.
GO IN.
AND HAVE TO BE ON THE PHONE ALL
THE TIME WHEN I'M DOING STUFF
WITH HIM BECAUSE I HAVE TO WATCH
HIM TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY. AND
THAT HE WAS ON THE TOILET AND I
HAD TO GO.
TALK TO SOMEBODY ON THE PHONE
HE'S GONNA FALL OFF THAT TOILET
BECAUSE I AM TO BE THERE RIGHT
BY HIM.
HE'S
HE'S.
NOT TOILET.
HE'S NOT HE'S DONE CALL IOWA IF
NOT COMPLETELY POTTY TRAINED.
AND YOU KNOW YOU DON'T SOLANO
WORK AND IF I HAVE TO GO IN AND.
YOU KNOW AND I CAN'T SPEND MY
TIME WITH HIM.
YOU KNOW HE'S GOING TO GET HURT
BECAUSE HE DOES THINGS HE TRIES
TO DO THINGS YEAH DO ANY GETS
HURT. AND AND YOU KNOW IT TAKES
OUR MIAMI MY TIME YOU KNOW TO
TAKE CARE YEAH SO WE'RE ASKING
THAT DO NOT IMPLEMENT THIS HAS
IT'S AN INVASION OF OUR CLIENTS
RIGHTS.
THANK YOU MA'AM THANK YOU TOBIN.
HI AM SONYA KRANZ AND I JUST
THIS WORKER AND.
.
I WORK FOR MY SON.
A ADAM AND.
I WOULD ECHO ALL THE CONCERNS.
THAT WE'VE HEARD OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
I REALLY AM CONFUSED AS TO.
WHAT THE ISSUES OUR I WOULDN'T I
WOULDN'T MIND HEARING FROM YOU?
?
IN SOME FORM THAT COULD BE.
SENT OUT TO US.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE ABOUT.
WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT WHY ARE
YOU CONCERNED?
THAT.
IN YOU KNOW IS THERE A IS THERE
A PROBLEM HERE THAT'S.
BROUGHT THIS WHOLE ISSUE UP THAT
YOU FEEL THAT THE. TAIL IS BEING
ROBBED OR THAT PEOPLE ARE BEING
FRAUDULENT.
.
I'M NOT SURE WHY THAT EVEN HAS
BECOME A PROBLEM. IN THIS AREA.
AM ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE.
THE MONEY THAT IS GOING TO TAKE.
TO EVEN.
EVEN THAT YOU'VE ALREADY SPENT
IN INVESTIGATING THE POT
ABILITY OF EVP.
VENDORS HAVE TO MAKE A PROFIT I
GET THAT.
BUT DO YOU GET IT THAT VENDORS
HAVE TO MAKE A PROFIT.
AND IS IS THIS REALLY SOMETHING.
THAT IS NEEDED.
IF THERE IS ANY FRAUDULENT
THINGS HAPPENING IT CAN'T
POSSIBLY.
BE BUT SUCH A MINOR FRACTION.
AS I'M.
PEOPLE WHO TO THIS WE DON'T DO
IT.
BECAUSE IT'S A CAREER GOAL.
.
WE HAVE A MISSIONARY'S HEART WE
STILL HAVE TO LIVE.
AND SO THERE'S A BALANCE OF
NEED.
I CAN'T DO THE THINGS THAT I
WENT TO COLLEGE FOR.
I I CHOSE TO BE WITH MY SON BUT
I STILL NEEDED A WAY TO KEEP A
ROOF OVER OUR HEADS.
SO.
.
I WOULD SPEND THE MONEY.
ON.
US FOOD STAMP PROGRAMS IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR A THAT A YOU KNOW
BURNING A HOLE IN YOUR POCKET
AND PUT THAT MONEY SOMEWHERE.
PUT IT INTO FOOD STAMPS PUT IT
INTO OMBUDSMAN WHO.
IF YOU HAVE MORE OMBUDSMAN.
THEY CAN START DOING THEIR REAL
JOBS INSTEAD OF CHASING
PROBLEMS.
.
I SEE THAT IS A REAL HELP THAT
IF YOU FEEL LIKE YOU NEED TO
CHECK ON THE CLIENTS MORE OFTEN
THAN. THEY'RE ABLE TO GET THEN
MAYBE THOSE STAFF NEED TO BE.
GIVEN MORE SUPPORT SO THAT THEY
CAN DO THAT KIND OF CHECKING
INSTEAD OF.
IMPLEMENTING.
DEVICES ON EACH AND EVERYONE OF
THE.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS AND UP CONSUMERS THAT
ARE OUT THERE FOR.
LIKE I WOULD AGAIN I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE REAL PROBLEM
IS HERE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU OUT OF.
YEAH YOU KNOW MY NAME SHERRY
BILLIONS I TAKE CARE MY MOM FULL
TIME AND.
HER CONCERN WOULD BE INVASION OF
PRIVACY THAT I LIVE IN A COMPLEX
WHERE THE SENIORS ARE WE LOCKED
HIMSELF UP BEHIND THEIR DOORS
AND YOU DO NOT SEE THEM FOR A
WHOLE WEEK AT TIMES.
AND BECAUSE OF THE MANAGEMENT
THAT RENTS THE FACILITY.
THIS WILL END YOU KNOW IMPLEMENT
EVEN MORE PROBLEMS FOR THEM.
THEY WOULD SHUT US OUT OF THEIR
DOORS.
AND MY CONCERN WOULD BE. YOU
KNOW ELECTRONIC DEVICE MY HAS
WERE STOPPED BY ONE OF THOSE
ELECTRONIC DEVICES WHEN THEY'RE
PUT ON HIM. AND YOU KNOW EVP
CHECKING IN AND OUT OF
EVERYTHING I JUST CAN'T SEE IT.
I MEAN LARRY HAVE SENIORS THAT
LOCK AT MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY IN
YOU SEE HIM ON SATURDAY WHEN THE
MANAGEMENT TEAM LEADS.
IT'S REALLY SAD AND IT'S WHAT IT
AMERICANS CAN.
I MEAN.
LOOK AT ALL OF THAT AS I MEAN
WOULD YOU LIKE SOMEONE CHECKING
YOUR HOUSE EVERY TIME TURN
AROUND. NO.
I HEARD SHE LEFT IN FREEDOM
WHERE'S OUR FREEDOM THAT OUR MEN
AND WOMEN FOUGHT FOR.
THANK YOU THANK HIM.
WHEN FELLAS MINAMATA SETTLING
THAT SANCHEZ SOBRE WITH ORAC WE
GOT ON THE HAIR. GAMESTOP
PRESENT THERE THE IN A STATE
COURT IN THE UNITED YA YES THOSE
YOU DON'T CUIDADO POR. LINK
YOU'LL SIGN YOURS A. S. WILLIAM
MOSTLY KOREA'S NAM BAD LARA. AYE
BE LIPSEY IDEA FEATHER SOON WENT
DOWN. AND DOES A SAM MANGLE
PROGRAM.
THE SILICON MESSIAH BORN
IMPERFECT ORDER NAY EBV AT EVEN
BAKER CARE BY SIDE OF MY
YOUNGEST AND PLAN AND THOUGH.
YOU HAVE A SONOS DEL LACKEY.
LOS I MENTAL JULIAN PROCESS THAT
THE STEP ASIDE BUT COULD GIVE US
IN A USE CLINICALLY THAT'LL KILL
LIZ THAT. GAVE.
LOSS OF UP FOR THEIR.
BARONE GRANDMA'S GAMBLE .
ENTIRELY THAT HAVING A PRODUCT
AND ASSEMBLY AND PRODUCT OF THE
LIST FROM HIS OWN SK. THE
NAMELESS ESTAMOS WITH ADULTS
ELIZAGA THE STADIUM WAS MUCHO YO
PIENSO KIND OF ALMOST ASSEMBLY.
MIRANDO WORKING ON THE STATEN
THE IN THE MAXIMO ASSET THAT
ITEM AS WELL SAYS.
BUT RACKABLE SO YOU THINK
GASEOUS.
CRISIS IS THAT.
SURE THAT HER NAME WAS I MEAN
THE SANCHEZ TAKES HARPER
DAUGHTER WHO'S FORTY ONE. HER
DAUGHTER WHO IS PRESENT SHE SAID
HER DAUGHTER BECAUSE.
EPILEPSY SHE ALSO HAS.
MENTAL RETARDATION AND SHE SAID
THAT AND SHE KNOWS THAT SHE'S
GOING
TO BE SEEING ALL OF YOU AGAIN
AND THAT SHE'S GOING TO BE
MAKING SURE THAT THERE ARE MORE
VOICES OUT HERE DONE.
TO BE IN SUPPORT AGAINST THE BB.
AND SHE COMES FROM NAPA COUNTY.
THANK YOU.
HOLA MI NUMBERS MONEY ISN'T THE
YEN YET THAT MAY MAKE BUT THAT
THAT MEANS THEY ONLY HOPE THEY
MAKE THE ARE TRYING YES.
THE SUPERMODEL COLLISIONS
PARAMUS.
THE MEDICAL WORKS HUMANNESS THE
IN A PALACE SAILOR THAT.
LIPID NICKEL BUT THAT MEANT THAT
I MEAN.
GO THE WHOLE LESSEN YOUR LIBERTY
MADE UP OF THE OLD. LADY THAT I
THAT BUT A PRISON DIFFICULT MOST
OF THIS TO ME BECAUSE HE WANTED
A YEAH.
THEY'RE GONNA COME GET BANANAS.
THEY LOCUSTS THAT HAD BEEN THE
IN THING THAT WE CALL ME THAT
THEM OVER AND LAWSUIT WAVERLY
LIVE THEY CALL ME THAT GOAL
MICAELA Y. WALKS OF LIFE AS HE
NINETY SIX GALA.
IT WOULD BE FEASIBLE CAN LOOK
DON'T TAKE WITH THAT OF THE YEAR
IN NO TREE.
BUT I GIVE ANY THAT KEY. I
BELIEVE GOOD KNOWING THAT A MAN
THEN EIGHTY A VVV THICK AND
IMPLEMENT THAT.
S. PROGRESS ON THE CA CSE AS
THEY MUST HAVE A PASADO.
IS THAT A CALL NAY YES BUT
ESTABLISHED DONE THOUGH IT
CUIDADO. NECESITA ANY MEDICINE.
ONLY SIMPLE AROMA BUT ELEMENT
THE ELEMENTS HAVE MANA YUBA
LIVING BOREDOM.
BUT BECAUSE THE MY SILLY IF YOU
SEE LESS IT IS OKAY IS GIVEN
IMPLEMENT THAT.
HI SHE SAID HER NAME IN BUT IF
AT THE END.
SHE ALSO TAKES CARE OF HER OF
SON WHO'S TWENTY EIGHT. HE WAS
BORN PREMATURELY WITH A LOT OF
PROBLEMS INCLUDING.
HERE IT'S COMPULSIONS.
AND TI ARE HAS RUBEL POLICY AND
HE COME QUICKLY DEPENDS ON HER.
AND LIKE SHE SAID.
SHE TAKES HER HIM.
NIGHT AND DAY AND IT'S
COMPLETELY DIFFICULT BECAUSE SHE
HAS TO MOVE HIM. TO E. SHIELDS
TO MOVE HIM TO DO ANYTHING.
AND WHAT SHE WAS SAYING IS THAT.
THIS PROGRAM ON THE V. V. MAKES
NO SENSE BECAUSE IT IS THE WORK
IS ALREADY EXTREMELY HEAVY. AND
IT WOULD ONLY MAKE IT SO MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT AND SHE KNOWS
THAT SHE WOULD BE LOSING THE
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT WOULD BE WAY
TOO DIFFICULT FOR HER TO USE
THAT IT JUST MAKES NO SENSE.
DEMI EN ALMA.
NO SIMPLE GONNA GETTING
IMPLEMENT THAT SIT PROGRAM UNDER
THE NAME IN CHICAGO.
I MENDOZA MICHAEL LEVINE I'M
BECAUSE ANALYTIC UNKNOWN ALL.
YET MADE US TO LET YOU MAY NECK
AT THE END YOU KNOW YOU BUT OF
AS HE CITY SEE THAT'S WHY I WAS
GONE THE LOOK ON THE. PHONE WITH
THE ENEMY IN CHECK EITHER. BUT I
ME SEMI US SAY I LEVEL.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE CAN GET AN
AGREEMENT THAT IS THE PROGRAMA.
OR LA TO THEY CANNOT THE NOW IN
ANOTHER IS QUAN THEN WAS THAT
THE SEVENTH ALL OKAY WILL NOT
THE IN A LOOK AT US A ONE LOCAL
MOSQUE AT THE US.
YOU HAVE WHAT THEY END UP WHAT
CAN WE NEED TO GET AMEND THAN.
GOLD PLATE THE LESSOR JUST ABOUT
MADE THEM SEEM CHORUS IN VIA
QUAN THE INSTALL OF BIG GOT THE
REST OF THE ECONOMY COOL PEOPLE
MUST HAVE BEEN THE OTHER
ANOMALOUS ON THAT. IS THIS THINK
IT'S COOL STILL BLOODY IMPLEMENT
THAT IS THEY BROUGHT I'M. BUT A
MEDIOCRE DEL.
HOW DOES IT PROGRAM I DID THEY
S. THINKING CAN IMPLEMENT THAT
AND I THINK OF HIM AS BEING?
GIVEN GAME OF MONOPOLY NET. BUT
A BULLET US IT CAN ALSO BE
ALMOST WHAT DOES THE INSIDE AND.
GAVE SYSTEM ACCORDING CASA.
KELOWNA BECAUSE OF THE
COALESCENCE THE QUAKE I DON'T
EVEN BOTHER ON MODELS THAT IS A
YAKKING LOOK AT BUT I'M NOT
BUCKLE MANIPULATES THE IN. IN A
LIVE ANOTHER LIKE OF THE OTHER
THE THAT KILLED NOTICED THIS
THAT I SUSPECT SALINAS GOOD US
YES.
AND SHE SAID SHE DID NOT
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS PROGRAM IS
BEING IMPLEMENTED IF IT'S
ALREADY BEING CONSULATE CHECKED
ON SHE SAID WHAT SOCIAL WORKERS
COME OVER THEY EVEN CHECKER
CHAIRMAN TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
HEADED ASHES ON THERE. SO SHE
DID NOT UNDERSTAND WHY THIS
PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE COMING
IN.
SHE SAID THIS WOULD ONLY MAKE
IT WAY MORE DIFFICULT. AND DOES
IT IS SHE SAID SHE TAKES OVER
SOME TWENTY FOUR SEVEN AND ON
THE DO NOT GIVE FOR THOSE HOURS
THAT SHE NEEDS EVEN THOUGH SHE
HAS BEEN FIGHTING FOR THEM.
THEN.
AND BUT BUT SHE WAS SAYING IS
THAT SHE IS.
AGAINST THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE
WHICH DOES NOT KNOW WHAT'S
COMING NEXT
IF ON THEY GOT TO THE POINT THAT
THEY WANT PEOPLE OUT OF THIS
PROGRAM WHEN THEY'RE MAKING IT
THIS DIFFICULT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR. I'M NOT I'M
DOT NAY DONE STONE.
I AM ON PROVIDER FOR MY TO
DISABLED KIDS AND. I AM PROUD TO
BE A UNION MEMBER AT SCO YOU
TEND TO BE FIFTEEN.
I CAME HERE TWO YEARS TO OPPOSE
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF.
ELECTRONIC VISITATION.
OF THEIR EDUCATION BECAUSE.
MY JOB I HAD TWO BOYS WHO ARE
THESE ARM.
WHO HAS AUTISM?
INTELLECTUAL DALY DELAY
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY.
AND MY JOB READ THE STILL VOICE
IS SO DIFFICULT IT'S TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN.
IN THEM THEY WAKE UP AT THREE
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING. BOTH OF
THEM AND I'M JUGGLING BITTMAN I
JUST DON'T HAVE TIME TO CHECK IN
AND CHECK OUT I RATHER ATTEND TO
THEIR NEEDS.
FOR THEM TO BE SAFE.
BECAUSE THAT'S MY JOB BEING
THEIR PROVIDER. AYE LIVID THEM.
I I EVEN DO A LOT MORE.
THANKS TO STOP FOR THEM YOU KNOW
EVEN ON THE WEEKENDS WHICH.
I ITS SS DAS NOT PAY ME.
BUT BECAUSE I'M A PARENT I DON'T
HAVE ANY CHOICE.
SO I ASKED YOU.
CHAIRMAN.
THE PLEASE.
DON'T IMPLEMENT THESE E. VV. IT
WILL NOT HELP US IT WILL GIVE US
MORE PROBLEMS.
I'D RATHER DO MY JOB.
TAKING CARE OF MY TWO BOYS.
DONE CHECKING AND CHECKING OUT.
AND BOTH OF THEM ARE NOT FOR YOU
BUT TO TRAIN SO YOU CAN JUST
IMAGINE HOW I TURN MY BOT
BETWEEN MY TWO BOYS.
THANK YOU.
HI LISA SCOTT EL DORADO COUNTY I
MEAN DOING THIS FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS. AND I'M NO OFFENSE TO YOU
MAN BUT YOU KNOW US WOMEN DO TEN
THINGS AT ONE TIME HOW ARE WE
SUPPOSE TO. PUNCHING AND PUNCH
OUT PENSION PENSION OUT ARM WERE
TAKEN AWAY THE CARE THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE GIVING. TO OUR
CLIENTS
SO I AM OPPOSING THAT E. V. V.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAMMY SAHOTA
AND I'M FROM SUTTER COUNTY.
AS A VERY HEARD FROM MANY
PROVIDERS TO RECIPIENTS TO
JOURNEY HAS BEEN LONG.
EMOTIONALLY AND PHYSICALLY
EXHAUSTING AND FINANCIALLY
TAXING.
WE ARE CONSTANTLY THREATENED
HARASSED.
COSTS INVASION OF PRIVACY AND
MONEY BY. ANY NOW EXPLOITATION
OF POWER AND MONEY BY THE VERY
ELECT OFFICIALS.
AND CORPORATIONS INCLUDED WHO
SHOULD BE PRESERVING THE HONOR
AND DIGNITY OF THE VERY
COMMITTEE THE PROVIDES THE CARE
FOR THE AGING.
AND THE DISABLED.
I PAUSE EBV AS WELL HARM MY SOUL
RIGHTS AND THOSE OF MY PARENTS.
MY SISTER AND I UP AT FOUR
THIRTY EVERY MORNING.
YOU CARE FOR PARENTS WE GIVE
THEM THE SHOWERS FEED THEM
DEPRIVE THEIR ACTS THE OTHER
ADDITIONAL NECESSITIES THAT THEY
NEED.
AND WE HAVE THE RUSSIAN GET
OURSELVES INTO THE SHOWER GET
READY FOR WORK CAN BE GONE ALL
DAY AND RUSHED BACK HOME JUST TO
PROVIDE THE SAME CARE WE'RE NOT.
WE DON'T GO TO BED UNTIL TWELVE
O'CLOCK AT NIGHT.
SEEK IMAGINE FOR OUR FOUR AND A
HALF HOURS OF SLEEP.
IT'S GOING TO BE DETRIMENTAL TO
HAVE TO TAKE TIME TO TEAR UP
EVERYTHING I DO FOR MY PARENTS
BECAUSE THE NEED WILL BE.
THE WILTON THE NEED WILL NOT BE
REALISTIC WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF
EVP SO YOU WOULD THINK THAT I
PROBABLY COULD PROVIDE.
I HIGHER EXIT ANYONE EXTRA
PROVIDE GET ANOTHER PROVIDER TO
HELP PROVIDE CARE FOR THE CARE
MY PARENTS.
REALISTICALLY THERE'S NOT GOING
TO BE SOME WHO CARE. FOR MY
PRESS THE WAY I TO.
THEY'RE MY LOVED ONES.
I'VE MADE SACRIFICES IN MY LIFE
TO BE.
THERE HOMECARE PROVIDER IS NOT
JUST A JOB.
NOR IS IT JUST IT'S THOUGHT OF
THE TITLE IS THE BY THE QUALITY
OF LIFE MY PARENTS.
AND KEEPING THEM
INSTITUTIONALIZE WILL HARM THE
QUALITY OF LIFE.
THIS MAN RIGHT WILL INFLICT IS
DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR MACAWS MORE
ISSUES.
TAKE AWAY FROM MY ABILITY TO
PROVIDE EXCEPTIONAL CLEAR.
AND US AS WELL AS COLLEEN'S HAVE
TO CARE.
WE NEED POLICIES THAT HELP
PROTECT HIM AND EIGHTY NOT
PUNISH THEM THIS IS HARASSMENT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
FEDERAL PAUL THIS IS A FEDERAL
LAWSUIT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT IN SOMEWHERE FORM.
BUT IF WE CAN FIND A WAY TO
RETALIATE OR FIND SOMETHING TO.
STOPPING THE EVERY THE MOST
HUMANISTIC APPROACH THAT WE CAN
PROBABLY MAKE.
IN IF AVB DOES GO THROUGH I ASK
ALL OF YOU.
TO MAKE A HUMANISTIC.
BRING HIM OUT OF THE TO THIS.
PUT IT A HUMAN CONSCIOUS AND TO
THIS.
BECAUSE EVERY DAY WERE
STRUGGLING.
WE THE PEOPLE ELECTED YOU.
SO PLEASE PICK PROVIDE US
SAYING.
SAME LEVEL OF RESPECT.
AND SERVICE BACK TO US
THANK YOU.
HUMAN.
MY NAME IS DONNA PARKS UP FROM
STANISLAUS COUNTY NOW WOULD YOU
D. W. AND HIDE YOURSELF A
PROVIDER.
MY MOM'S IN BED TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY.
HE CANNOT. UP TO YOURSELF
HARDLY.
AND WITH THIS PROGRAM IS AS YOU
KNOW I CAN DO MY JOB.
AND.
WITH I HAVE MORE THAN ONE CARE
GIVER AND THEY COULD DO THEIR
JOB EITHER.
SO I'D APPRECIATE IF YOU GUYS
DON'T ADMIT THIS.
AND I I AGREE WITH MY BROTHERS
AND SISTERS AND THEN YOU'RE.
THANK YOU.
A I EVERYONE I MEAN GREEN.
PROUD MEMBER THE GW.
NOT REALLY SURE THAT.
MY OPPOSITION EVEN.
MATTERS THAT MUCH AT THIS POINT
TV VIEWING.
SO BASICALLY WHAT I'M MORE
CONCERNED WITH AT THE MOMENT IS
THAT.
EVERYONE THAT SUSPECTED BY EVEY
INDEED OUT SOME KIND OF PLACE
ARE ON THE TABLE. WHILE THREE
IMPLEMENTED.
BECAUSE ON ETW OBVIOUSLY ALISON
ASCII YOU SHOULD HAVE SOME KIND
OF A. ROLE IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
THANK YOU
THE CONCERT.
HELLO MY NAME IS DENISE ROW
OFTEN BUTTE COUNTY AND I HAVE
THREE CLIENTS I TAKE VERY GOOD
CARE OF MY CLIENTS AND I DON'T
HAVE TIME TO BE CHECKING IN ON
EVERYTHING THAT I DO.
AND THAT WOULD AFFECT THE
QUALITY OF CARE.
AND THAT WOULD BE IT DOWN RALLY
DIRTY SHAME IF THEY HAVE TO
LOOSEN HOURS BECAUSE BECAUSE I
HAVE TO CHECKING.
HUMAN.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS KEESHA
HEANEY I AM ALSO A CAREGIVER BUT
I'M ALSO AN ADVOCATE FORTHE AYE
JUSTICE PROGRAM. AND ALSO I AM
WITH UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS SO
I ADVOCATE ALSO FOR OUR MEMBERS.
AND I OPPOSE A. B. EBV FOR A LOT
OF DIFFERENT REASONS AT ALLTHE
REASONS THAT. MY SISTERS AND
BROTHERS HERE EXPRESSED HERE
TODAY. AND I KNOW THAT IT'LL
PROBABLY BE INPUT IMPLEMENTED
BUT ALSO AND I KNOW THAT
EVERYONE HAS A BUDGET.
AND BUT I'M ASKING YOU THE STATE
AND THE COUNTY. I HEARD IT SAID
LIKE THIS THAT IF YOU STAND FOR
ANY IF YOU STAND FOR SOMETHING
THE YOU WON'T FALL FOR ANYTHING.
AND I'M CHALLENGING YOU TO STAND
FOR SOMETHING.
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS ABOUT
MONEY. AND SO WE GET CAUGHT UP
IN THE MONEY FIGURES BUT WE
FORGET ABOUT THE HUMAN BEINGS
THAT ARE INVOLVED.
AND WE ALL ARE HUMAN BEINGS.
AND SOMEONE SAID BEFORE JUST
WHEN IT'S IMPLEMENTED.
MAKE SURE THAT YOU GO ABOUT IT
WITH THE HUMANISTIC APPROACH.
SO THAT EVERYONE INVOLVED.
CAN STILL REMAIN WITH DIGNITY
AND RESPECT.
SO I'M CHALLENGING YOU TO STAND
FOR SOMETHING.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR KURT CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE HAD NO POSITION NINE E.
V. V..
THUS FAR AND.
ACKNOWLEDGING BOTH THE.
THAT FEDERAL LAW ON THE FEDERAL
PENALTIES THAT WE'VE ALL GOT TO
CONFRONT AYE I THINK IN LOOKING
AT THIS BUT THAT BEING SAID AS
WE'VE TALKED WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES.
AROUND THE COUNTRY I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING.
FROM MANY TODAY.
IS JUSTIFIED AS THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS GONE IN THOSE.
STATE SO I THINK THERE IS.
SOME REAL CAUSE FOR CONCERN.
HOW THOSE STATES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED BUT IMPORTANTLY IT'S
AN OPPORTUNITY I THINK FOR
LESSONS LEARNED ON THE DIRECTION
THAT?
THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE GOING.
I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
DEPARTMENT FOR.
THEIR EFFORTS AND I THINK
THEY'RE THOUGHTFUL APPROACH.
THAT THEY'VE UTILIZED THUS FAR
BOTH IN REACHING OUT I THINK TO.
PROVIDERS AND CONSUMERS AS
THEY'RE MOVING FOR BUT ALSO
CANDIDLY I THINK COMING FORWARD
WITH I I THINK SOME OF THE
SOLUTIONS THAT THEY'VE SUGGESTED
ARE OFF THE TABLE THAT WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO
REPLICATE.
FROM THOSE OTHER STATES SO WE
STAND READY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THAT. WITH THE.
DEPARTMENT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AS WE GO FORWARD ON.
ON AND IMPLEMENTATION UNLESS
THERE IS ANOTHER ALTERNATIVE
THAT HAPPENS IN THE AND THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH VERY AGAIN I
WANTED TO.
OUT OF COURSE OPPOSE EVEY V.
FOR ALL THOSE.
YOU KNOW DE HUMANIZING REASONS
THAT WE CONTINUE TO SEE.
BE UP BEYOND BE A PRACTICE OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT WHAT I WOULD ASK.
BEAT BECAUSE OF BUDGETARY THING
ON A STATUS OF FEDERAL THINGY.
IF WE CAN HAVE SOME KIND OF CUT
COST IMPACT ANALYSIS OF
NONCOMPLIANCE I KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE THEIR FEET THEIR THEIR FINE
SCHEDULE AND THAT AND THAT SORT.
BUT EVEN NAM.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT NOT JUST THE
COST OF IMPLEMENTING THE
PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW OFF SAID IN THOSE
THINGS.
BUT ALSO POTENTIALLY.
WHAT WHAT MAY HAPPEN FOR THOSE
THAT WILL PROBABLY END ALLEY BE
INSTITUTIONALIZED BECAUSE OF
THIS?
PROGRAM
SO.
MAYBE UNDERSTAND IN THE THE THE
FULL.
IMPACT OF THE COST MIGHT.
GIVE US A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF WHETHER OR NOT SITE
IMPLEMENTATION SHOULD BE MOVED
LOOKED AT ALL AND OF COURSE
OBVIOUSLY IF IT IS SOMETHING
THAT DOES HAVE TO HAPPEN.
I WOULD I WOULD HOPE THAT WE
HAVE.
WE HAVE CONSUMERS AT THE TABLE
TO.
MAKE SURE THAT PROCESS IS
GUIDED THANK YOU.
MY LEFT OUT OF THIS NUMBER AS MY
IDEA RODRIGUEZ. WITH ARMY HARLEM
SORT ES CHARITY. WHEN NOT. PART
OF THE FEW LEFT OR PERFORM ALL.
ON ARNOLD'S RECORD THIS GIDDY
THINK I WANNA FISH.
CAN LOOK AT THEM LAST FLORIDA.
BUT GET ME HOPE YOU NOT A BUSTLE
MEN FOUND IT IMPEDIMENT I LOOK
I'M GOING TO. MISS A FEET BY
YUBA LESBIAN PICK WHAT BROUGHT
US IN VIA.
AND DOES HIS YOUNG FEMALE
SOPHOMORE RECORD FIFTH GADEA.
BONTA PREVIOUS.
WHAT WHAT WHAT?
LAWN UNRECORDED FISH.
BUT I.
HER NAME IS MOTHER YEAH BECAUSE
SHE TAKES CARE FIRST ON ON ON
SORT OF THE BIGGEST CHAVEZ.
WHO HAS ON?
A REPORT OF A STUDY ALLOWS
HOLIEST CHAVEZ. AS SHE TAKES HER
HIM TWENTY SEVEN HOURS A DAY.
SHE'S HERE FROM NAPA COUNTY AND
SAYS.
THAT SHE DOES NOT WANT ANY.
BUDGET CUTS FOR THE HOURS.
AND SHE'S.
ASKING AGAIN THAT THERE'S NO.
CUTS
BECAUSE.
THIS IS THE WAY THAT SHE IS
ABLE TO LIVE FOR HER AND HER
PERSON.
CRISIS IN YOUR HOME.
HELLO GOOD EVENING EVERYONE.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
WHEN IT THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THIS AND ALSO ASSEMBLY PERSON
FOR BEING HERE.
.
ETV SOUNDS LIKE A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT. BUT I'M HERE TO TRY
TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE THAT YOU
SPOKE TO BEFORE.
WITH THE ISSUE TO.
TWELVE BUT IT WAS NOT ALLOWED TO
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND THAT IS
THE HOME SAFE.
PROPOSAL WE'RE SO GOING TO
BRING THAT ONE UP IN A LITTLE
BIT IF YOU WANT TO COMMENT NOW
THOUGH FEEL FREE IF.
ONE FIVE I DO APPRECIATE THAT I
DO HAVE A PLANE TO CATCH A. WELL
ACTUALLY A LONG DRIVE ACTUALLY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL MY NAME
IS ROB WHY. I'M A CO WELL MAYBE
COLD WAR NAVY VETERAN.
BUT TODAY I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF A. R. P. AND IT'S
THREE POINT ONE MILLION.
MEMBERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE HOME
SAFE PROPOSAL.
THIS JUST A GOOD PROGRAM TO GET
STARTED.
.
BECAUSE IT WILL PROTECT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN ABUSED THE
ELDERLY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ABUSE
THAT BECOMING HOMELESS.
AS A RESULT OF SOME FORM OF
FINANCIAL ABUSE PHYSICAL ABUSE
IN SOME PARTS BY THEIR OWN
FAMILY MEMBERS.
AARP WOULD LIKE TO.
DEFINITELY FULLY SUPPORT.
THIS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE IT IS PROACTIVE.
THE STATE OF REACTIVE.
AND WE DON'T WILL HAVE THE CIVIL
TSUNAMICOMING WE DON'T WANT TO
SILVER HOMELESS TSUNAMI COMING.
AND IF WE GET ON TOP OF THIS NOW
BY INITIATING THIS PROGRAM.
AND ITS MEAGER FUNDING TO GET
IT STARTED I THINK WE WILL HEAD
OFF OF VERY VERY SLIPPY SLOPE
THAT WILL TAKE CALIFORNIA. DOWN
IN A VERY BAD PATH I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO GO
OUT OF ORDER I SURE DO
APPRECIATE IT. THANK EVERYONE
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN JOHNSON.
AND I'M SACRAMENTO.
AND I FEEL YOU SHOULD TAKE OFF
YOUR SHOES AND PLACE THEM ON OUR
FEET.
SO YOU FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
COMPLICATIONS THIS WILL BRING
ABOUT.
IT WAS NOT BROKEN. WHY BRING
ABOUT CHANGE?
OUR FOLKS WOULD CHANGE IT TO BE.
OUR FOLKS WOULD CHANGE IT'LL BE
YOU NOT THEM.
THANK YOU.
HOW CAN I AM CHRISTIE'S FATHER
ROBERT SAID AND I AM A MEMBER OF
THE I. H. AS AS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND STAMMER MEDINA
COUNTY?
I'M ALSO IF EDUCATE ADVOCATE
EMPOWER FAMILY CALIFORNIA.
AYE I WANTED TO AND JUST STATE
FOR THE RECORD THAT.
DURING THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
CARES ACT WHERE THIS COMES FROM.
I'M EDUCATE ADVOCATE DEAD.
I URGE.
CONGRESS IN THE U. S. SENATE TO
OPPOSE THE BELL.
WE DIDN'T JUST LIKE THE I AGES
AS ISSUES THERE'S OTHER ISSUES
IN THAT PARTICULAR BELL.
BUT AND WE ALSO BROUGHT TO LIGHT
THAT I JUST AS EBV CONNECTION
DURING THE TIME. THAT WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW BY PRESIDENT OBAMA IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
I WANTED TO ALSO MENTION THE
FACT THAT I HAVE CONCERNS THAT.
IF THE STATE IMPLEMENTS
I EVD.
THAT THIS COULD BRING FOR THE
POSSIBILITY OF LITIGATION
AGAINST A STATE TO BE INCLUDED
IN LITIGATION.
I'M OVER EIGHTY EIGHT COMPLAINTS
AMONG OTHER. AMONG AMONG OTHER
PROTECTIONS FOR THE DISABLED.
AND THE ELDERLY.
AND ALSO I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE FACT THAT. I THE DEPARTMENT
IS GOING TO BE UTILIZING AN
INDEPENDENT VENDOR.
AS OPPOSED TO THE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING THE THAT
THE EBT PROGRAM I HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT AND I AM. ASKING THE
QUESTION AS TO WHY THAT IS WHY
IS THE DEPARTMENT. GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM AS
OPPOSED TO AN INDEPENDENT. AYE
VENDOR THAT MAY HAVE.
THEIR OWN.
AGENDA AT HAND.
INCLUDING A PROFIT MARGIN.
THANK YOU.
HUMAN.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT I'LL
BRING IT BACK UP HERE AND BEING
THE ONLY ONE HERE.
I WANT TO SAY THAT THE SUB
COMMITTEE APPRECIATES THE
COOPERATION THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES HAS HAD WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS ISSUE.
AND THE STATED PRINCIPLES AROUND
IMPLEMENTATION THAT THE DSS HAS
BEEN CONSISTENTLY PROTECTING.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
ELECTRONIC TIME SHEETS CAN BE
LEVERAGED AS WE THINK.
ABOUT COMPLIANCE WITH THE V. V.
WE ENCOURAGE AS WELL.
AND AN ATTENTION TO THE POSSIBLE
SUB POPULATIONS OF THE CASELOAD
THAT MAY HAVE A PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT TIME COMPLYING WITH
EBV FOR A HOST OF LEGITIMATE
REASONS.
WE KNOW THAT THIS DISCUSSION IS
CONTINUING INTO THEM A REVISION
AND HOLD THIS OPEN AT THIS TIME
THANK.
WITH THAT WE WILL RETURN TO
ISSUE THREE
.
GIVEN THE LATE HOUR.
VERY QUICK SUMMARY AND IT WAS
REALLY QUICK I WE SAW. A VERY
QUICK ATHERTON EYES AND THAT
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS AND CIVIL
RIGHTS PRESHEAF AT CSI'S I'M SO
JUST A QUICK UPDATE ON WHERE. WE
ARE AYE WITH THE HOUSING
DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM AND
SO WE PUT OUT THE REQUEST FOR
PROPOSALS IN THE END OF JULY.
WITH.
END OF OCTOBER COUPLE MONTHS A
COUPLE WEEKS I EXTENSION FOR
SOME OF THE FIRE IMPACTED
COUNTIES. BY GOT ALL OF THEM IN
BY MADE ME AND NOVEMBER AND I'D
SORT OF A DONE IN TWO ROUNDS OF
THE BASE ALLOCATION. AYE WHICH
WE FINALIZE OF THE FORTY ONE OF
THE FORTY THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
HAS GONE OUT TO THIRTY NINE
COUNTIES ALSO WERE EXCITED ABOUT
THAT THE LEVEL OF INTEREST WE
GOT FROM A PRETTY BROAD SWATH
AND. SO THAT WOULD NOT JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO WERE IN THE
MIDST OF GETTING THE LAST TWO
POINT EIGHT. MILLION OUT A
COMPETITIVE ALLOCATION ROUND
SPLIT SORT OF AMONGST.
OF THE HANDFUL OF MOST
COMPETITIVE COUNTIES.
AND HOPING TO HAVE THAT IDEALLY
BY THE END OF OF MARCH EARLY
APRIL AND WE'VE ALREADY BROUGHT
THE COUNTIES SEEING NONE. CAN
THE DEPARTMENT
PLEASE RESPOND TO THE CONCERN
RAISED BY LEGAL SERVICE
ADVOCATES ON THE USE OF THE
FUNDING SO FAR.
YEAH SO JUST A QUICK
CLARIFICATION ON THAT AND ANNA
AND MAYBE I MISUNDERSTOOD THAT
THE QUESTION IN TERMS OF HOW IT
WAS RETARDED SO TELL ME IF I DID
BUT.
FOR I A ARE IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
JUST BE GA THAT IS.
SORT OF AN ALLOWABLE BENEFIT
REIMBURSEMENT SO ANY RENTAL
SUBSIDY THAT WE'RE GIVING IS
ALLOWABLE FOR AYE A OUR.
ALLOCATION AMOUNTS AND SO IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE
AN INCREASE IN GI AT CAN BE.
ANYTHING FROM MOTELS TO RENTAL
SUBSIDIES SORT OF A WHOLE RANGE
OF BENEFITS BOTH CASH AND IN
KIND. THAT CAN BE I'M INCLUDED
AND I ARE SO NOT OF THAT HELPS
CLARIFY.
THE QUESTION A BIT BUT IF I CAN
PLEASE ASK THE DEPARTMENTS TO
MEET WITH THE LEGAL SERVICE
ADVOCATE TO ISCUSS THIS ISSUE
IN MORE DEPTH THAT WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED ABSOLUTELY.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
THREE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
SIX
.
AGAIN I BELIEVE MANY OF THESE
ISSUES WERE ADDRESSED IN THE
HANDOUT AND MAY OF BEEN SPOKEN
TO BEFORE SO.
IF WE CAN.
DO OUR BEST.
GOOD AFTERNOON NEW DELHI
THOMPSON.
.
WE KIND OF. HAD STARTED INTO AS
YOU MENTIONED INTO A COUPLE OF
THESE.
.
I'LL JUST GO BACK TO THE POWER
POINT.
SLIDE EIGHT BEGAN THAT FLSA
INFORMATION SO WITH IN THE AND
I'M GONNA JUST.
COME THROUGH THIS QUICKLY.
IN THAT POWER POINT IT DOES
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
STATUS OF VIOLATIONS AND
EXEMPTIONS
THE TRANSITION.
WITH THE EXCEPTIONS TO THE
COUNTIES.
GIVES A LITTLE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
PROCESSING OF OVERTIME IT STAYED
PRETTY STABLE. ON THE NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS BEING PAID. OVERTIME
OVERTIME AS WELL AS FOR TRAVEL
TIME.
.
THE NEXT SECTION GOES INTO.
OTHER IMPLEMENTATION OF
ELECTRONIC TIME SHEETS WHICH YOU
MENTIONED. EARLIER AND JUST TO
GO TO YOUR COMMENT AROUND EBV IT
IS ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING. THAT WE
ASK FOR IN THE ARE OF AYE AND
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT WAYS THAT
WE CAN LEVERAGE WHAT WE'VE DONE
IN ETFS THAT HAS BEEN.
.
WELL RECEIVED AND PEOPLE HAVE
FELT HAVE GONE WELL AS A WAY TO
LOOK AT LEVY FEES.
.
YOU'LL SEE THAT WERE ALMOST UP
TO. THIS IS ACTUALLY.
FROM THE END OF DECEMBER SO. AS
OF LAST WEEK WHERE UP TO CLOSE
TO TWENTY PERCENT OF PROVIDERS
USE THE UTILIZING EACH GAS NOW.
TO SUBMIT THEIR TIME SHEETS
WITHOUT GROWING EACH WEEK SO
WE'RE VERY PLEASED ABOUT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR UNION
PARTNERS ARE COUNTY PARTNERS. TO
OUTREACH TO FOLKS TO ENCOURAGE
THEM TO UTILIZE THAT IT DOES
PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT AS
FAR AS.
.
TWO HOT BEING ABLE TO GET
PAYMENTS OUT QUICKLY. ELIMINATES
THE MAIL TIME ON THE FRONT END
OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO CHOOSE TO
USE DIRECT DEPOSIT ELIMINATES
THE TIME ON THE BACK END. SO IT
REALLY CAN GET PAYMENTS TO
PEOPLE WITHIN TWO OR THREE DAYS
AND THAT HAS BEEN A VERY
POSITIVE POSITIVE OUTCOME AS
WELL AS THE SYSTEM PROVIDES
PROMISED INDIVIDUALS AROUND THE
VIOLATIONS WE WERE MENTIONING.
WITH.
.
WITH C. FLSA IMPLEMENTATION TO
ASSIST THEM IN BEING ABLE TO
COMPLETE TIME SHEETS CORRECTLY
AND NOT INCURRED IN VIOLATIONS.
I. SEE.
KIND OF MOVE THROUGH IT GIVES
YOU A AND NUMBER OF PIECES OF
DATA AROUND THE ELECTRONIC TIME
SHEETS.
THE NEXT SECTION HAWKS ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PAID SICK
TIME.
SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING
EXTENSIVELY WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AROUND THAT IMPLEMENTATION WHICH
IS SCHEDULED FOR JULY OF THIS
YEAR.
WE'VE HAD AN ACL COME OUT
TALKING ABOUT HOW TIME WILL BE
ACCRUED AND PROBABLY WHEN IT CAN
BE USED.
THAT NEXT PIECE THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT AND HAVE CONVENED A
WORK GROUP TO TALK ABOUT THE
BACKUP SYSTEM. FOR.
INDIVIDUALS WHEN THEIR
PROVIDERS ARE OUTSIDE.
SO THAT'S GOING TO BE.
ONGOING DISCUSSION.
AND.
THEN WE HIT EBV WHICH WE JUST
FINISHED UP SORRY MISSED ONE
PROVIDER ENROLLMENT.
THAT A SEPARATE.
TOP VIETNAM SEPARATE ISSUE.
BUT I COVER NOW THERE'S A
SEPARATE PROPOSAL HELP IF WE CAN
JUST HOW PEOPLE TO HEAR.
WITH THAT I THINK CRISTINA BUS
HAMILTON IS.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR
CRISTINA POSSIBLE TO WITH YOU W.
APPS ME.
.
WHO?
SEVERAL ISSUES THAT I'D LIKE TO
RAISE.
FIRST OFF IS IT AND WE ASK THAT
THIS BE AGENDA IS AN AND ARE
VERY.
THANKFUL THAT IT WAS A GEN DIS
THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE SEVEN
PERCENT CUT.
.
THEY WE NEED TO BE TALKING ABOUT
RESTORING THE CUT ONCE AND FOR
ALL AND AS WE ALL KNOW RIGHT NOW
IT'S RESTORATION AND IS
DEPENDENT ON.
THE MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATION
TAX BEING IN A FACT.
WHICH IT DOES EXPIRE NEXT YEAR
WE KNOW THAT WE NEED FEDERAL
APPROVAL FOR THAT AND SO TAX TO
CONTINUE.
THE LA OLA ITSELF ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT FEDERAL APPROVAL WAS
UNCERTAIN AT THIS POINT.
SO IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN THEN
THIS SEVEN PERCENT CUT
AUTOMATICALLY GOES BACK INTO
PLEASE AND.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT COAT CAME
ABOUT AS A RESULT OF THE
RECESSION. AND AS OTHER.
FOLKS HAVE TESTIFIED REGARDING
OTHERS SERVICES AND BENEFITS
ATTA AT A TIME WHERE THE
GOVERNOR IS SEEKING TO PUT. THE
MAXIMUM ALLOWABLE AMOUNT IN THE
RAINY DAY FUND.
IT IS NOT RIGHT TO BE DOING THAT
WHEN THERE ARE SERVICES THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN RESTORED GOING BACK
TO THE RECESSION.
AND THIS CUT NEEDS TO BE STRUCK
FROM CURRENT LAW IN OUR OPINION.
I.
WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THIS
NOW WHILE TIMES ARE GOOD AND NOT
NEXT YEAR WHEN WE ARE IN A
CRISIS MODE.
SO WE WE DO OF WORK RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ADOPT THAT.
AND THEN SECONDLY ON PAID SICK
LEAVE WHICH IS A VERY GOOD THING
IN WE FAR VERY LONG TO GET PAID
SICK LEAVE FOR I JUST AS
WORKERS.
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT THE A
COMPREHENSIVE BACK UP PROVIDER
SYSTEM.
IS NOT GOING TO BE PUT INTO
PLACE IN EVERY COUNTY AND THE
REASON I SAY THIS ISN'T
NECESSARILY THAT THERE'S NOT.
DESIRE FOR ONE TO GO INTO PLACE
BY THE DEPARTMENT BUT WHAT
APPEARS TO BE A LACK OF FUNDING.
AND IF YOU SPEAK TO PEOPLE FROM
THE COUNTIES AND MEAN THIS IS A
JOINED EYES TO DATE COUNTY ADMIN
COSTS AND CONCERNS ABOUT PUBLIC
AUTHORITY FUNDING.
THERE IS SIMPLY NO WAY TO EXPECT
THAT COUNTIES ARE GOING TO
CREATE PROVIDER BACK UP SYSTEMS
THAT DON'T CURRENTLY EXIST
WITHOUT MONEY.
DO IT AND YOU KNOW HAVING INTENT
AND GOOD INTENTION IS GOOD BUT.
WITHOUT THE DOLLARS ALLOCATED
THAT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN AND
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT IF A
PROVIDER CALLS OUT SICK ANY
CONSUMER DOESN'T HAVE ANOTHER
PROVIDER TO CALL. WHICH MAY
OFTEN HAPPEN. THEN THAT PROVIDER
PROBABLY WILL FEEL LIKE THEY
SHOULDN'T CALL OUT SICK AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK IS THAT
CONSUMER WON'T HAVE ANOTHER
PROVIDER WHERE THE CONSUMER WILL
ACTUALLY HAVE NO PROVIDER AND.
BE IN A VERY BAD SITUATION SO.
A REAL PROVIDER BACKUP SYSTEM IS
SOMETHING THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
ORIGINALLY WHEN S. B. THREE
FIRST PASSED.
TWO YEARS AGO AND. IT FELL OFF
ON THE PAGE
ALL OF LAST YEAR IN AND IT
APPEARS THAT THERE'S JUST.
RELUCTANCE TO FUND IT THIS BUT
AGAIN WE WE THIS IS IT.
THIS IS A BENEFIT BUT IT'S ONLY
A BENEFIT THAT WILL BE TAKEN IF
THERE'S SOMETHING EMPLOYEES FOR
WHEN THAT WORKERS NOT ABLE TO
WORK SO WE WE WE REQUEST FUNDING
FOR THIS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF WE WANT.
IF ANYONE WITH SCO YOU.
WERE IN FULL SUPPORT OF A FULLY
AND PERMANENTLY RESTORING THE
SEVEN PERCENT ARE AGES AS
PROVIDERS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
CONTINUOUSLY COME TO THE STATE
AND ASK FOR SOMETHING THAT'S
RIGHT BILLION DESERVEDLY
THERE'S.
AND SO WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WELL AND THANK YOU W.
FOR BRING IN THE REQUEST FORWARD
SECONDLY I AM I ALSO ECHO THE
COMMENTS ON FOR MY COLLEAGUE
FROM UT W. WITH REGARD TO THE
BACKUP SYSTEM FOR.
I AGES AS PROVIDERS WE WOULD
JUST URGE YOU GUYS.
TO. DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
WELL DEVELOPED AND FULLY FUNDED
PROVIDER BACKUP SYSTEM.
FOR PIZZA THANK YOU.
BILLION.
ON WE REVIEWED THE BUDGET.
ESTIMATES AROUND I JUST US
REYES NODES ADDITIONAL CONCERNED
ONE TECHNICAL BUDGET NOTE IS
BASED OFF OF JUST THE RECENT
GROWTH TRENDS IN THE NUMBER
PROVIDERS RECEIVING EXEMPTION TO
THAT THAT WOULD ALLOW CERTAIN
PROVIDERS WORK ABOUT THE. A
MAXIMUM WORK WEEK CAPS.
WE WOULD ESTIMATE THAT PERHAPS
FEWER PROVIDERS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR BUDGET YEAR AUTUMN WOULD BE
RECEIVING EXCEPTION TO THAN WHAT
IS ESTIMATED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
BERMAN FUNDS.
WITH RESPECT TO A CERTAIN
PERCENT RESTORATION WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THERE'S NO PROPOSAL TO
TAKE AWAY THE RESTORATION FOR
BUDGET YEAR WITH RESPECT TO THE
EXEMPTIONS OF REQUEST WE'RE
GOING TO BE TAKING A LOOK AT THE
ACTUAL NUMBERS COMING OUT
EXEMPTIONS. AT THE MAY REVISED
WHO JUST NOTE THAT LAST YEAR
THERE WAS A.
STATUTORY OF TO
SOMETHING PASSED NOT ALLOWED THE
EXCEPTIONS TO BE INCLUDED INSIST
INTO STATUTE AND ALSO REQUIRES
COUNTIES TO. TAKE A LOOK AT ALL
THE. DIRT DURING THE ANNUAL
ASSESSMENTS TO SEE WHETHER THOSE
PEOPLE ARE ELIGIBLE TO PROVIDE
AN EXEMPTION WHICH MAY NOT BE
RAISING THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT. MAY APPLY FOR EXEMPTION.
THANK YOU WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE SIX.
CHAIRMAN A ARAMBULA AND A
STALWART SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS.
.
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE.
LET'S GET REAL.
IN JUNE AND JULY.
PAUL RYAN IS GOING TO IMPLEMENT.
HIS CARDS ONTO THE TABLE FOR
CATASTROPHIC
CUPS.
TO OUR HEALTHCARE.
PROGRAMS.
IT'S YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THIRTY PERCENT
WE DON'T KNOW.
AND WE NEED TO SEVEN PERCENT.
CUT ELIMINATED THIS YEAR.
BECAUSE FRANKLY IF WE DON'T.
IT'LL BE A VEHICLE TO HELP IN
THE CRISIS THAT COMING AND WILL
HAPPEN IT'S NOT. IF IT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
LIKE A YEAR AGO WITH THE ATTACK
ON LIKELY WE STOPPED IT. ON THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE A PROGRAM
FROM A HUNDRED PERCENT FACING
THOSE CUTS NOT FROM NINETY THREE
PERCENT.
OF A PROGRAM.
AND IT'S HELD OVERS EVERY YEAR
IT'S KIND OF I MEAN WE HAVE TO
COME AND ASK FOR THAT.
.
IN TOES AND FINGERS THAT'S LIKE
A FINGER AND A HALF.
YOU KNOW AND.
AND THE STATE IS GOING TO HAVE
SERIOUS
SIRIUS.
BUDGET CRISIS.
IN JUNE AND JULY WHEN THE.
WHEN THE HOUSE DOES THIS
AGAINST.
OF THE PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT.
WE NEED IT IT WE NEED TO START
THE DISCUSSION WITH A HUNDRED
PERCENT OF OUR PROGRAM.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR NEXT YEAR.
AND EVEN IF SOMEHOW MIRACULOUSLY
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
IF THEY DECIDE THAT THIS IS A
LOSER FOR THE NOVEMBER ELECTION.
OF.
THE ECONOMY'S COMING YOU KNOW A.
GOOD THING SO LAST FOR EVER.
AND THEY'LL BE MORE CONCERNED
MAYBE WE CAN CUT SEVEN PERCENT.
REMEMBER IT WAS UP ARBITRARY
FIGURE THAT WAS PUT ON.
US THE EIGHT
SEVEN PERCENT BECAUSE IT WAS
DONE LIKE.
FIFTEEN YEARS BEFORE SOMETHING
THEN NUMBER.
HE WAS EVEN BASED ON THE
SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS OF.
WHERE WE HAD BEEN RECENTLY?
SO I I'M SPEAKING AS A HOME CARE
WORKER FROM SAN FRANCISCO. BUT
ALSO OUR UNION SUPPORTS
THAT THIS BE DONE THIS YEAR.
ALSO WE NEED THE BACK UP FOR A
THIS SMALL BENEFIT WE HAVE ONE
DAY EIGHT HOURS A YEAR. YOU KNOW
MOST PEOPLE WHEN THEY.
WHEN THEY THINK ABOUT TAKING
THAT THEY HAVE TO DO WITH TRIAGE
AND STRETCHED OUT OVER THE DAYS
I MEAN HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ONLY
SICK FOR ONE DAY A YEAR.
YOU KNOW TO TO DELAY.
THE ABSOLUTE NECESSARY CARE THAT
WE GIVE TO PEOPLE AND TRY TO
SPREAD IT OUT AND GET OUR
FRIENDS TO WORK FOR US BUT. YOU
KNOW IT DOESN'T ALWAYS HAPPEN
THERE THEY'RE BUSY TOO SO WE
NEED THE BACKUP SYSTEM AS WELL.
SO AS.
FAR AS THE UNION AS FAR AS THE
INDIVIDUAL I ASK YOU TO END.
THIS CUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE RELYING
ON THE GENERAL FUND AND. NOT THE
M. CEO OF TAX
OF. LISTS REMOVE THIS.
CUT AND THIS THREAT OVER OUR
HEADS THAT WE'VE LIVED WITH
SINCE THE SCHWARZENEGGER YEARS
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA DEB ROTH'S
DISBELIEVE DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA.
HERE TO SUPPORT THE PROPOSALS
THAT WERE JUST PRESENTED AND.
IN PARTICULAR ABOUT THE SEVEN
PERCENT CUT IT IS LONG OVERDUE
FOR IT TO BE RESTORED WITHOUT
BEING DEPENDENT ON.
SOME OTHER FINANCIAL OR POLICY
DECISION MADE BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND SECONDLY.
THE GENTLEMAN WHO JUST SPOKE.
UNDERSCORED.
THE THE SENSE OF CONCERN ABOUT.
PAID BACK UP AND.
HAVING IT AVAILABLE.
BACK UP WAS IN ISSUE YEARS AGO
WHEN I USED TO WORK ON AYE XSS
AND THAT WAS BEFORE THERE WAS
PAID SICK LEAVE OR ANYTHING ELSE
LIKE THAT.
IT'S ARE REAL PROBLEM NOW IT'S A
TOUGH NUT TO CRACK AND PEOPLE
HAVE TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT WE GET IT GOING
AND THAT IT WORKS.
THE GAME.
HI GOOD EVENING NOW.
MY NAME'S AMY DAY I'M A PROUD
MEMBER OF UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND NOW ALSO AN
ORGANIZER.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SPEAK TO
THE PERSONAL SIDE OF THE SEVEN
PERCENT HIGH AND WHEN IT WAS
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED IT WAS AN
EIGHT PERCENT SKY.
THAT YOU'RE LATER WHEN WE CAME
OUT OF THE RECESSION IT WAS
RESTORED ONE PERCENT.
WHICH WAS NOT FAIR.
OF COURSE AS I SAID I CARE
PROVIDERS BAND TOGETHER AND MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WAS COMPLETELY
RESTORED I THINK IT SHOULD BE A
NON ISSUE LIKE CRISTINA BASS
HAMILTON EXPLAINED IT SHOULD
JUST BE OUT OF LAW. WE SHOULDN'T
BE SCRAMBLING TO TO FIND A
PROGRAM THAT SHOULD BE
COMPLETELY FUNDED ALREADY AND.
FOLKS LIKE.
THAT OUR FAMILY HOME CARE
PROVIDERS AND YOU GUYS KNOW THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO THE WORK FOR
FREE AND JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE
DOING GOD'S WORK DOESN'T MEAN
THAT WE SHOULD MAKE IT HARDER ON
THEM TO DO SO. ARE REGISTRIES
ARE OR EIGHTY.
SUFFERING AND TWO OF THE
COUNTIES THAT WE REPRESENT UP IN
THE NORTHERN AREA OR OR EIGHTY
I'M DON'T HAVE ENOUGH HOME CARE
PROVIDERS ON THOSE REGISTRIES
AND OUR OR EIGHTY FOLKS WITH
DISABILITIES GOING WITHOUT CARE.
AND IF IF.
WE DON'T FIND THE FUNDING I'M
TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS ARE
GETTING WHAT THEY NEED IT'S
GOING TO BE EVEN WORSE AND TO
TRY TO HOLD ON TO HOME CARE
PROVIDERS. AND THERE OR DO YOU
NOT MAKING A LIVABLE WAGE THERE
OR EIGHTY SUFFERING SO MUCH TO
DO GODS WORK I'M ASKING YOU GUYS
TO REALLY SUPPORT HOME CARE
WORKERS IN. AND ALSO THE CLIENTS
THAT THEY TAKE CARE OF BY MAKING
SURE THAT THE SEVEN PERCENT IS
NOT AN ISSUE IN THE YEARS TO
COME THANK YOU. BECAME.
HI LISA SCOTT EL DORADO COUNTY
AND SOME THREE YEARS AGO WHEN
THAT SEVEN PERCENT CAT WAS.
.
IN. EFFECT ARM WHERE MY CLIENTS.
I CAN GO OVER THERE TO THEIR
HOUSE BECAUSE THEY DE HOURS WERE
CUT AND SHE HAD FALLEN IN HER
BATHTUB.
AND GOT KNOCKED OUT AND I DIDN'T
FIND A FOR TWO DAYS.
AND WAS A HUNDRED AND FIVE
DEGREES UP THERE EVERY DAY.
IT WILL UNFORTUNATELY WHEN I GOT
THERE.
I WAS YOU I FOUNDER OXYGEN
UPPER DONNA CALLED NINE ONE ONE
THEY CAME AND GOT HER THEY TOOK
HER TO THE EMERGENCY.
AND AND THAT AND THE HA DOCTOR
SAID IF I HAD BEEN THERE WITHIN
TWENTY MINUTES SHE WOULD BE HERE
TODAY WHILE UNFORTUNATELY PASSED
AWAY BY.
NOW BUT ARM ARE YOU JUST WORRIED
ABOUT THE OTHER CLIENTS THAT
THAT PICKED UP PROVIDERS DON'T
GO BY BECAUSE THEY THEY DON'T
HAVE HOURS SO WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
TO THE OTHER PEOPLE FORTUNATELY
I'D I LIVE REAL CLOSE TO EARN
CENTER JUST TOLD ME TO. STOP BY
AND I GET THE GUY DID SO.
A.
THINK ABOUT DOES.
RESTORE THE SERVER SHIP PLEASE
THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS ALLEY
WITH UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS OF
AMERICA.
A SO ON THE BEHALF OF YOU KNOW
HOME CARE WORKERS GOING TO BE
HERE TODAY.
ICED FULLY OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE SEVEN PERCENT
RESTORATION OF THE I JUST I
SERVICE HOURS.
YOU KNOW BEING IN THIS FIELD
THIS WORK FIELD AND MEETING A
LOT OF HOME CARE WORKERS I SEE
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS ALREADY AS
IT IS TO BE A HOME CARE WORKER.
AND ALL THE ROAD BUMPS THAT WE
WE KEEP COMING ACROSS YOU KNOW
LIKE THINGS LIKE THE SICK DAY
YOU KNOW THEY FOUGHT REALLY HARD
FOR A WE WERE. HOME CARE WORKERS
WERE EXEMPT FROM IT. AND WITH
THE SEVEN PERCENT CUT YOU KNOW
LIKE IF BIG IF IT'S NOT IF IT IS
REDUCE REESE.
IF IT IF IT BECOMES AN ISSUE
AGAIN IT'S GONNA AFFECT NOT JUST
THE HOME CARE WORKER BUT THE
RECIPIENT AS WELL SO I ASK YOU
YOU KNOW PUT YOURSELF IN THEIR
SHOES. LIKE IF IT WAS YOUR LOVE
ONE AND IT WAS YOUR HOURS BEING
AFFECTED OR THE QUALITY OF CARE
TO GIVE YOUR LOVE ONE.
YOU KNOW I WORKED IN THE IT AND.
AND. HOME CARE FACILITY BEFORE
AND YOU KNOW BEING ON THE FLOOR
AND BEING IN A FACILITY WITH
FIFTY YOU KNOW ELDERLY.
PATIENTS THERE. AND HAVING ONLY
FOUR PEOPLE ON THE FLOOR IS NOT
A GOOD.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO BE ABLE TO
GIVE THEM THE NEEDS THAT THEY
NEED AT THE TIME AT THAT MOMENT.
SO YOU KNOW BE IS BEING SEEN
BOTH SIDES OF THE TABLE LAKE.
THIS IS THIS HAS TO BE IMPORTANT
THIS HOUSE TO BE SOMETHING THAT
WE ALL SUPPORT AND THAT WE
REALLY. WHEN MAKING THESE
DECISIONS THEY HAVE TO.
IT IT'S NOT ABOUT THE MONEY IT'S
ABOUT THE WORK AND LIKE SHE SAID
LIKE OTHER PEOPLE HAVE SAID
BEFORE PEOPLE ARE GONNA DO IT
ANYWAY. BUT THEY DESERVE THE
DIGNITY DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
TO PUT FIRST SO YOU KNOW I JUST
ASK YOU GUYS TO PUT HOME CARE
WORKERS.
FIRST.
YOU KNOW WE ARE ALL RECIPIENTS
OF THIS PROGRAM AND WE WANT TO
KEEP IT AROUND BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DATE WHAT TOMORROW
BRINGS.
HE NOW IT MIGHT BE ME ON AYE
CHESS SETS
IT MIGHT BE ME ON SSI IN MIGHT
BE ME THAT'S AFFECTED.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
BINGAMAN.
HI AGAIN A IN FOR MEDIA W..
ON.
THINKING ABOUT THE AYE CUTS THE
SEVEN PERCENT CUT.
I IT'S FREE IT'S A MORAL I DON'T
REALLY SEE WERE PERPETUALLY LIKE
THE FIRST TICKET CON OR ONE OF
THE FIRST PROGRAMS TO GET CUT.
I SEEN AS A SIGN ONE.
WE'RE GONNA BE NEXT TO NEXT
TIME SOMETHING HAPPENS.
WE ARE ALREADY BELOW THE POVERTY
LINE.
GET A SLOW THEY CLOSER THE
POVERTY LINE GIVE A SEVEN
PERCENT BACK. OVER THE NEXT TIME
SOMEONE NEEDS TO BE CUT PLEASE.
THANK YOU SIR.
ADAM GREEN. UW.
I AM TO THEM BACK UP MY
CONSTITUENTS.
KNOW WHAT THEY SAID.
I'M A FORMER FIREFIGHTER. AND A
PARAMEDIC
I'VE SEEN PEOPLE AUTHOR WORSHIP.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE.
I TO HAVE GONE INTO HOSPITALS.
WITH PATIENTS ROB HAD A WORK
EMERGENCY ROOM.
TO GIVEN THE QUALITY OF LIFE
THEY HAVE.
THIS SEVEN PERCENT AND MY MIND.
SHOULD STICK AROUND IT'S HIGHLY
NEEDED.
THAT TAKES CARE OF OFFICE
OUR LOVED ONES AS WELL.
AS I STATED EARLIER.
I DO TAKE CARE WHEN ELDERLY
VETERAN WHO I LOVE DEARLY.
SHEILA ALMOST LATER LIFE DOWN
FOR US.
MY SELF TO FOR THIS COUNTRY
ALMOST AT.
I WOULD GLADLY DO IT ANY DAY.
FOR ANYBODY THIS IS NOT ABOUT
JUST ME THIS ABOUT THEM.
THEY'VE EARNED IT THEY DESERVE
IT LET'S KEEP BUT.
THANK YOU.
I SIVA TAMALE SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN HOME CARE WORKER.
THE SEVEN PERCENT I'VE REALIZED
RIGHT NOW HAS BEEN TAKEN AWAY
FROM US YET.
BUT I A OB JACK THAT WE HAVE TO
KEEP COMING BACK.
AND ASKING ERROR RE YEAR PLEASE
DO NOT BRING IT BACK PLEASE DO
NOT TAKE THOSE HOURS AWAY FROM
US.
I I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE AWARE
OF IT OR NOT BUT.
NOT ALL CLIENTS HAVE NOT ALL
RECIPIENTS HAVE A LOT HOURS.
SOME OF ONLY HAVE LIKE THIRTY
FIVE HOURS.
SOME ONLY FORTY HOURS.
THOSE ARE HOURS IT THEIR REVIEW
PROVIDER COMES IN AND JUST MAYBE
COOKS MEALS FORUM THAT THEY CAN
POP IN THE MICROWAVE. CLEAN
THEIR HOUSE GIVEN TO THE DOCTOR
GO GROCERY SHOPPING.
IMAGINE IF YOU TAKE SEVEN
PERCENT OF THAT AWAY.
WHAT IS THE PROVIDER GOOD YOU
WELL I CAN'T GO GROCERY
SHOPPING FOR YOU THIS WEEK
BECAUSE WE USED UP THE HOURS?
AT THE DOCTOR.
NO THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
AND.
THE SEVEN PERCENT NEEDS TO BE
PUT INTO THE BUDGET AND LEFT
THERE AND LEFT ALONE. IT WE
EARNED IT WE DESERVE IT.
YOU GIVE US A WOMB A MINIMUM
WAGE RAISE SO THAT WE ARE
FINALLY GETTING CLOSE TO HAVING
A QUALITY OF LIFE. AND YOU PULL
THE RUG OUT FROM UNDER US IN
ANOTHER AREA.
IT'S NOT RIGHT.
OF WE SAVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MONEY
EVERY DAY.
BECAUSE IF YOU HAD TO TAKE THOSE
FOLKS
AND PUT A MAN TO AN INSTITUTE
WINE YOU WOULDN'T HAVE THE
NURSING HOMES. ENOUGH NURSING
HOME.
IN LIKE COUNTY WE HAVE THREE OR
FOUR NURSING HOMES
AND EVERY ONE OF THEM IS FULL.
WE HAVE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
PROVIDERS IN OUR COUNTY SO
IMAGINE HOW MANY RECIPIENTS WE.
IF ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE HAD TO GO
INTO A NURSING HOME IN OUR
COUNTY THEY WOULD BE LIVING IN
THEIR HOMES TILL THEY DIED.
BY THEMSELVES.
BECAUSE A WAS NOT A PROVIDER
THAT COULD COME IN AND TAKE CARE
OF THEM.
SO PLEASE.
REINSTATE PARA KEEP THE SEVEN
PERCENT
BUT MAKE SURE IT'S IN A SECURE
PLACE.
AND.
I JUST ASK THAT YOU MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO KEEP
COMING BACK ASKING FOR THIS
PLEASE. VISIT WERE IT IT IT'S.
THE GRADING THAT I HAVE TO KEEP
COMING AND BEGGING FOR MY
PAYCHECK.
BECAUSE IT IS MY PAGE.
I WORK FOR FOR SENIORS
ONE ONLY HAS FIFTY NINE HOURS
ONE ONLY HAS FIFTY ONE HOURS
TAKES SEVEN HURT FOURTEEN
PERCENT AWAY FROM BOTH OF THOSE.
AND THEIR I HAVE TO GO GET
ANOTHER CLIENT SO THAT I CAN
MAKE UP FOR THE ONES Y. LAS.
PLEASE DON'T DO THAT TO ME
BECAUSE I REALLY I WORK HARD AS
IT IS I DON'T NEED MORE HOURS.
I DON'T HAVE TO WORK MORE HOURS.
AND THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN ARE.
IM DOT ME DONE STONE AND I ARM.
BOB I AM PROUD OF DURING MY
UNION SEIU TEND TO BE FIFTEEN
AND. I AM A PARENT A MOTHER OWED
TO SPECIAL NEEDS.
IF YOU* GOTTEN THEIR HOURS
FOR LIKE SEVEN PERCENT EACH.
SO THAT'S A BOLD ON AUG FOURTEEN
PERCENT FOR MY TWO BOYS.
IT WILL AFFECT OF COURSE I'M A
MOTHER I WILL DO IT FOR THEM
FOR%
FREE BUT HOW BUT MY OTHER BROUGH
AYE IT'S JUST PROVIDER. THAT I
COULD NOT GIVE THE THE OTHER
HOURS BECAUSE YOU CUT SEVEN
PERCENT PER KID. SO IT WILL
AFFECT THE QUALITY OF A BOMB.
CARE FOR MY TWO BOYS SO I URGE
YOU SIR.
OUR DOCTOR ON BELOW DEPLETES.
ARM BOOK DOT SEVEN PERCENT
PERMANENTLY.
DONT THEY GET OUT FROM OUR.
I'M.
OUR KIDS ARE APPLY DISABLE.
BECAUSE THE NEEDED THIS HELP.
AND I AM TALKING ALSO ABOUT
HOME.
THE POLICE ARM I SUPPORT FOR
DOES SICK DAYS.
I USE JUST PROVIDE A BACKUP
SYSTEM.
THIS IS THE PER ARM I'M I'M LIKE
I'M REALLY HAPPY DOT YOU'RE
GIVING US A SICK TIME. BECAUSE I
HAVE EXPERIENCED IT LAST YEAR
DIED I WAS SICK ARMS LIKE YOU
KNOW I GOT VERTIGO.
AND I COULD NOT CALL ANYBODY.
TO.
HELP ME OUT.
LET'S TAKE CARE OF MY TWO BOYS
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE A SICK
TIME.
BUT WHEN YOU GUYS GAVE US ONE
DAY IN A YEAR I WAS VERY HAPPY.
THE ONLY THING THAT MY CONCERN
USE.
MY BOYS ARE AUTISTIC.
IT'S SO HARD FOR THEM TO LIKE
LIKE I'M.
YES YOU WILL IMPLEMENT A BACK UP
SYSTEM BUT I NEED. TO CALL
SOMEBODY DUCT WORK SWEDE THEM.
TAKE CARE OF THEM THAT THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED TAKING CARE OF MY
BOYS FOR THEM NOT THE HUB ABOUT
DON WHEN I KNEW PARA SON COME
SENT THE PROVERB ME FOR MY SICK
TIME.
THANK YOUR LISTENING THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CLARA KAUFMAN
EL DORADO COUNTY U. D. W..
I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION ABOUT
THE SEVEN PERCENT. BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND I EACH SS.
YOU HAVE TO GET APPROVED FOR
THESE HOURS THESE ARE HOURS THAT
THE CLIENTS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
STAY IN THEIR HOMES.
AND LIVE THEIR LIVES IN THEIR
HOMES AND NOT IN AN INSTITUTION.
SO YOU'RE TAKING AWAY HOURS THAT
THEY NEED TO LIVE IN THEIR
HOMES.
IT'S NOT ABOUT.
YOU KNOW PAYING THE WORKER SO
MUCH AS THE CLIENTS NEEDING THE
HOURS.
SO IF THEY DON'T HAVE A FAMILY
MEMBER THAT LIVES THERE.
WHO'S GOING TO TAKE CARE OF THE
CLIENT LIKE.
THINK OF THESE CLIENTS YOU SEE A
LOT OF THEM IN WHEELCHAIRS.
OKAY YOU'RE TAKEN SEVEN PERCENT
OF THE TIME THAT THEY NEED
SOMEBODY.
WHO'S GOING TO FILL THAT TIME
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO WITH
THAT TIME.
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO GET FROM
THEIR CHAIR TO THE BED?
HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT HOW YOU
WOULD GET FROM YOUR FROM A CHAIR
IF YOU END UP THERE BECAUSE WE
NEVER KNOW WHAT TOMORROW IS
GOING TO BRING.
HOW WILL WE GET FROM A CHAIR TO
THE BED?
IN HAVE SOMEBODY IT YOU KNOW
JUST SITTEN AT THE MEETING ROOM
GO NOT KNOW SOME PERCENT GONE.
YOU DON'T GET TO DO THAT THAT'S
WHAT SEVEN DAYS A WEEK SO MAYBE
THAT'S WHAT WE ELIMINATE GET
INTO BED EVERY NIGHT.
WHEN DOES IT WHEN DOES IT STOP.
YOU KNOW THE DISABLED ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE ARE YOU KNOW
THEY'RE ALWAYS THE ONES THAT GET
IT THE WORST.
WE ALWAYS GO FOR THE PEOPLE
THE KIDS THE DISABLED
YOU NO THEY DIDN'T THEY DON'T
GIVE US MUCH OF A VOICE IN
SOCIETY.
THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
YOU TAKE CARE OF THE LOWEST
YOU BRING UP THE LOWEST.
IT'S NOT ABOUT TRUMP IN IS YOU
KNOW ONE PERCENT OF SOCIETY IN
THREE PERCENT A SOCIETY WE KNOW
BETTER THAN THAT WE ALL KNOW
BETTER THAT WE ALL GREW UP. WE
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE.
GO BACK TO WHAT YOUR MOM TAUGHT
YOU.
I AM CHRISTIE'S FATHER BRIDGET
AND I AGES AS PROVIDER AND I'M
ON THE I JUST ADVISORY COMMITTEE
FOR SALMON AND YOU KNOW COUNTY.
AND WITH EDUCATE ADVOCATE
EMPOWER FAMILY CALIFORNIA I JUST
WANTED TO SAY ON THIS POINT THAT
WE WOULD ASK TO PERMANENTLY
RESEND THE SEVEN PERCENT COTTON
I JUST ASKS.
AND THEN IF IT'S OKAY I'D LIKE
TO SKIP TO MY PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
ISSUE ELEVEN IT'S OKAY OKAY.
I'M CURRENTLY IT CAN TAKE
ANYWHERE FROM A FEW WEEKS TO
MONTHS BEFORE ANYWAY AYE AGES AS
PROVIDERS ARE ROLLED INTO THE
PROGRAM AND NOW THEIR FIRST TIME
SEE. THIS DELAY IS UNACCEPTABLE
IT HAS SEVERELY IMPACTED THE
ABILITY OF I JUST AS CONSUMERS.
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN NEW
WORKERS HE MUST WAIT WEEKS OR
MONTHS TO GET THEIR FIRST
PAYCHECK.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE A MODEST
APPROPRIATION TO EXPEDITE THE
PROVIDER ENROLLMENT PROCESS AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL.
SO THAT PROVIDERS ARE ENROLLED
IMMEDIATELY ABLE TO TURN IN
PAPERWORK IN A TIMELY
ORIENTATION. PROVIDED A TIME
SHEET AT THAT ORIENTATION
DETERMINED AT THE END OF THE PAY
PERIOD. AND PROVIDED A DEDICATED
TELEPHONE ENROLLMENT LINE SO I
JUST AS RECIPIENTS CAN
SEAMLESSLY DESIGNATE THEIR
PROVIDER. AND WE'VE TALKED A LOT
OF.
ADULTS.
ON AYE AGE AS SASS THAT ARE
ESPECIALLY THAT ARE DISABLED
AND.
THIS DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY
REALLY NEED AND SO I HOPE THAT
SOMETHING THAT.
YOU GUYS WILL CONSIDER THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
KRISTEN JOHNSON.
OF HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF THEY
TOOK SEVEN PERCENT OF YOUR
MONEY.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT.
.
YOU KNOW I DO AGREE WITH MUCH OF
WHAT THE PUBLIC HAS SAID AND.
.
WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING OUR BEST AS WE'RE GOING
FORWARD TO HELP TO ATTEMPT TO
RESTORE.
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF.
THE CURRENT FINANCIAL STATE OF
OUR STATE.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SIX OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUES.
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
I DEBBIE THOMPSON DEPUTY THOUGH
PROGRAMS.
DO YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL IS LIKELY TO.
ADDRESS.
THE DETAILS ARE IN THE AGENDA I
THINK IT. WELL BRINGS THAT UP.
SO IF DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE
ONLY OVERSEEING COMMENTS ON
ISSUES SEVEN.
WE'RE JUST NOT THAT THE PROPOSAL
IN PART REQUEST ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS TO KIND OF LOOK AT.
RESYNC GROWTH UNPAID HOURS PER
CASE AND TRAIN A LINE THAT
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S INDICATIVE
OF INCREASED ACUITY WITHIN THE
CASELOAD EXCITER.
AND WITH THAT.
JUST GIVEN THAT DATA ANALYSIS.
WE WOULD THINK THAT THAT.
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL FOR
THOSE REASONS MERITS FURTHER
CONSIDERATION.
THINK BERMAN FUNDS.
BUT.
WE SUPPORT A PROPOSAL OF.
INCREASING RESOURCES TO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE CAN PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANT
THE COUNTIES IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
SEVEN.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SEVEN OPEN AND MOVE ON ISSUE A.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR FRANK
MECCA EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
APPRECIATE YOUR.
THE GEN DIS IN THIS ISSUE THAT
WE BROUGHT FORWARD. RELATED TO
THAT SEEM AT SYSTEM THE COMPUTER
SYSTEM THAT OUR WORKERS USED TO
PROVIDE EXCELLENT CUSTOMER
SERVICE TO CONSUMERS AND
PROVIDERS.
IF THE SYSTEM WHERE WE DOCUMENT
CONSUMERS NEEDS WE TRACK.
A PROVIDERS WORK HISTORY AND
BECAUSE OUR WORKERS ARE USING
THE SYSTEM EVERYDAY. THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT OFTEN IDENTIFY FIRST
BUGS IN THE SYSTEM AS ANY
SYSTEMS HAVE.
OR IDEAS FOR IMPROVING HOW THE
SYSTEM CAN BE MODIFIED.
TO PROVIDE EVEN BETTER SERVICE
FOR CLIENTS.
THOSE IDEAS TURN INTO CHANGE
REQUESTS THAT GET FORWARDED TO
THE STATE.
AND THERE IS A BUDGET FOR
CHANGER QUEST THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE STATE AND
PRIORITIZES.
THE CHANGE REQUEST THAT CAN BE
ACCOMMODATED WITHIN THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDS BUDGET.
FOR A COUPLE OF REASONS.
THIS THIS PROCESS HAS BEEN
ABOUT BECOME PROBLEMATIC FOR
COUNTIES.
THE FIRST IS THAT OFTEN COUNTY
REQUESTS.
I'M GET DEFERRED SORT OF MOVED.
THE PRIORITY LIST.
COMMENT BY DSS IN FAVOUR OF
OTHER STATE PRIORITIES.
YEAH SECOND ISSUE IS THAT COM
THERE'VE BEEN INSTANCES LIKE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ELECTRONIC A
TRONIC ELECTRONIC TIMESHEETS
WHERE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
OVERTIME. WERE IN LIEU OF
BUDGETING SUFFICIENT ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THOSE CHANGES.
THE STATE INSTEAD USES THE
EXISTING POT OF MONEY.
FOR CHANGER QUESTS
TO IMPLEMENT NEW POLICY
PROPOSALS WHICH WHICHWE BELIEVE
IS AN APPROPRIATE.
ARMED THE RESULT IS THAT THERE
ARE AT LEAST FIFTEEN CHANGE
REQUEST THERE SITTING IN THE
QUEUE.
I'M MORE THAT ARE BIG.
WAITING TO BE ADDED TO THE
QUEUE THAT'S A DECISION THAT THE
DEPARTMENT GETS TO MAKE AND SOME
OF THESE CHANGER QUESTS.
ARE AS OLD AS THE SEEM AT TO
SYSTEM ITSELF GOING BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
THAT THIS MAY SOUND TECHIE.
IT'S SORT OF.
ARM.
THIS IS THAT COMPUTER TECHNICAL
ISSUE IT CAN'T REALLY MATTER BUT
IT ACTUALLY REALLY DOES MATTER
LET ME GIVE YOU A FEW EXAMPLES.
ONE CHANGE WOULD INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF SPACE A SOCIAL WORKER
HAS SO THEY CAN FULLY DOCUMENT
THEIR ASSESSMENT OF HOW THE
CONSUMERS ARE DOING.
ANOTHER CHANGE WOULD ADD SPACE
SO THAT WE COULD HAVE ADDITIONAL
EMAILS.
I AM AN ADDITIONAL PHONE LINES
FOR PROVIDERS SO THAT IN A
DISASTER RESPONSE.
WERE BETTER ABLE TO GET IN
TOUCH WITH PROVIDERS.
.
IN ADDITION AT ONE EXAMPLE IS
BEING ABLE TO ADD INFORMATION
ABOUT AUTHORIZED REPRESENTATIVE
SOME CLIENTS HAVE PEOPLE THAT
CAN ACT ON THEIR BEHALF.
SO THAT WE HAVE THAT INFORMATION
IN THE SYSTEMIC CAN IMPROVE
CUSTOMER SERVICE.
.
THE INABILITY TO HAVE SORT OF A
REASONABLE DEGREE OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF.
COUNTY DRIVEN CHANGE REQUESTS
RESULTS AND MANUAL WORKAROUNDS
INEFFICIENT TIME AND
INCONSISTENT SERVICE FOR.
TAPPER CLIENTS AND SO WE'RE
REQUESTING THREE THINGS.
THE FIRST IS AN ADDITIONAL ONE
TIME PART OF.
FUNDS TWO POINT FIVE MILLION A
GENERAL FUND WHICH WHEN MATCHED
UP WITH FEDERAL FUNDS.
AND WE BELIEVE WOULD BE ABLE TO
WORK THROUGH THE EXISTING
BACKLOG.
TO MAKE SURE THEIR BACKLOG
DOESN'T MATERIALIZE AGAIN WERE
REQUESTING THAT FIVE PERCENT OF
THAT THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
BE DEDICATED FOR COUNTY
GENERATED CHANGE REQUESTS.
NUMBER ALSO ASKING FOR A POLICY
WHEREBY WHEN SIGNIFICANT NEW
POLICY CHANGES ARE MADE TO THE
STATE. THAT WE APPROPRIATE THE
NECESSARY FUNDS TO AUTOMATE
THOSE CHANGES AND NOT USE A POT
OF MONEY.
THAT WAS NEVER INTENDED TO FUND
THOSE DOES SIGNIFICANT NEW
POLICY CHANGES.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST.
DIRECTOR LIKE ONE. OFF. ALWAYS
STRUGGLED TO TRY TO GET ON THE
SAME PAGE WITH MY FRIEND MISTER
AMERICA. HOME IN THIS INSTANCE
AYE AYE WHAT I'D SUGGEST IS THAT
WE GO ON HAVING DIALOGUE WITH
THE ASSOCIATION ON WHAT WE MAY
PERHAPS A SOLUTION.
AND WITH THAT FLOWS COMPLICATED
WILL SIMPLY BE TO HAPPY
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTED ON THE.
CHANGE CONTROL MANAGEMENT
PROCESS FOR SEE MAPS MUCHAS WE
ARE WORKING WITH THEM TO HAVE TO
STATE REPRESENTED ON THE SOLES.
CHANGE MANAGEMENT BOARD.
ELIOT IF I MIGHT IS NOT A BAD
IDEA. ARM BUT IF THE COUNTIES
ARE REPRESENTED ON A CHAIR ON
THE GOVERNMENT SYSTEM. THAT
DOESN'T CHANGE THE FACT THAT THE
NEXT SIGNIFICANT POLICY THAT
HAPPENS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DECIDES NOT TO FUND
THAT.
DE AUTOMATION NECESSARY AND
THEN THAT AND THEN WE USE AN
EXISTING POT OF FUNDS THAT WAS
NEVER INTENDED FOR EXAMPLE.
SO WHILE I APPRECIATE THE
SINCERITY AND I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE SOLUTION.
TO DISCUSS GOVERNANCE I DON'T
BELIEVE IT'S A FISH AND.
TO DEAL WITH THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEM OF THE BACKLOG.
A LOON DEPARTMENT OF.
YEAH YOU IF I IT'S I I DO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
MAJOR POLICY CHANGES
I DO PROVIDES.
FUNDING FOR THOSE AUTOMATION.
FOR EXAMPLE WE.
DID THE.
LATEST CHANGES WITH OVERTIME WE
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS SIR
MONEY FOR CEMEX TO ACCOMMODATE
THOSE CHANGES.
SO I JUST MORE POINT OUT THAT
WE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE.
SUCH RESOURCES WE AND WE CAN
THAT WE CAN DOCUMENT FOR YOU HOW
THE QUEUE OF CHANGES THAT WERE
IN THE HOPPER. GOT PUSHED OFTEN
DELAYED WHEN THINGS USURPED
THINGS BECAME A HIGHER PRIORITY
THAT WERE THE FUNCTION OF POLICY
CHANGES THAT THE STATE.
BUT AGAIN I ALWAYS TRY TO STAY
ON THE SAME PAGE OF MY FRIEND
ON.
IN TRUTH THERE'S A THROUGHPUT
ISSUE
WHICH IS THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH
BANDWIDTH THAN WHEN THE.
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS AROUND FAIR
LABOR STANDARDS ACT OCCURRED IT
LITERALLY BLOCKED OUT THE SUN
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT TO GIVE WAY
FOR ITS IMPLEMENTATION.
IN OTHER POLICY CHANGES FRANKLY.
THE LEGISLATURE DETERMINES
SO IF.
AS WE BECAUSE YOU THEIR
PROPOSALS IN FRONT OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR POLICY CHANGES
WE ALWAYS TRIED NOTE AND.
ALLOCATE THE RESOURCES TO MAKE
IT POSSIBLE
BUT AGAIN I MEAN THAT WE WILL
CERTAINLY WORK WITH THE
COUNTIES.
BECAUSE THEY'RE A GOOD PATH.
EARLIER INCOMES.
JUST HAPPY TO PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THE MEMBERS
MAY HAVE AND LOOKING INTO THIS
THANK YOU WILL NOT TAKE.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE A.
STEP BROUGHT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
JUSTIN YOU'RE A CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL ON THAT
WILL HELP REDUCE THE BACKLOG OF
COUNTY PARTIES FOR C. MIPS AND
ALSO REDUCE THE LOCAL
WORKAROUNDS THINK.
THANK YOU SIR.
KELLY BRICKS ON BEHALF OF THE
SENATE CLARK COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
CLEAR IN SUPPORT OF THE CUTTING
OFF OUR DOCTORS REQUEST THANK
YOU.
THINK YOU DE ON INSTITUTING ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE COUNTY
SUPPORTS THE BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS THE AYE IT JUST US.
AUTOMATION SYSTEM BACKLOG
THINKING.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL HOLD ISSUE EIGHT OPEN AND
MOVE ON TUITION ON
.
IF WE CAN BEGIN WITH NORMA FULL
OF ARTISTS.
SENATE QUICKLY.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS YES THAT'S
CORRECT I'M ON NORRMALM ONLY LOT
IS SO WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR A TWO THOUSAND.
AND I AM FILLING IN FOR CARRYING
KIESLER WHO COULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY.
AND I YOU HAVE A COPY OF OUR
PROPOSAL ON PAGE THIRTY NINE. OF
THE AGENDA.
.
AND IT IS A REQUEST FOR
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO ENSURE
THAT PUBLIC AT THE ORTIZ.
COUPLE FILLED THEIR STATS
STATUTORY MANDATES.
.
AS A RESULT OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW COUNTY
I A TOUGH* AMMO .
.
THIS RESULTED IN A SHORT FALL TO
PUBLIC AUTHORITY ADMINISTRATIVE
FINDING IN YOU CAN SEE THE.
IN THE CHART THAT FOR FISCAL
YEAR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THAT
SHORTFALL WAS TWENTY SIX POINT
ONE SIX PERCENT AND FOR FISCAL
YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. OTHER
SHORTFALL IS NINETEEN POINT
EIGHT SEVEN PERCENT.
THE IMPACT OF THIS SHORTFALL IN
PUBLIC AUTHORITY ADMINISTRATIVE
FINDING.
HAS HAD A SIGNIFICANT.
.
SIGNIFICANT.
ISSUES AT THE PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES.
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES HAVE HAD TO
LAY OFF STAFF AND CURTAIL
SERVICES
UP MORE THAN ONE PUBLIC
AUTHORITY HAS LOST HALF THEIR
STAFF FOR EXAMPLE.
IN SANTA BARBARA STAFFING HAS
GONE DOWN FROM.
TWELVE TO SIX AND TO IN THE
RIVERSIDE PUBLIC AUTHORITY HAS
HAD TO CUT THIRTY STAFF
POSITION.
SO THE SHORTFALL IN PUBLIC
AUTHORITY FINDING HAS RESULTED
IN PRO LONG TO PROVIDER
ENROLLMENT TIMELY. DELAYED
REGISTRY REFERRALS AND SLOWER
RESPONSE TO CONSUMERS AND
ROVIDERS
AND THESE ARE DELAYS IN SERVICES
TO THOSE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES OUR SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP A
BUDGET FORMULA TO ENSURE
ADEQUATE AND SUSTAINED FUNDING
FOR PUBLIC AUTHORITIES.
HOWEVER WE ARE REQUESTING
SUFFICIENT FUNDING FOR THE
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR.
WHAT IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
RESPONSE TO THIS BOOK?
WE'RE HAVING ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE PUBLIC AUTHORITIES AND
WE AS MADE COMMITTED TO DO AS WE
ARE CONTINUING TO DO WITH THE I
JUST US COUNTY FOUND.
I MEN AS WELL AND WE ARE HAVING
REGULAR MEETINGS TO.
TRY AND EVALUATE EXACTLY WHERE
WE NEED TO BE IN ORDER TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF.
OF THE PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
THANK YOU LA NO HAN FINANCE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
NINE.
JUSTIN GARRETT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
I'M AS I INDICATED EARLIER WITH
COUNTY ADMINISTRATION FUNDING
STRIPES ES I'M WITH.
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE TAKING
PLACE ON TO ENSURE COST
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM ALIGNS
WITH STATE FUNDING
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE NINE OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE.
THAT.
DID ANYONE WITH THE ARE YOU I'M
W. PCS PROVIDERS CARE FOR
CONSUMERS THAT NEED ADDITIONAL
PERSONAL CARE OURS BUT
ESSENTIALLY PROVIDE THE SAME
SERVICES AS I AGES AS PROVIDERS.
SPECIFICALLY W. PCS PROVIDERS
ARE REQUIRED TO MEET THE SAME
PROVIDER REQUIREMENTS OUTLINED
IN THE ICE AGES THIS PROGRAM AND
ARE PAID THE SAME HOURLY RATE AS
I AGES AS PROVIDERS WITHIN THE
SAME PAY ROAMING SYSTEM.
THERE'S APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED WBCS PROVIDERS STATEWIDE
SEVENTY PERCENT PROVIDE BOTH AYE
AGES SAYS AND W. PCS SERVICES
AND ROUGHLY EIGHT HUNDRED
PROVIDE.
WBCS ONLY SERVICES.
DESPITE THE SIMILARITIES AND
WORKING. AND WORKING TERMS AND
CONDITIONS W. PCS PROVIDERS ARE
NOT AFFORDED THE SAME BENEFITS
AS I AGES AS PROVIDERS SUCH AS
HEALTHCARE AND LABOR
REPRESENTATION.
CURRENTLY W. PCS PROVIDERS ARE
UNABLE TO RECEIVE HEALTH
BENEFITS BECAUSE THEIR HOURS
DON'T COUNT TOWARDS THEIR HEALTH
COVERAGE.
THIS PROPOSAL BRINGS PARITY BY
ESTABLISHING THE PUBLIC RECORD
ABOUT THAT THE PUBLIC AUTHORITY
AT THE EMPLOYER OF RECORD FOR W.
PCS PROVIDERS AND EXTENDS THE
SAME BENEFITS TO WBCS PROVIDERS
AS I JUST AS PROVIDERS. BY
HAVING LABOR REPRESENTATION W.
PCS PROVIDERS WILL BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE ASSISTANCE WITH
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS
FLSA THAT WAS DISCUSSED.
.
A LITTLE BIT EARLIER IN THE
AGENDA SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
PUBLIC ALREADY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY A MORE ACCURATE
APPROPRIATION FOR THIS REQUEST
AND WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU WHAT'S THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RISK.
OPPOSING.
THANK YOU.
THERE ARE.
Q. AS THERE ARE A LOT OF
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN I JUST
HASN'T W. PCS AMBER CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT THE PROPOSAL THAT HAS
BEEN PUT FORWARD AND WILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THIS PROCESS. AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TEN.
THANK YOU BRADLEY WE ADMIRE AYE
AYE JUSTICE WORKER AND A FORMER
W. PCS I'D SHOW WORKER. IN
SEVERANCE IS CO THE PROGRAM OF
COURSE IS A SUPPLEMENT TO HELP.
KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES
THERE'S A FORMULA THAT IS.
IT IT IT IS INVOLVED BEFORE US.
OFTEN THE.
THERE'S A COMBINATION OF MY AGE
SHOW.
WCS HOURS HD.
I JUST US HOURS AT SO THERE IS
LIKE A DIFFICULTY IS.
YOU KNOW ARE THESE HOURS.
AYE JURORS ARE THESE HOURS I
JUST AS OURS SO AS A MATTER OF
YOU KNOW PEOPLE LOSING THEIR.
THEIR MEDICAL I'M COVERAGE
IF WE WERE ON TOP OF THAT IT WAS
JUST AN INSANE.
PROBLEM TO.
IT TOO YOU KNOW HAVE TWO
CLASSES OF WORKERS DOING
BASICALLY THE SAME. OF JOB BUT
FUNDED BY THESE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS SO WE REALLY NEED THE
W. PCS IN THE I'D SHOW WORKERS
TO BE.
ABLE TO TO HAVE HEALTH CARE AND
HOW THE BENEFITS THAT.
AYE AGE AS AS WORKERS HAVE ONE
THROUGH OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
DEB BROCK DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA SPORT HUMAN.
CRISTINA BUS HAMILTON UW IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT ON
BRINGING UP THE DYESS I HAVE ONE
QUESTION IF I CAN ASK THE ABSENT
YES.
HE WAS AGENDA IS AS AND
PRESENTED AS THE ADVOCATES AS
BEING INADVERTENTLY EXCLUDED I
WAS HOPING YOU COULD TALK ABOUT
THAT.
SO WHY CAN'T SPEAK TO THE.
THE HISTORY OF THE ORIGINAL
BILL.
HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
I JUST AS AND W. PCS FOR EXAMPLE
I JUST HAS A STATE PLAN BENEFIT.
W. PCS IS BUILT INTO TWO OF OUR
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED SERVICE
WAIVERS.
THAT BOTH OF WHICH I'VE COME ON
AT DIFFERENT TIMES.
AND HAVE DIFFERENT RULES AND
REQUIREMENTS AROUND HOW WE FUND
THOSE THE SPLIT OF THOSE FOR
EXAMPLE IS ONLY STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDS VERSUS I JUST AS
HIS. COUNTY STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDS I'M SO THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES AND BUT I WOULD HAVE
TO GO BACK AND CONSULT WITH MY
COLLEAGUES REGARDING THE HISTORY
SPECIFICALLY OF.
THAT REFERENCE I'D APPRECIATE
IT JUST TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW WE GOT INTO
THIS.
IN THE FIRST PLACE AND ANY
INFORMATION YOU CAN PROVIDE OUR
STAFF WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED
OF COURSE WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE TEN OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE ELEVEN.
IF ANYONE WITH THE CI YOU
CALIFORNIA.
ON BEHALF OF OUR THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THOUSAND I AGES AS
PROVIDERS WE REQUEST TO MAKE
SMALL YET SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO
THE PROVIDER ENROLLMENT PROCESS
IN ORDER TO ON BOARD NEW
PROVIDERS INTO THE SYSTEM AND
INEFFICIENT AND EXPEDITED
MANNER.
WE I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE DEPARTMENT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING A LOT WITH THEM.
IN THE PAST FEW MONTHS TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS OVER THIS
PROPOSAL.
AND SPECIFICALLY REQUEST FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS INTERESTED IN
APPLYING TO BECOME AN AYE AGE
ASSESSED PROVIDER RECEIVE THEIR
ENROLLMENT PACKET WITHIN THREE
BUSINESS DAYS AND ENSURE
PERSPECTIVE PROVIDERS HAVE
ACCESS TO THE MANDATORY PROVIDER
ORIENTATION WITHIN NO MORE THAN
TWO WEEKS.
ACCORDING TO EDIE DE THE STATE
WILL NEED AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOME CARE
PROVIDERS BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TO MEET THE DEMAND OF THE AGING
POPULATION. CURRENTLY IT CAN
TAKE ANYWHERE FROM A WEEK TO
MONTHS.
BEFORE PROVIDERS ARE IN WROTE
CLEARED AND GIVEN THEIR FIRST
TIME SHEETS THIS IS DEFINITELY
THE CASE IN RURAL COUNTIES
OFTENTIMES ARE PROVIDERS HAVE
BEEN HIRED BY CONSUMER THEY WILL
BEGIN WORKING WITHOUT ANY
COMPENSATION EVEN IF ALL THE
STEPS ARE NOT COMPLETED.
SOMETIMES ON PROVIDER THAT'S
HAVE TO WAIT TO GET APPROVAL
THEY WILL SEEK OTHER EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES OF OPPORTUNITIES
WHICH ONLY EXACERBATES THE NEED
FOR MORE PROVIDERS IN THE
SYSTEM.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL HELP GAIN AND
RETAIN PROVIDERS IN THAT WITHIN
THE SYSTEM AND WE WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAX WILL HAVE CRISTINA
VASANTHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
CRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON WITH YOU
W..
COMPLETELY ECHO THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM ASCII YOU
I I JUST WANT TO RAISE ONE
EXAMPLE THIS IS THE MOST RECENT
EXAMPLE THAT WAS GIVEN TO ME BY
OUR FOLKS IN THE FIELD.
A WE HAVE A PROVIDER HER NAME IS
FIVE YEAR OLD LOW MEDINA THE
MEDINA FROM KERN COUNTY.
WHO ATTENDED A OR I AM SORELY
MISSED OUR BACK CALL THE COUNTY
TO APPLY?
OR TO ATTEND ES ORIENTATION
AND SUMMIT HER.
APPLICATION TO BECOME A
PROVIDER IN ON DECEMBER EIGHTH.
WAS GIVEN AN APPOINTMENT FOR AN
ORIENTATION ON DECEMBER
TWENTIETH.
SUBMITTED HER BACKGROUND CHECK
MATERIAL ON JANUARY SECOND. AND
RECEIVED A TIME SHE'D ON
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH.
SO FOR ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES
FROM DECEMBER JANUARY HALFWAY
THROUGH FEBRUARY THIS PER RIDER
WAS WORKING. AND MIND YOU THIS
IS GOT A TIME SHE ON FEBRUARY
FIFTEENTH NOT GOT PAID ON
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH THEN IT WAS
HOWEVER MUCH LONGER TO GET PAID.
SO THIS IS A COMMON POLICE ISSUE
THAT UNFORTUNATELY HASN'T BEEN
RESOLVED BY THE ELECTRONIC TIME
SHEETS.
AND.
AYE I WISH THERE WAS A SIMPLE
SOLUTION TO THIS I THINK THIS IS
COMMON SENSE STUFF.
SEND THEM AN APPLICATION WITHIN
THREE DAYS AFTER THEY.
YOU KNOW CALL.
THE HAVE A ORIENTATION FOR THEM
TO TEN WITHIN TWO WEEKS OF
APPLYING I MEAN THIS IS COMMON
SENSE STUFF THAT SHOULD ALREADY
BE HAPPENING. BUT FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS ISN'T AND SO WE NEED
FUNDING PER OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH OUR OUR COUNTY PARTNERS TO.
.
ALLOW THIS TO OCCUR IN THIS WILL
AT LEAST
HELP WITH SOMEWHAT WITH THIS
DELAY. THANK YOU.
AFTER LIKE WHEN.
THAT INTEL.
I WE ALSO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
WAYS TO.
SURE THAT PROVIDERS ARE ABLE TO
GET THROUGH THE ENROLLMENT
PROCESS IN AN EXPEDITIOUS WAY.
OF ONE OF THE AREAS OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALSO WORKING ON IT
CURRENTLY IS.
THE POINT TIME WHEN SOMEONE
BECOMES ELIGIBLE TO GET THEM AND
IT CONNECTED TO THAT PARTICULAR
CLIENT THEY'RE GOING TO WORK FOR
WORK FOR AND TIME SHEETS ISSUED.
AND WORLD.
FIRST AREA WE'RE LOOKING AT
BEING ABLE TO EXPEDITE THAT IS
BY.
.
ENHANCING OUR.
I JUST US PORTAL THAT'S A PART
OF THE ELECTRONIC TIME SHEET.
SYSTEM.
SO THAT RECIPIENTS COULD
ACTUALLY ENROLL THEIR PROVIDERS
DIRECTLY THROUGH THAT PORTAL SO
WE CERTAINLY. I SHARE THE VALUE
TO.
I EXPEDITE THESE PROCESS.
HELLO DEPARTMENT OF FUNDS.
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
ELEVEN.
GET BROUGHT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA CLIENTS NEED
PROVIDERS PROVIDERS NEED TO GET
PAID. YOU SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
WE CAME.
BRADLEY WE ADMIRE AYE TO SAYS
WORKERS HAVEN'T CISCO I HAVE A
WITNESS LIKE.
A HALF A DOZEN PEOPLE WHO JUST
GAVE UP AND QUIT AND DIDN'T YOU
KNOW THAT THEY WERE WORKING FOR
A WHILE BUT IT JUST THEY NEVER
IT.
THE THEY LOST FAITH IN THE SIT
AND PROGRAM. AND THEY'VE FIGURED
VOTE THIS IS THE WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN IN THE BEGINNING.
YOU KNOW BY BY.
SO WE REALLY NEED TO TO TRY THIS
AND I WOULD SUPPORT THAT.
WITH THAT SEEING NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT ON BRING IT BACK
TO THE DYESS.
I'D LIKE TO GET THE DEPARTMENT'S
ASSESSMENT OF THE ESTIMATED COST
OF THE ADVOCATES PROPOSAL THAT
THEY'VE TAG TO IT. IS IN THE
BALLPARK FOR THE KINDS OF
SPECIFIC IMPROVEMENTS AND. JUST
TO GET AN ANALYSIS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT.
I JUST ANSWER ON THAT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THE ASSUMPTIONS BEHIND THAT
NUMBER YAK THEY'RE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE SPONSORS OF IT.
GREAT.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
ELEVEN OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
TWELVE.
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY IF I COULD
JUST REGISTERED MY SUPPORT FOR
THE ISSUE TWELFTH THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES AT HOME SAFE
ADVOCACY PROPOSAL GREAT THANK
YOU THANK
.
BEFORE WE BEGIN I JUST WANTED TO
THANK THIS FINAL PANEL FOR
STAYING SO LATE TENS.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE.
I CAN GET GIVEN THE HOUR ALONG
WITH. AYE WE DISTRIBUTED UP
POWER POINT ON THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM OF
WAR DEL GRAMMATICAL RUNS THE
PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF THE CVS
OURSELVES OUR LIAISON COUNTIES
IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS HAPPY
TO ANSWER THEM.
OTHERWISE I THINK.
TARA OR A GLASS OF THEIR
MEMBERS.
I GOT.
YOU'RE GOING.
THANKS FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK
I HAD TONIGHT MY NAME IS ADAM
ARE COOKIE SHOP AND I'M A
PHYSICIAN AND A PROFESSOR OF
MEDICINE AT UCSF AND I PRACTICE
AT SOCCER BURKE SAN FRANCISCO
GENERAL WHICH IS THE. PUBLIC
HOSPITAL IN THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO. AND I'M ALSO
AN NIH FUNDED RESEARCHER WHO
SPENT THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
STUDYING AND HOMELESSNESS AND
THE AFFECTS ON HOMELESSNESS ON
HEALTH.
AND THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION HAS ASKED ME TO
PRESENT TODAY ON THE ISSUE OF
ELDER HOMELESSNESS SAFE BY TO
PROPOSE ON.
I COME HERE TODAY TO EXPLAIN
WHAT I'VE LEARNED TO MY TWO
DECADES OF WORK AS A RESEARCHER
AND PRACTICING CLINICIAN HAVE
THE SAFETY NET HOSPITAL ON THE
TOOL OF HOMELESSNESS AND OTHER
ADULTS. AND TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
URGENT NEED TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS IN THIS POPULATION.
IN OUR RESEARCH WE FOUND THAT
AMONG SINGLE ADULTS WHO ARE
HOMELESS ABOUT HALF FOR OVER THE
AGE OF FIFTY. ARE WORKING
OAKLAND HAS SHOWN THAT AMONGST
THOSE WHO ARE HOMELESS OVER THE
AGE OF FIFTY FORTY FOUR PERCENT
HAD NEVER EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS BEFORE THE AGE OF
FIFTY.
MANY OF THESE WERE PEOPLE WHO
HAD BEEN LEFT VULNERABLE BY
ELLIS JOB LOSS LOSS OF A FAMILY
MEMBER.
OR OTHER ABUSE AND IT WAS THAT
ABUSE PHYSICAL ABUSE FINANCIAL
EXPLOITATION THAT LED DIRECTLY
TO THEIR BECOMING HOMELESSNESS
AS YOU WELL KNOW HOMELESSNESS IS
A CRISIS LEVELS IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT FOR EACH PERSON TO
EXPERIENCE IT IT'S A PERSONAL
CATASTROPHE A CATASTROPHE WITH
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
TO END HOMELESSNESS WE NEED TO
SHUT THE FRONT DOOR TO
HOMELESSNESS
WE NEED TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS
BEFORE IT OCCURS IN THE FIRST
PLACE. PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS
IS LESS COSTLY IN EVERY WAY THEN
RE HOUSING PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BECOME HOMELESS.
ARE SYSTEMS ARE NOT CURRENTLY
WELL DESIGNED TO RESPOND
PROACTIVELY TO PEOPLE WHO ARE AT
HIGH RISK OF LOSING HOUSING. BUT
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RECTIFY THIS WITH HOME SAFE
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
WORKERS ARE THE ONES WHO
INTERACT WITH GLOBAL ALLDERS AT
THIS PIVOTAL MOMENT OF CRISIS.
AND THESE ARE THE CRISES THAT
HAVE ACTED UPON PREVENT THAT
RARE OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS BEFORE IT
OCCURS.
WHATEVER STUDY PARTICIPANTS ARE
COMMON T. IS A FIFTY SIX YEAR
OLD MAN WITH LIFELONG
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY. HE WAS
LIVING IN A LOW COST DEPARTMENT
PAID FOR A BIAS DISABILITY
BENEFITS THAT HE HAD BY VIRTUE
OF BEING DELAYED.
HE HAD NO FAMILY BUT HE HAD MET
MANY PEOPLE THROUGH HIS CHURCH.
THERE HE MET SOMEONE WHO OFFERED
TO BE AND I SAY THIS IN QUOTES
HIS PAY E.. THIS PAY E. TOLD HIM
THAT HE COULD HELP MANAGE ITS
BUDGET IF HE HANDED OVER HIS
DISABILITY CHECKS.
THE P. INSISTED.
AND THAT T. COME EVERY DAY TO
PICK UP SMALL AMOUNTS OF MONEY
THAT HE GAVE HIM TEN OR FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AT A TIME.
THE TRIP REQUIRE TEE TO TAKE
SEVERAL BUSES AND THE MONEY HE
PICKED UP HARDLY EVEN COVERED
HIS BUS FARE.
IT PAYING UNFORTUNATELY NEVER
PAID HIS RENT.
BECAUSE OF THIS HE FELL BEHIND
AND WAS EVICTED WITH NO FAMILY
OR SOCIAL SUPPORT HE BECAME
HOMELESS AND AND RESORTED TO
SLEEPING ON THE AC TRANSIT
PASSES.
HIS HEALTH DECLINED
PRECIPITOUSLY AND HE LOST
CONTACT WITH THOSE WHO MAY HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO HELP AGAINST THIS
EXPLOITATION.
WE KNOW THAT THEIR WELL KNOWN
AND SEVERE CONSEQUENCES TO
HOMELESSNESS AMONG OLDER ADULTS
A RESEARCH HAS FOUND THAT ADULTS
FIFTEEN OLDER HAD HEALTH
INDICATORS THINGS LIKE COGNITIVE
PHYSICAL FUNCTION. THAT WERE
WORSE THAN ADULTS TWENTY YEARS
OLDER THAN THEM IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION SO THEY MAY BE IN
THEIR FIFTIES THEY REALLY WERE
MORE LIKE PEOPLE IN THEIR
SEVENTIES OR EIGHTIES IN TERMS
OF THEIR HOUSE.
HOMELESSNESS AGES PEOPLE IRAQ
WHICH IS THEIR BODIES THEIR
MINDS IN THEIR SPIRITS.
AND WHEN OLDER ADULTS BECOME
HOMELESS THE CAN NO LONGER
ACCESS THEIR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS AND THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS AND RELY
INSTEAD ON EMERGENCY CARE.
pOF THE OLDER ADULTS WE STUDIED
HAD VISITED EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
AND ELEVEN PERCENT HAD BEEN
HOSPITALIZED FOR PHYSICAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS.
HOMELESSNESS IS CATASTROPHIC.
TO HEALTH AND WELL BEING AND IT
ALSO PREPARED TO TENCHI IT'S THE
RISK OF VICTIMIZATION. AND OUR
RESEARCH WE FOUND THAT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS SORT
ENORMOUS RISK OF BEING
VICTIMIZED WHILE THERE ARE
HOMELESS BOTH PHYSICAL AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE EXTRAORDINARILY
COMMON. WE FOUND THAT THIS RISK
IS CUT BY HALF IS SOON AS THEY
BECOME REHOUSED.
THEREFORE HOME SAFE WOULD ALLOW
APS WORKERS NOT ONLY TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS BUT TO PREVENT
FURTHER VICTIMIZATION AT A
CRITICAL POINT.
AS A PHYSICIAN I CAN SAY THAT
THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT STEP I
CAN TAKE FOR PATIENTS IS TO HELP
THEM RETAIN THEIR HOUSING. THERE
IS NO MEDICINE AS POWERFUL AS
HOUSING.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THE ENORMOUS TOLL OF
HOMELESSNESS AND OLDER ADULTS ON
THEIR HOUSE IN ON THE COST.
SOCIETY HOUSING IS THE BEST
MEDICINE AND HOME SAFE IS A
COMMON WAY TO COMMONSENSE WAY TO
PREVENT THE DEVASTATION OF
HOMELESSNESS AMONG FRAIL OLDER
ADULTS.
WE COULD TALK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK
DR SHOW REALLY SAID IT ALL. YOU
DON'T PROTECTIVE SERVICES WORKER
IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO BE
ABLE TO INTERVENE TO PREVENT
THAT HOMELESSNESS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM AS
IT WAS CREATED COUPLE OF DECADES
AGO. NEVER ANTICIPATED THE
HOUSING CRISIS THAT WAS NEVER
RESOURCES ARE BUILT.
PROVIDE WORKERS WITH THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO.
UP PAY UP BACK RENT OR A
SECURITY DEPOSIT OR DO SOME
HEAVY CLEANING UP THERE WAS A.
HOARDING INCIDENT OR TED
NEGOTIATE WITH LANDLORDS.
AND SO.
WE'RE ASKING FOR FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A THREE
YEAR.
GRANT PROGRAM
COUNTIES WOULD HAVE TO MATCH IT
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR.
AND IT'S IT'S MODELED AFTER TO
PROGRAMS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR HAVE ACTUALLY
CREATED IN THE PAST ONE IS THE
CAL WORKS HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM.
AND ONE IS THE BRINGING FAMILIES
HOME PROGRAM.
THOSE ARE TWO INVESTMENTS WISE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION AGREED
UPON.
TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS AMONGST
CAO WORKS FAMILIES.
AND TO FACILITATE THEIR
REUNIFICATION OF FAMILIES IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM OR
EXPERIENCING HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS. WE'RE BUILDING ON
THE SUCCESSFUL MODELS.
THE MODEL REQUIRES SO A COUNTY
MATCH DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR SO THE
COUNTY WILL HAVE AN INVESTMENT.
YOUR SKIN IN THE GAME THE COUNTY
WILL BE REQUIRED TO UTILIZE TO
THE FULLEST EXTENT EXISTING
RESOURCES SO THAT WE'RE NOT.
SO THAT WE'RE NOT REINVENTING
THE WHEEL AND WE'RE CONVINCED
THAT WE CAN PROVE NOT ONLY CAN
WE SAVE LIVES AND ALLOW PEOPLE
TO LIVE OUT.
THAT THEIR SENIOR YEARS WITH
MORE DIGNITY THAN THEY EVER
WOULD HAVE IN THE ABSENCE OF
HOME SAFE BUT THAT WE CAN SAVE
THE TAXPAYERS.
MONEY.
AS WELL SO WE VERY MUCH THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND URGENT
CONSIDERATION OF THE.
AFFIRMATIVE.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK US IT
EVERYDAY FOR REACHING OUT TO THE
AND RESTORATION ON THIS PROPOSAL
WHILE WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
LANGUAGE.
WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WE'D
LIKE THAT PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE
SPECIFIC DATA BY WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE AND DEMONSTRATION
COULD EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF A PROGRAM AND CONSIDER IT AT
ANY STATE OPERATION COSTS THE
DEPARTMENT.
UNIVERSALLY SKIPPED OVER
DIRECTOR LIKE BORN TO SEE IF YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THE PRICE
NO ALL I JUST WOULD LIKE TO SAY
I WISH I'D THOUGHT OF IT.
WITH THAT WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE TWELVE.
JUSTIN YOU'RE A CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
THIS WILL HELP.
I VICTIMS OF ELDER ABUSE WHO ARE
BECOMING HOMELESS IT ADDRESSES A
CRITICAL ISSUE WOULD ALLOW
COUNTIES TO DEMONSTRATE HOW TO
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS AMONG THIS
VALUABLE POPULATION AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THINKING.
THANK YOU SIR.
THEY'RE BROUGHT DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE HEARD SO
MANY PROPOSALS TODAY INTENDED TO
HELP PEOPLE. NOT NEED PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS.
BUT THIS IS SO VERY IMPORTANT WE
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
THIS IS A PRUDENT INVESTMENT AND
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS VERY STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT BEGIN.
CAROL SUL REPRESENTING CO
SPONSOR ORGANIZATIONS CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND THE
CALIFORNIA ALTER JUSTICE
COALITION AND THE SUPPORTER OF
THE CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA
SENIORS.
WE KNOW THAT.
THERE IS AN INCREASING
PERCENTAGE OF OLDER ADULTS IN
THE HOMELESS POPULATION IT'S
EVIDENCE WE'VE HEARD FROM DOCTOR
COULD SHOW THE PROBLEMS THAT
THAT BRINGS.
ONE OF THE FACTORS THAT WE'VE
LOOKED AT A LOT IS THE
INCREASING INCIDENCE OF
FINANCIAL ABUSE AND
EXPLOITATION.
AND ONCE PEOPLE LOSE THEIR
RESOURCES THEY HAVE THEY HAVE
NOTHING AND SO THIS CREATES A
VERY GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR A LOT
OF CREATIVE PEOPLE. TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE COME UP WITH
EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS THAT WE
COULD BUILD ON IN FUTURE SO. WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TIFFANY WHAT WHAT THOSE THE OUR
YOU CALIFORNIA THIS IS A A VERY
GOOD PROGRAM THE STRONG PROGRAM
AND WE WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING MISTER MEMBERS ON
MARTHA REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WE ALSO.
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF ON CW
TAKING THE LEAD AND.
THIS IS A POPULATION THAT IS
ALREADY VULNERABLE DEVASTATED
AND. WE NEED TO PROVIDE THE
TOOLS TO OUR SOCIAL WORKERS SO
THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE THEM WITH
THE SUPPORT. AS.
WERE SEEN AN INCREASE IN.
ABUSE IN THIS AMONG THIS
POPULATION. AND.
THIS INFORMATION THAT THAT THEY
CAN GET ALL THE THE RESOURCES
THEY CAN GET WOULD HELP ME GET
BACK IN. YOU KNOW WAS THERE SO
FRAGILE THEY NEED THAT SUPPORT
IMMEDIATELY SO WE APPRECIATE YOU
FIND IN THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
I THINK HERE TO YOUR MESSAGE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE HOMES THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADISON Y. ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
MATEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IS PART OF A
PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT I WILL
BRING IT BACK UP TO THE DYESS.
I FEEL INCLINED TO SAY THAT WE
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS PROPOSAL
ON THE ASSEMBLY LAST YEAR AND.
HOPEFULLY THAT GIVES YOU A.
INSIGHT INTO WHERE THIS
COMMITTEE MAY BE THIS YEAR AS
WELL.
A BEFORE I CLOSE TODAY'S MEETING
I WANTED TO SPECIFICALLY THANK
DIRECTOR LIKE ONE FOR.
STAYING HERE THIS ENTIRE TIME
AND.
REALLY LISTENING TO EVERYONE'S
TESTIMONY IT'S.
IMPORTANT THAT OUR LEADERS ARE
ALSO LISTENING AND JUST WANTED
TO THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT.
WITH THAT WE WILL CLOSE TODAY
SOMEONE HERE